Bis dann, tschüss. So, mit fast geilem Heil.
Geilen Heil, wieso haben wir den geilen Heil?
Echo.
Du willst auch? Hallo Echo. Hallo, hallo, hallo, besser, viel besserer. Leif aus der Kloschüssel. Wo kommt das denn jetzt her?
Das muss jetzt iOS 9 sein, was hier irgendwie durch die Leitung geht.
Also die Meta-Ebene ist auch wirklich ganz schön groß geworden. Du solltest vielleicht jetzt mal langsam doch wieder diese Dämmmatten an die Wand machen.
Der Witz ist, wir hören das jetzt, glaube ich, gerade so im Echo, aber die anderen nicht.
Naja, ach so, nee, doch nicht. Chad, hört ihr das Echo?
Nein, die wissen wieder nicht, was Sache ist.
Hä, wo kommt das denn jetzt her?
Wir fangen gleich nochmal an.
Immer das gleiche mit dem Timme. Ich dachte, man ist fertig und dann dauert es immer noch.
Das nimmt uns doch wieder keiner ab. Man muss nachher wieder das Echo draufrechnen. Wo kommt denn das jetzt her?
Ich leg mich nochmal hin kurz.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen verwirrt. Besser?
Nee.
Weniger. Aber immer irgendwie noch blächern.
Was?
Was ist denn hier los?
Ah, jetzt ist es besser. Ja, das war jetzt bestimmt der lebhafteste Anfang, den wir seit längerer Zeit haben. Wollen wir nochmal anfangen?
Das schneidest du doch alles noch zusammen später.
Ich bin nur gerade etwas verwirrt, aber ich glaube, ich weiß schon, wer der Schuldige ist, aber ich spreche das jetzt mal nicht aus für den Fall, dass es doch anders ist und dann habe ich wieder etwas Böses gesagt und dann sind alle ganz stinkig. Wie auch immer, hier ist Freak Show und zwar die 161. Ausgabe mit frischem Internet in der Metaebene.
Riecht noch so komisch.
Das wäre in der Tat mal was. So was, jetzt lachen wir noch. Jetzt lachen wir noch und wir wissen alle.
In zwei Jahren wird uns das wieder aufs Brot geschmiert.
Ich würde dir gerne mal jetzt hier auf, wie heißt denn dieser Hersteller von diesen Duftbäumchen? Einfach noch mal kurz um das Spektrum der Geschmäcker und olfaktorischen Erlebnisse, die olfaktorische Erlebniswelt. Wie heißt denn diese Firma?
Olfaktorische Erlebniswelt?
Microsoft? Nein, diese Duftbäumhersteller.
Duft gibt es da einen besonderen.
Na, dieses Bäumchen halt, was überall alle haben.
Ja, machen das nicht 1000 Hersteller?
Das ist eine Marktduftbäumhersteller, jetzt kucke ich selber, komm. Wie heißt das? Little Trees? Wunderbaum, sagt der Chat.
Der Chat sagt Wunderbaum. wunderstrichbaum.de.
Alles klar, check ich mal aus.
Und was gibt es da?
Na ja, ich hoffe doch jetzt mal irgendwie Kirsche, Ananas, Banane.
Ja, aber gibt es da auch Internet.
Ach so, ja, Duftideen, gucken wir mal, Christiglein, uh, scheiße, da ist was Kackbraunes.
Wir googeln für sie.
Ah, das ist Leder, siehst du mal.
Es gibt Wunderbaum, Pure Steel, mit Stahlgeruch, Battle Gum.
Also für das nackte Metall könnte man das vielleicht benutzen.
Ja, Bare Metal.
Bare Metal-Geruch.
Na ja, du wolltest doch User Interface.
Sportfrische, was ist denn Sportfrische?
Das weiß keiner.
Ja, wie kurz nach dem Sport machen halt, ne?
Erdbeert, Zitrone.
Die sind so eklig, diese Dinger.
Fleck. Frühling.
Ja, der sieht ein bisschen, na ja. Also Internet gibt es noch nicht.
Oh Gott, das habe ich auch noch nie verstanden. Das sind wirklich so Produkte unserer Welt, wo man sich wirklich fragt.
Es gab doch hier irgendwie mal von diesem Memen-Conspiracy-Kiano, gab es auch irgendwie so eine Ausgabe, wo drauf stand, what if ex body spray was invented by women to identify the douchebags? Weil die riechen ja auch einfach alle so, weißt du, die riechst du auch schon so ein Kilometer vorher. Und dann denkst du so, warum bist du wirklich so ein Werbefollower, das nur weil der Typ da unter der Dusche so wahnsinnig gut aussieht und alle Frauen in der Werbung kriegt, dass dann die Nase sagt, riecht zwar komisch, aber das scheint ja das zu sein, worauf die Frauen stehen. Was man das denn kauft?
Das habe ich mal aktiv aus meiner potenziellen Produkte, das ist aktiv auf der Blacklist eingetragen.
Ganz weit weg, Mülltonne ganz unten.
Ja, also nicht nur wegen dieses Gestank, sondern auch wegen dieser furchtbar schrecklichen, sexistischen Werbung, die die da abziehen, das nervt mich so richtig. Also das macht mich so richtig aggressiv.
Das Testosteron spritzt nur so.
Ja, führt aber nicht zum Kauf. Ich hoffe, das hat jetzt irgendein Werbemanager gehört, aber das ist denen wahrscheinlich sowieso scheißegal. Ja, dass du das schon wieder nicht verstehst, das war mir klar. Entschuldigung, ich weiß, es ist ein bisschen hart. Na ja, das war eine Adaption wieder einmal. Ihr wisst doch, David macht auch von Zeit zu Zeit Entlehnungen von anderen Intros an andere Podcasts, die auch gehört werden von manchen Leuten.
Aber nicht von allen und deswegen erklärst du das jetzt mal.
Ja, welcher Podcast?
Es gibt noch andere Podcasts außer Freak Show?
Nein, das war der Podcast, der auf dem Camp nach uns hätte kommen sollen, zwei Tage später, aber nicht konnte.
Der weggeblitzt wurde.
Genau, methodisch inkorrekt. Wer den noch nicht kennt, der sucht sich das jetzt mal gleich in dem Podcast-Verzeichnis seiner oder ihrer Wahl heraus und hört da mal rein. Auch die heute glaube ich oder gestern frisch erschienene Folge ist auch wieder extrem dedikat. Vor allem geben die sich ja auch mit den Intros auch nochmal Mühe, muss man ja gleich nochmal dazu sagen. Also methodisch inkorrekt. Selbst wenn man jetzt so auf Physik und so und auf Wissenschaft und so Welt erklären und so nicht steht. Furchtbarlich, kann man, was ich mir eigentlich bei unserem Publikum kaum vorstellen kann, aber selbst wenn dem so wäre, also allein für die Intros kriegen sie ein Bienchen und für das Intro nach dem ausgefallenen Camp-Auftritt gibt es nochmal einen richtigen Bienchenschwarm. Weil der ist richtig geil, ich nehme da jetzt mal nichts vorweg, aber es haben sie einfach diese ganzen Vorkommnisse auf dem Camp wunderbar aufgearbeitet und ein großartiges, ich würde sagen, das ist das Intro des Jahres. Unsere laufen natürlich außer Konkurrenz, da lebt es sich sowieso immer am besten.
Ja, aber das heißt dann Turbobienenblitz-Award, also wenn du so richtig nicht nur Bienchen, sondern richtig mit Auszeichnung, dann Turbobienenblitz-Award. Ja, das ist irgendwie, das ist einfach immer mit Goldkante. Aber jetzt ist es auch hier mit dem Product-Placement, wo die Sponsoren uns ja wieder ordentlich... Wunderbaum, ja. Unser verstecktes Product-Placement. Weil es gibt ja auch keine schlechte Publicity, es gibt ja nur gute Publicity, selbst wenn wir jetzt Axe, Body Spray, Dissen, wie nix Gutes am Ende bleiben.
Doch es gibt schlechte Publicity, doch gibt's.
Ich glaub da nicht dran. Ja, ich auch nicht, aber...
Der Spruch geht immer, sagste. Wie auch immer, ihr werdet schon mitbekommen haben, Dennis ist da, Huckel ist da, Roddy ist da.
Da hast du schon was gesagt?
Leise, zurückheim, das Mikrofon... Ich erkenne dir das noch einmal jetzt mit dem Mikrofon. Da vorne, das ist eine gerichtete Niere und die musst du in deinen Mund...
Das letzte Mal diese Woche.
Besser ist jetzt auch nichts.
Das letzte Mal diese Woche?
Ist jetzt was besser?
Ja, es ist schon besser, aber du kannst es ruhig noch näher ranführen, um so ein bisschen mehr Pep in deinen Vadern zu bekommen.
Dann hast du mehr Attack beim Vadern, die Transienten sind irgendwie...
Ich kann dir auch noch ein bisschen Gain geben, wenn du möchtest.
Heute habe ich auch schon überlegt, ob es schon Software gibt, die ein möglichst authentisches Schnarchen generiert. Also es gibt ja so Apps, die der Regen und Donner und Wasser plätschern und was nicht, noch alles und irgendwie, das wäre eigentlich auch mal eine schöne Aufgabe, so organischen Schnarchen generiert und dann gleich die nächste Stufe VADER-Mod.
Für Leute, die zu gut schlafen?
Nee, ich weiß nicht.
Kannst du ohne Schnarchen nicht einschlafen?
Manchmal denke ich so in der Mittagspause mit Kollegen, denken wir uns halt so, wenn man so über Software und was es nicht alles für Scheiß gibt, und dann...
Was es für Scheiß noch nicht gibt?
Genau, und dann so, gibt es wohl schon Software, die ein möglichst organisches Schnarchen generiert?
Was wäre denn die Anwendung davon?
Das ist gar nicht die Fragestellung gewesen, ne?
Der wahre Hacker fragt nicht nach der Anwendung.
Also das Thema war eigentlich tatsächlich die Freak Show heute in der Mittagspause, weil ich dachte, oh, heute podcast, ich bin heute total müde, den ganzen Tag schon. Und dann meinte auch noch ein Kollege, naja, kannst du ja schnarchen, ach nee, dann kannst du ja auch eigentlich Schnarchen generieren lassen. Dann haben wir halt überlegt, gibt es überhaupt schon Software, die Schnarchen generiert? Aber sind wir auch nicht so spontan auf eine Lösung gekommen, wie beim Eisessen, Nachmittagessen? Aber falls ihr Schnarchen hört, ist es nicht generiert, sondern ich bin dann auf der Tischplatte zusammengeklappt.
Ich meine, es gibt ja schon Apps, die so alles Mögliche generiert, so Waldesrauschen und Nervosität haben.
Ja, das wäre genau so. Hat sich schon mal irgendein Entwickler hingesetzt und hat so gesagt, so, jetzt investiere ich mal einen Mann, Monat, Zeit in den besten Schnarchgenerator aller Zeiten.
Wie Ultimate Snorkel.
Es gibt doch solche Schlaflabore, wo sie die Leute so Schlafforschung betreiben, wo sie dann Leute halt so schlafen lassen und dabei messen. Da fällt auch bestimmt der eine oder andere Schnarcher auch an. Es wird ja mit dem Teufel zugehen, wenn die das nicht aufzeichnen. Vielleicht gibt es da eine riesige Schnarch-Datenbank, über die man halt mal…
Eine Schnarch-Bibliothek.
Im Chat wird schon der Cat-Per-Noise-Generator beworben. Das ist schon mal in die richtige Richtung. Aber naja, vielleicht finden wir das ja dann in den Kommentaren wieder. Nicht, dass wir das wirklich bräuchten, aber… Ja, sinnvolles Software.
Ich kann heute gar nichts einspielen, weil wenn ich jetzt was einspiele, dann kommt gleich wieder…
Echo.
Dann kommt gleich wieder Echo. Aber ich weiß immer noch nicht ganz genau, wo das eigentlich herkommt.
Frequency-Shaped Cat-Per-Noise-Generator. Gibt es aber auch scheinbar als App.
Nee, jetzt haben wir kein Echo mehr. Ich glaube, ich weiß, was das Problem ist. So, jetzt könnte ich den Per-Generator, aber das ist doch bestimmt mit Flash, oder?
Nee, das modernste Web-Technologie. Das klicken jetzt halt alle im Chat. Holen sich jetzt noch zum Freak Show ein bisschen Katzen.
Und das, obwohl eigentlich gar keine Bandbreite mehr vorhanden ist, ne? Now Playing? Ach so, warte mal, wo spielt der denn hin?
In den Stream, aber nicht in unsere Ohren.
Also ich höre nichts.
Das ist ja eine Enttäuschung auf ganzer Linie.
Ich weiß aber nicht, warum ich nichts höre, weil ich jetzt auf einmal hier in meinem gestellten Setup misstraue.
Dann fummelt da jetzt lieber nicht weiter drum herum und wir vertrauen der...
Doch, da kommt das. Wieso kriege ich denn das nicht? Was ist denn hier verdammt nochmal los?
Also wenn die Freak Show jetzt gleich unterbrochen wird, dann...
Ich werde das schon noch hinkriegen, keine Angst.
Hattest du nicht eigentlich auch...
Was?
Letztes Mal was erzählen wollen zum Thema NiceCast? Man hat es nicht gemacht?
NiceCast? Wollte ich was erzählen zu NiceCast?
Scheinbar nicht. Irgendwie hatten wir letztes Mal darüber gesprochen. Jetzt wo ich das gerade zwischendurch gesehen habe, fiel mir das wieder ein, aber dann hat sich das nie aufgelöst. Tja, wir haben gar keine Themen heute, ihr merkt schon.
Ist ja auch nichts passiert.
Okay, dann skipt das mit der Katze und lasst uns noch mal unsere Themen durchdingen. Durchdingen hier. Die ist für eine Katze.
Aber du kannst da hier irgendwie noch an den Frequenzen auch drehen.
Das heißt eine japanische Roboter-Katze.
Ich kann jetzt hier die Mitten noch ein bisschen.
Also ich weiß nicht, wer das da gemacht hat, aber eine Katze hat der sicher nicht gehabt.
Das klingt jetzt eher nach so einem Tiger oder so.
Na ja, okay, also es hat sich schon mal zumindest jemand mit Katzenschnoren beschäftigt sehr schwer. Jetzt runden wir das noch ab, indem wir sagen, hey Siri! Ich hab jetzt auf Arbeit einen Android, weil wir entwickeln ja jetzt so unsere Spiele erstmal Android First, weil dann...
Wirklich? Weil da hast du eigentlich Absatz, da kommt das Geld her.
Nee, nee, nee, die iOS-DOSer haben schon noch mehr Geld, aber du kannst halt einfach schneller deployen und mal Sachen testen und musst nicht immer die zwei Wochen warten. Und jetzt bin ich halt auch in so einem Projekt gelandet, wo Android First entwickelt wird und halt alles mit Unity. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, holst du jetzt auch mal so ein Android-Test-Device, das einfach auf dem Schreibtisch liegt und damit ich jetzt halt auch mal dieses Spiel dann auf dem Device testen kann. Und dann gehe ich so zu unserem kleinen Entwicklungsleiter, der uns dann die Androids gibt, und dann meinte der so, ja, welche habt ihr denn schon, weil du kriegst dann anderes, damit ihr schon mal so auf so einer gewissen Bandbreite von populären Devices testet. Und dann habe ich einen HTC One oder so bekommen. Und viele Hörer oder Twitter-Leute haben schon geschrieben, da hätte ich wohl den richtigen Glücks-Topf gegriffen, weil das wohl eins der schlimmeren Android-Interfaces wäre. Und ich kann euch sagen, du...
Du hast ja keine Vorstellung.
Ich hatte ja keine Ahnung, ne?
Ist es gar nicht so schlimm, oder was?
Das ist der Horror. Das ist...
Sprachlos ist er.
Das ist so die Fortschritte in User Experience und User Interface der letzten 20 Jahre in die Weichteile getreten. Das ist wirklich eine unfassbare Katastrophe. Aber die Hörer meinten alles, es ist HTC One. Oder diese HTC-Oberfläche, die besonders schlimm ist. Aber es ist wirklich... Also ich komme aus dem Staunen nicht mehr so...
Das ist auch kein Standard-Android.
Ja, scheinbar nur so halt.
Du weißt, dass wir jetzt schon 50 Kommentare im Blog haben.
Ja, ich sage ja deswegen auch die ganze Zeit dazu, HTC One oder wie auch immer, ne? Aber es ist krass. Also da kommt mir immer dieser Spruch, ich weiß nicht, wo ich den mal gelesen habe, aber wenn man noch nie ein sauberes Glas gesehen hat, dann sehen die schmutzigen Gläser alle total shiny oder das Beste, was es gibt, aus, ne? Und so kommt mir das auch vor bei den Leuten, die sagen, ja, also das ist ja hier wirklich, also da brauchen wir ja gar kein iPhone mehr. Ähm, wirklich unfassbar. Und das Gleiche hier mit dieser Android-Watch hat auch ein Kollege gehabt.
Diese große Runde?
Und du denkst dir, das darf doch nicht wahr sein.
Android Wear heißt das? Was darf denn nicht wahr sein?
Da zum Beispiel das User Interface besteht ja im Wesentlichen, die haben ja nicht diese Crown als Navigationsinterface. Und ich dachte mir, bei der Apple Watch habe ich jetzt nicht drüber nachgedacht. Ja, okay, Crown von mir aus, ne? Aber wenn du das benutzt, du bist halt die ganze Zeit mit deinem Finger über dem, was du eigentlich wischen willst oder sehen willst. Also du siehst, du bist die ganze Zeit mit deinem Navigationsorgan komplett über dieser User-Oberfläche. Oder dann gibt es so Sachen wie, du kannst halt in dem SDK, kannst du eine Text-Import-Box auch in einer Watch-App bauen. Und dann klickst du da drauf und dann kriegst du tatsächlich ein Eingabefeld, ohne dass es aber ein Eingabe-Interface ist. Nein, nein, das gibt es ja nicht, ne? Also du hast dann einfach eine Eingabe-Box mit einem blinking Cursor, kommst auch nicht mehr raus.
Ja, aber kannst du nicht auch Spracheingabe machen? So wie bei der Apple Watch?
Also er meinte, nee. Übrigens der Kalender ist auch irgendwie wohl ganz schlimm. Das würde Tim zur Weisgut schreiben. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie bin ich denn auf Android eigentlich gerade gekommen?
Weiß ich nicht, über Schnarchen und Schnuchern sind wir da hingeschrieben.
Ach genau, das ist HeySiri und jetzt ist genau mal, jetzt habe ich es wieder. Der rote Faden kommt zurück. Das HTC One ist nämlich auch rot. Nee Quatsch, ich sitze halt die ganze Zeit vorm Rechner und da liegt dieses Telefon und immer wenn ich OK sage, springen dieses scheiß Telefon an. Weil es heißt OK Google oder was? Aber es geht schon bei OK los. Also ich sag immer wenn ich irgendwie so mit einem Kollegen vorm Rechner sitze und Pair-Programm mache und dann irgendwie so OK, jetzt lass uns mal da und dann so blibblibblip und dann geht da irgendwie das Telefon am Schleuchel und ich krieg's auch in dieser HTC-Uberfläche. Also ich weiß nicht, wo man das deaktiviert. Aber das ist jetzt so mein ständiger Begleiter, deswegen, weil ich gerade hier Hey Siri meinte und so sorry OK Google, an die Hörer. Das war eigentlich nur so eine kleine Überleitung zum Thema, wie stelle ich das aus? Das blubbert dann halt irgendwie und geht auch wieder aus.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist ja dann bei Siri jetzt auch nicht anders.
Ja, ja, ne, ne, aber das Problem ist oder sagen wir so bei Hey Siri, also Hey beim Pair-Programm, sagt man halt nicht so oft wie OK, ne?
Hey, hey, Siri, hey, Siri, hey.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht so genau, was man beim Pair-Programming...
Du hast noch nie gepair-programmt wahrscheinlich, ne?
Ne, ich bin ja alt schul.
Ist nicht extrem-programming auch ziemlich alt schul? Das war auch schon so, was ich ja halt...
Ich hab vielleicht schon mal, ich hab schon Pair-Programming gemacht, da hieß das bloß nicht so.
Und da gab's auch noch kein Telefon, was auf OK anspringt.
Man saß halt gemeinsam vor dem Rechner, weil es halt nur einen gab.
So war die Situation damals. Ja, ich hab auch letztens einen kleinen Vortrag gehalten, ich mach hier voll Themenjumping, in der Ruby User Group zum Thema, was Hacken ist und Hacker und so weiter. Und da hab ich ja auch so ein paar Projekte mal so vorgestellt, jetzt nicht unbedingt so Matrix und irgendwie alles unsicher, sondern halt irgendwie auch so kunstmäßig. Dann hab ich natürlich ein paar Art-Com-Projekte auch ausgegraben und da ist mir das Urban Jungle Pack wieder unter die Finger gekommen. Und da gibt es ja zwei Fotos, das eine und das andere.
Ich muss das ein bisschen weiter ausholen, weil ich den Kontext kenne, aber der Rest nicht.
Ja, also ihr müsst euch vorstellen, was war das, 1999 oder so?
Also erstmal der Laden, wir haben aber bei Art Plus-Com schon mal gesprochen.
Art-Com haben wir schon mehrfach gesprochen, Terravision und so weiter. Und das Urban Jungle Pack, also ihr müsst euch vorstellen, die haben sich dann 1999 mal hingesetzt und gedacht, na Mensch, wir haben jetzt so das erste mobile Internet, wir haben jetzt irgendwie Computer, die nicht mehr so groß sind wie eine Bierkiste, sondern die jetzt auch an den Rucksack passen. Es gab die ersten Display-Brillen, und es gab GPS-Receiver für den Computer und da könnte man noch jetzt alles mal zusammenkombinieren in eine unglaublich großartige, aussehende Installation. Da müssen wir gleich mal Bilder noch rein posten hier in den Chat. Und dann läuft man halt so durch die Stadt und kriegt halt sozusagen schon ein Augmented Reality. Und dann denken sich die Leute, naja, okay, das klingt ja verdammt wie Google Glasses, aber das war halt 99 und natürlich sah das groß und klobig aus, aber ich fand halt so die alten Art-Com-Projekte teilweise wirklich ganz besonders fantastisch, weil die einfach eben so vor ihrer Zeit waren, obwohl die eigentlich ja nur das kombiniert haben, was es halt zu der Zeit gerade gab, aber wo noch niemand quasi eins und eins und eins zusammengezählt hat, sondern vielleicht nur eins und eins.
Wenn überhaupt.
Wenn überhaupt, genau. Und jetzt muss ich mal, ob man dieses Urban Jungle Pack mal eben findet, ich finde, das ist auf der neunen...
Der Ding ist schon im Chat.
Ah ja, perfekt. Und da gab es ja auch zwei Versionen von, glaube ich, die eine, die noch richtig klobig war mit diesem Bobblebee. Ach so, das ist jetzt hier... Ach nee, das ist jetzt bei spiegel.de, da gibt es jetzt nicht so viele Brotes. Aber genau, das eine, diese große, klobige Datenbrille hier, das sieht wirklich einfach großartig aus. Und dann später gab es das ja noch ein bisschen kompakter im Bobblebee-Rucksack-Format.
Bobblebee?
Na hier, dieser Packer-Rucksack.
Ninja Teenage Mutant Turtles-Rucksack.
Genau, der beste Nerd-Rucksack der Welt.
Ist er das wirklich immer noch?
Wie heißt er?
Bobblebee, also mit nur einem B, B-O-B-L-E, nee ohne E sogar, einfach nur Bobblebee. Ja, das ist so eine, glaube ich, schwedische Rucksack-Marke, die gibt es halt auch schon seit den 90ern, mindestens. Und die machen so eine Hardsharn-Rucksack. Und ich meine, wir haben hier in dem Podcast bestimmt schon ein paar Mal über Rucksäcke geredet, hier Axio und Incase und wie sie nicht alle heißen.
Apropos, da habe ich auch noch was zu.
Und ich hatte eigentlich jetzt so ziemlich alle Nerd-Rucksäcke schonmal durch und die waren dann auch nach kürzester Zeit durch, vor allen Dingen so mit Reißverschluss kaputt, das ist so das Üblichste, was kaputt geht oder da, wo der Laptop drin sitzt, dann sind dann irgendwann die Ecken durchgewetzt, weil wenn man jeden Tag so als Nerd mit fetten Gier unterwegs ist, dann machen die doch irgendwie schnell schlapp und der Bobblebee ist tatsächlich der einzige Rucksack, der jetzt schon über drei Jahre im Dauereinsatz ist und keinerlei Schäden nennenswerte aufweist und das Geile ist vor allen Dingen, er hat keinen Reißverschluss, das heißt, er kann auch keinen Reißverschluss kaputt gehen. Er ist wasserdicht, kann man noch irgendwie Sachen ranklemmen, also das Konzept ist halt auch, dass du da verschiedenste Aufbauten noch ran machen kannst.
Das heißt, den du hast, den ich gerade auf dem Screen habe?
Genau, der Megalero, was auch immer, genau. Und da gibt es halt so Aufbauten, also da sind ja lauter Schnallen und Öse noch dran, den kannst du auch fast so im Tracking-Rucksack machen mit so einem Aufbau. Genau, ich habe den Phantom-Matt oder Hacker-Schwarz, wie es so schön heißt. Also wer mal einen Rucksack haben will, der einfach wirklich lange hält und alle Strapazen mitmacht und vor allen Dingen ein ganz geiles Feature, wenn man einen Flug macht, der nur Handgepäck benötigt, ihr kennt das vielleicht. Ihr sitzt so im Flieger, ihr habt schon eure Tasche ins Handgepäck gelegt, dann kommt noch so Lars, millt einer rein mit so einem Koffer und macht so das Fach auf und rammt den sozusagen noch so mit allem, was so geht, rein, rüttelt und ihr habt vielleicht gerade noch irgendwelche Kekse oder so im Rucksack oder in der Tasche und denkt euch so, nein, vorsichtig und mit dem Rucksack, da crumbled nichts, da bleiben die Kekse ganz, ja, also da, wenn da was kaputt geht, dann ist das das andere Stück im Handgepäckfach.
Mir kommt ja immer so schmal und flach vor, dass da so viel nicht reinpasst.
Ja, der kann relativ flach sein, aber wenn du den hier...
Weil der unten so dünn zuläuft, verschwinden da nicht Dinge, die man nie wieder findet.
Also, guck mal, der kann hier, der hat hier so noch...
Ja, der faltet sich so ein bisschen aus, aber unten ist er ja dann auf jeden Fall immer eng und findet man da nicht irgendwie alte, kriegt man da überhaupt schnell noch am Flughafen mal eben alle Drogen rausgeschützt oder...
Naja, hier unten sind halt Löcher, ne? Also wenn das da durchfällt, dann fallen die Drogen auch raus einfach.
Hier unten sind Löcher. Du hast einen Rucksack, wo unten Löcher drin sind?
Naja, das ist, sagen wir mal, nur für die kleinen Krümel und Flüssigkeiten, ne?
Ach, und das ist auch bewusst so?
Ich glaube schon, ja. Aber den kannst du auch durchspülen, da bleibt dann kein Wasser drin. Ne, aber ganz ehrlich, das Geile ist auch noch an dem Rucksack, du kannst halt die Hartschale auswechseln, du kannst die Rückseite auswechseln, du kannst ganz viele Teile an diesem Ding sozusagen auswechseln. Der besondere Clou ist halt, es ist ein zertifizierter Rückenprotektor. Das heißt, so für die Motorradfahrer oder, ich meine, die haben doch auch Skifahrer und so drauf, aber eigentlich ist es auch so ein Motorradfahrer-Rucksack, weil wenn du halt dich hinpackst und den Rucksack aufsetzt, dann hast du zumindest noch eine Chance, dass dein Rücken auch noch heile bleibt.
Ich bin ja nicht überzeugt, weil wenn ich da so ein hart Schalen-Dings auf meinem Rücken hab, also harte Schale auf dem Rücken, wäre wie ein Panzer, aber sie steht ja voll ab.
Das heißt, du kannst nicht... Nee, die Schale wird zerbrechen. Also das ist die Rückwand dann eher.
Ja, wenn du da lauter Zeug drin hast, ich weiß nicht.
Na ja, egal. Auf jeden Fall, also wird er seine Zertifizierung schon irgendwoher bekommen haben, egal. Nichtsdestotrotz, wie gesagt, ist der einzige Rucksack, der bei mir komplett Dauerbetrieb ausgehalten hat und der wird jetzt echt nicht schonend behandelt und war seinen nicht geringen Preis für mich total wert. Ist sogar hier vom TÜV Rheinland zertifiziert.
Ja, auf jeden Fall macht er nicht zu viele Illusionen.
Okay, dann kann ich gleich auch noch mal einen Rucksack placken. Und zwar auf Kickstarter gibt es jetzt die zweite Generation des Riot-Bags. Da habe ich damals die erste Generation schon erworben. Das Geile an dem Rucksack ist es wirklich ein Stadt-Rucksack. Und zwar, wenn man den auf hat, also wenn der auf dem Sitz, genau, Riot, wie war das? Revolution in User-Thinking oder so ähnlich.
Noch eine dritte Zeit.
Völlig bekloppte Abkürzung. Wenn man den auf dem Rücken hat, dann kann da niemand rein.
Ach, weil der sozusagen nach innen aufgeht?
Genau, weil die Reißverschlüsse sind alle so angebracht, dass wenn du den auf hast, dann kommst du nicht mehr ran an den Rucksack. Also nur noch da an diese Tasche, wo man die Wasserflasche von außen ran stecken kann.
Das hat auch Nachteile, ne?
Ja, man muss ihn absetzen, wenn man voran will.
Ja, wenn ich sonst mit meiner Freundin einkaufen bin, dann irgendwie, steckt man das noch hinten in den Rucksack, dann geht das nicht.
Es ist halt für Singles. Für Leute, die alleine durch den urbanen Dschungel sich durchkämpfen und keine Frau da haben.
Das ist kein Einkaufsrucksack, aber der ist schon ganz cool.
Das ist ja schon ein relativ ausgedachter Use-Case.
Okay, passt da ein 15 Zoll rein?
Ja.
Sogar zwei.
Und fällt der seitwärts raus, oder muss man den nach oben rausziehen?
Nein, sie haben in der zweiten Generation, du musst den nach oben rausziehen, sie haben in der zweiten Generation sogar noch so Gummibänder angebracht, dass wenn du ihn aufklappst, dass der eben nicht rausfällt, sondern erst wenn du die Gummibänder zur Seite tust, dass dann der Laptop rauskommt.
Bei mir ist schon zweimal mein Laptop seitwärts rausgefahren, weil ich vergessen habe, zugemacht zu machen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Muss man das immer wieder Crowdfunding, bevor man das kaufen kann, oder was?
Ja, ich denke mal, wenn das Crowdfunding von der zweiten Version durch ist, dann wird es den auch wieder normal zu kaufen geben.
Wie weit ist denn der?
Na ja, der ist schon über Funding-Goal, hat aber noch 21 Tage. Da ich den ersten schon habe, habe ich da irgendwie die Mail gekriegt.
Erwirbt man dann mit dem Crowdfunding gleich ein, oder was?
Also ich habe so einen Super Early Bird noch gekriegt. Aber die sind all gone, genau. Du kriegst jetzt nur noch den normalen irgendwie. Also es gibt den irgendwie in 10 Liter und in 15 Liter und den grauen in schwarz. Also vier Stück insgesamt.
Und welchen hast du dir geklickert?
Den großen, den 15 Liter in schwarz.
Und du hattest auch vorher schon 15 Liter?
Na ich hatte vorher den erste Generation, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel Liter der hat. Das haben die damals nicht dazu gesagt. Aber er müsste ungefähr genauso groß sein.
Und wie lange hast du den ersten schon?
Und er hat was auch ganz Cooles, er hat in dem in den Schulterträger noch mal Taschen drin, wo du die Fahrkarte rein machen kannst. Beim öffentlichen Nahverkehr, das ist nämlich ganz praktisch, wenn dann die Kontrollettis kommen, kann man die direkt rausholen.
Du hast eine Fahrkarte?
Ich habe eine Fahrkarte.
Machst du das nicht mit der App jetzt mittlerweile alles? Ich habe mir letztens dieses Touch-and-Travel-Dingsbums installiert. Ich benutze gar keine Fahrkarte mehr.
Jetzt bleibt doch mal bei dem Rucksack. Wir können uns gerne noch über Fahrkarten unterhalten.
Aber wie lange hast du den denn schon, deine ersten Generation?
Ein halbes Jahr ungefähr.
Okay, das ist also noch kein Langzeit-Belastungstest.
Und der hat auch so im Langzeit-Belastungstest die erste Generation. Na ja, was war die erste Generation?
Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, ob du das eben schon gesagt hast, aber mir wird gerade klar, dass diese Aufklapp-Technik ja noch einen anderen Vorteil hat, weil sich das Ding ja dann im Prinzip wie ein Koffer öffnet.
Ja, genau.
Das heißt, du machst den Deckel einfach auf und kannst dann wirklich alles von oben, also nicht von oben, sondern wie halt ein flachgelegter, ah, da ist er ja sogar, er hat ihn jetzt in der Hand.
Also was ich auch ganz schön finde, ist, dass der unten, ja, wie gesagt, die erste Generation, schonmal ordentlich.
Ah, unten ist er...
Und ein ordentliches Material, den kannst du also auch mal...
Auch mal in eine Suppe stellen.
In eine Suppe stellen. Und, ja, also jetzt, da, erste Generation, gibt's so zwei Taschen außen, wo man was reinstecken kann. Ich hab da einmal einen Schirm drin. Das ist ein bisschen sinnlos, dass es zwei sind, weil ich nicht zwei brauche, aber...
Stört aber auch nicht, weil...
.dass man später nichts verloren, ne?
Ja, genau.
Und was ist jetzt an der zweiten Version besser als an der ersten?
Also wie gesagt, zum Beispiel, dass es mehr, dass es Stifthalter gibt und mehr Taschen innen, und dass es eben diese beiden Gummibänder gibt, die den Laptop vom Rausfallen bewahren, was in der ersten Generation noch nicht ist. Das ist aber so für einen normalen täglichen Stadtbetrieb groß genug, meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, vor allem, ich bin jetzt gerade echt am Durchatmen, weil ich habe nämlich immer das Problem, dass ich so einen... Ich brauche halt irgendwie einen guten Rucksack für so ein, zwei, drei Tagesreisen, also wo ich sozusagen so das notwendige Maß an Wechselwäsche etc. dabei haben sollte, aber halt auch nochmal so ein Elektro-Teil.
Aber Tim spart immer ein Wäsche, weil der Elektro-Kram so viel Platz braucht.
Ne, es gibt dann halt einfach nicht so viele Rucksäcke, die wirklich so beiden Anforderungen gleichzeitig gerecht werden, aber der ist ganz schön wobbly, ne?
Also ich kann dir sagen, mit dem wobbly geht das wunderbar.
Ja, es ist jetzt kein Hartschalenkoffer wie andere Rucksäcke.
Hol du mal Version 2, dann gucke ich mir das nochmal an, weil so richtig überzeugen tut mich das jetzt nicht.
Genau, und oben ist die Tasche. Das ist, wie gesagt, also erste Generation. Aber ich habe da auch eine lange E-Mail hingeschrieben mit, weiß ich nicht, sieben oder neun Punkten, was mich alles so stört. Und einiges haben sie gefixt. Ja, zum Beispiel, was ein relativ bekanntes Problem ist, sind diese komischen Ecken unten am Bänzel, die irgendwie so ein bisschen pieksen. Wie sie da drauf gekommen sind, weiß ich nicht. Aber das haben sie auf jeden Fall gefixt. Und es sind vor allen Dingen so Materialsachen. Also du hast halt zwei Reißverschlüsse ein für die große Klappe und einen noch mal die Tasche oben drüber, so für Geld und anderen Kleinkram. Und was mich da so ein bisschen gestört hat, war, dass die Reißverschluss-Dinger zum Auf- und Zumachen ziemlich genau gleich sind. Und man dann immer auf Anhieb nicht den richtigen in der Hand hat.
Ich finde hier auch die Verarbeitung gerade nicht so geil.
Ich hoffe, der zweite ist da besser. Aber ansonsten bin ich da bisher ganz zufrieden mit.
Was ich jetzt hier zu diesem Bobblebee noch sagen würde, ist, also der hat ja unten diese komische Welle drin, wo auch immer alle Leute fragen, warum ist denn die da so? Und der hat auch noch tausend Ösen und Laschen dran und du kannst halt da eben noch diverse Sachen so ranbauen. Zum Beispiel dieser Use-Case für, okay jetzt fahre ich mal ein paar Tage weg und will Sachen oder Isomatte oder zum Beispiel, ich packe mal noch eins in den Chat, ein Accessoire, was man zum Beispiel da ranbauen kann. Ich glaube, das ist auch das Modell, was du dann quasi so auch für unterwegs als kleine Tasche irgendwie abklippen kannst. Das kann dann halt eben unten so in diese Welle mit rein und von denen gibt es halt so ein paar so eine Anbauten quasi bis hin zu so einer fast, also ich habe zum Beispiel so ein Netz, da packe ich manchmal einen Helm rein oder Regenjacke oder so Zeug, was jetzt nicht unbedingt in den Rucksack rein muss. Und das ist halt das Coole noch an dem Rucksack, durch diese Laschen sind die halt auch bombenfest, fällt auch beim Motorradfahren bei 180 Sachen nicht ab. Also quasi eine Hüfttasche, die man sich dann da in den Rucksack, in dieses Ding da Genau, und dann hier weiter, dann gibt es noch dieses Teil, das klicke ich dir auch nochmal kurz in den Chat, da kannst du dir dann quasi noch so richtig irgendwie die Gepäckrolle ran schnallen und ja, das ist dann sozusagen noch die Antwort auf so Flexibilitätswünsche. Aber was ich auf jeden Fall empfehlen kann, wenn ihr euch so ein Bobble Bee holt, kauft euch den nicht mit dem Gummibandverschluss, sondern den mit dem Ratschverschluss, weil der Ratschverschluss ist einfach total großartig. Gerade zum Beispiel für Motorradfahrer ist das super, weil man braucht keine Handschuhe ausziehen, um den Rucksack aufzumachen. Diese Gummibänder funktionieren zwar auch, aber der Ratschverschluss ist einfach 1000 mal geiler. Was meinst du mit Ratsch? Na hier, da siehst du ja den Verschluss. Für die Kappe oben ist so ein Gummibindel, da um diese Links. Und wenn du nochmal den Link von vorhin anklickst, den meinen Hacker Schwarzen.
Ich muss hier auch mal für die Show-Notizen mitschreiben, ne?
So hat es doch im Chat hier den Hacker Schwarzen verlinkt. Ich kann den einfach nochmal anklicken.
Hier, Phantom.
Genau, der hat da so einen Verschluss. Ich kann dir das ja hier vor Ort auch nochmal vorführen. Also der ist halt, hast hier eine so eine Schnalle. Der ist auch unkaputt, weil da war schon Sand drin, da war Wasser, alles Mögliche und der ist hältbombenfest und kann es halt wie gesagt mit Handschuhen oder mit einem Ellbogen bedienen zur Not.
Das ist gut.
Der ist deutlich besser und den kann man aber auch wieder da siehst, der ist auch abschraubbar. Falls ihr auch einen habt mit dem Gummi-Benzel, dann könnt ihr den Verschluss auch einzeln sozusagen noch wechseln. Weiß gar nicht, wo ich den gekauft habe. Doch, ich glaube, ich habe den bei denen im Online-Shop gekauft. Die haben auch tatsächlich auch noch ein paar andere Modelle. Das ist halt so das Modell, wofür sie bekannt sind. Die haben auch noch ein paar andere Rucksäcke. Vielleicht ist da eigentlich auch mittlerweile was Schöne, also noch irgendwie andere schöne Modelle. Ich glaube, es gibt einen kleineren davon noch. Und den gibt es einmal mit so der normalen Kappe obendrauf und einmal mit der Super-Wasserdichten, die dann halt auch fürs Motorradfahren taugt. Naja, das ist auf jeden Fall, warum ich sonst eigentlich nie mehr über Rucksäcke geschrieben habe, weil ich seit mehr als drei Jahren mit dem ganz zufrieden bin. Das hat auch echt lange gedauert, bis ich einen gefunden hatte. Früher waren ja, was waren früher immer so die Nerd-Rucksäcke, das waren E-Specs tatsächlich, oder? Was waren früher so diese Nerd-Rucksäcke, oder Tatonka, nee, irgendwie, es gab doch...
Also ich habe E-Specs, so ein uraltes Ding, aber der ist inzwischen auch ganz schön durch. Alle schneilen, diese Plastik-Dinger, so sind schon durchgebrochen.
Ja, aber der ist halt auch...
Gibt's die noch?
Den hast du auch früher hier in der Sendung schon mal bestellt, auch sogar, und dann nächste Folge darüber geredet und so, oder?
Genau, aber da sind halt zum Beispiel auch die Reißverschlüsse irgendwann kaputtgegangen, obwohl die schon so als extra total super stabil und so...
Die Reißverschlüsse sind bei mir okay, aber die, die schnallen, mit denen man den so zusammenfüllen kann, sind alle kaputtgegangen.
Nee, die gibt's vielleicht nicht.
Da ganz oben.
Nee, es kann tatsächlich sogar sein, dass es die gar nicht mehr gibt.
Mir war nämlich auch irgendwas warm mit dem Laden.
Aber die würde ich jetzt auch tatsächlich nicht mehr empfehlen. Also, den einen Nerd-Rucksack, den ich immer noch ganz schick finde, ist der von Incase. Da gibt es halt auch so einen Notebook-Rucksack und da gab es ja auch eine Variante, wo damals sogar das 17 Zoll reingepasst hat.
Das 17 Zoll.
Na ja, das gute alte 17 Zoll.
Ich habe noch einen von diesen Australiern. Wie heißen die? Mit diesem Rastlermännchen da drauf. Da passte damals das 17 Zoll auch rein, aber eher theoretisch. Also praktisch nicht wirklich benutzbar.
Und bei Eastpac gibt es so viele, dass man nicht weiß, welcher der richtige wäre.
Genau, der Icon-Backpack, so heißt der jetzt von Incase. Oh, das haben sie ja auch noch mal geändert. Was ist denn das jetzt hier für ein Konzept? Wie klappt der sich denn auf?
Link or didn't happen. Ich frage mich, warum gibt es eigentlich keinen Spezialisten für sowas. Wie ein Spezialisten für so Nerd-Rucksäcke. Was hast du jetzt?
Das ist einer der modernen Klassiker der Nerd-Rucksäcke. Das ist aber jetzt auch schon mal eine neue Version, weil da gibt es so ein Bild, wo der so komisch aufklappt. Aber den finde ich halt sehr schick und der ist auch ziemlich gut verarbeitet. Also ich hatte eine frühere Version schon mal und die war auch richtig gut.
Sieht aber ein bisschen bissennässig aus, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Vor allem von außen ist anscheinend gar nichts zu regeln. Ich will ja nicht immer meinen ganzen Rucksack auspacken, nur weil ich meine Kleinigkeit irgendwie rein oder raus machen will. Ich habe gerne schon auch so Außentaschen und auch verschiedene, damit ich in...
Ja, also er hat hinten diese Laptop-Tasche, dann vorne noch mal so Dokumenten, was auch immer Tasche. Und dann hast du auch links und rechts, also nee. Oder mittendrin halt auch immer noch so Stift-Täschchen und so Zeug. Der sieht jetzt auf jeden Fall anders aus als ich den... Den haben sie auch irgendwie überarbeitet scheinbar oder verändert. Da unten diese komische Wulst, die dann beim Aufklappen entsteht, die finde ich jetzt auch nicht so charmant ehrlich gesagt. Schade eigentlich. War doch mal so gut.
Sieht auf jeden Fall ganz elegant aus. Hat so ein bisschen was von so Weltraum, Paketentreibstoff.
Genau, deswegen fand ich den eigentlich auch... Das war halt so damals einer der wenigen Rucksäcke, die halt nicht scheiße aussah. Es gibt ja auch diese Nerd-Rucksäcke von Jack Wolfskin oder was auch immer mit tausenden Schnallen und Laschen und Henkeln und Labels und was nicht alles dran.
Ich hatte, es ist jetzt leider schon zu lange her, als dass ich mir jetzt das hätte merken können, aber ich hatte vor ein paar Monaten, schon über ein halbes Jahr her, habe ich auch noch mal ein bisschen geforscht. Und vor allem grundsätzlich, ich kann jetzt leider keine Marken nennen, aber ich hatte so ein paar Sachen gefunden, was ich halt extrem cool finde, sind halt Rucksäcke. Und das war damals bei dem Axio, glaube ich, auch so, die einfach so, wie sie geschnitten sind, sich sehr weit ausklappen lassen. Also jetzt bei deinem Riot gerade, Roddy, gefiel mir halt, man klappt halt auf und man hat so, alles liegt so vor einem. Und die Alternative bei den Rucksäcken, die halt nach hinten aufgehen, ist, dass eben die Reißverschlüsse möglichst tief gehen.
Und alles auf der Straße liegt.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Bei dem Axio war das zum Beispiel so, du machst die Reißverschlüsse wirklich bis nach unten auf. Wenn die dann halt aufgehen, haben die dann aber so heute, die halt sozusagen sich so aufspannen. Aber du kannst die Dinge halt sehr weit aufklappen, sodass du eben an Dinge, die unten sind, rankommst. Viele Taschen sind halt einfach immer so Stopfleber-Taschen.
Der Vorgrahr-Rucksack.
Und das finde ich einfach extrem unpraktisch. Und vielleicht werde ich demnächst mal wieder ein bisschen auf Suche gehen, ob in dem Laden, wo ich das gefunden hatte, ob es sie da vielleicht noch gibt. Ich konnte mich in dem Moment nicht dazu durchringen, das zu kaufen. Aber naja, das ist auf jeden Fall gut. Was ich auch schon mal erwähnt hatte, aber wenn man jetzt hier sowieso gerade bei Taschen und so weiter...
Oh, hast du dich vertippt bis jetzt auf der Telekom.
Das habe ich doch schon ausgeschaltet, ihr Penner.
Das ist echt Arsch.
Hier DNS-Weiterleitungsschnicke. Das habe ich natürlich sofort als erstes ausgeschaltet heute. Ist natürlich immer noch an oder wieder. Egal, bleiben wir bei den Taschen. Wer sich jetzt hier gerade inspiriert fühlt und selber ein bisschen auf die Suche gehen will, wie auch so viele andere, das Problem, dass die in Europa nicht zu kriegen sind oder zumindest sehr schwierig zu kriegen sind oder nur online kaufbar sind, aber Turbobienen. Ich habe ja so die eine Tasche von Turbobienen schon vor Jahren schon mal drüber erzählt, finde ich immer noch super, weil die einfach fantastisch verarbeitet ist und unglaublich praktisch. Muss man kurz mal gucken, ob das Modell, was ich habe, naja, da gibt es so alles Mögliche. Also die haben so richtig Rucksäcke, die haben so Köpfe und Umhängetaschen. Oh, die haben auch richtig viel Neues. Da müsste man sich gleich noch mal ein bisschen umschauen. Genau, das hier ist mein Restretto. Also wer so iPad-Size, MacBook Air unterwegs ist, gleich mal hier den Link in den Chat werfen. Also die Restretto ist einfach von daher eine super Tasche. Vor allem, ich habe so die erste Generation und die ist halt auch sehr viel verbessert worden. Also die Probleme, die ich mit meiner eigentlich noch habe, die sind bei dem Modell offensichtlich komplett behoben. Das ist halt so eine vertikale Tasche. Also man hat nicht so ein breites Ding an sich herum baumeln, sondern das Ding ist halt quasi ab.
Man hat nicht so ein breites Ding an sich herum baumeln.
Nein, du kennst doch diese großen Taschen, diese großen Laptop-Taschen so. Und da hast du quasi den Rechner immer quer neben dir, was überhaupt keinen Sinn macht in meinen Augen. Und hier stecke ich das Ding halt einfach von oben rein. Hier passt ein 11 Zoll sehr bequem rein und auch ein 13 Zoll passt hier glaube ich noch sehr bequem rein. Beziehungsweise gibt es unter Umständen auch noch verschiedene Größenvarianten. Und die Details. Also erstmal schon allein, was ja häufig ein Problem ist bei vielen Sachen, so dieser Shoulderstrap, also womit du das Ding halt trägst. Der ist halt dann oben so stabil, aber weich. Also auch wenn du mal so richtig viel reingepackt hast, das Ding ist schwer, dann hast du nicht gleich so Stream in der Haut. Ordentliche Karabinerhaken, die wirklich mit zu den Besten gehören, was ich im Bereich Karabinerhaken schon mal in der Hand hatte. Also es ist einfach super sturdy. Hier ist auch noch nix, auch nur ansatzweise ausgerissen. Das finde ich auch bemerkenswert. Ich habe das wirklich mehrere Jahre im Einsatz. Und es ist nicht eine einzige Naht, es ist ja auch nur ansatzweise defekt. Das finde ich schon geil. Also Topf Wien Restretto ist eine ganz tolle Tasche, ist bloß sehr schwierig zu bekommen. Und muss man sich halt irgendwie aus den USA schicken lassen. Also am besten mit mehreren Leuten zusammentun.
Also ich finde die Namensgebung sehr schön. Den Restretto gibt es in der Farbkombination Aubergine-Wasabi.
Oh ja, die haben echt interessante neue Farben hier. Na gut, ich habe ihn mir natürlich in Schwarz geholt. Ist ja klar.
Ist ja klar.
Das ist jetzt Black Steel.
Ein Shopping-Bag.
Also es ist einfach geil, weil du auch alles schnell im Zugriff hast. So dieser eine Clip, zack, Rechner raus, Rechner rein. Passt einfach für viele Sachen und es ist einfach mal fantastisch. Fantastisches Ding und ich ärgere mich, dass es das hier nicht gibt. Ich habe gehört in anderen Podcasts, dass wohl auch das, war das jetzt dieser Co-Pilot oder war das dieses Ego? Ich glaube, dass dieser Co-Pilot wohl auch eine geniale Sache ist. Wobei der sieht mir persönlich schon wieder so ein bisschen zu sehr nach, weiß auch nicht, der macht mich irgendwie auch nicht so an.
Der sieht so aus, als könnte man ihn in der Mitte mit dem Reißverschluss in zwei Hälften zippen.
Ja, also die haben einfach, das ist das, was ich an Turbobienen so mag und was ich so bisher auch noch nirgendswo gesehen habe. Bei denen ist wirklich das Placement jedes Reißverschlusses und jeder Tasche enorm durchdacht. Und wenn die jetzt hier so ein Ding haben, wo so ganz merkwürdige Reißverschlusskombinationen sind, dann hat das bestimmt irgendeinen Grund. Das müsste man sich nochmal genauer anschauen. Ah ja, doch, du kannst hier wirklich so auseinander. Egal, da müsste ich jetzt selber erst mal rumklicken. Klickt mal rum, Turbobienen, tolle Sache. Gibt es hier auch Videos, Pippa Po, schau ich mir vielleicht selber nochmal an. Ja, klar, aber geht halt auch nicht kaputt.
Mit Shipping und Zeug ist das wahrscheinlich relativ heftig.
Ja, aber ich bereue nichts. Diese Tasche, ich habe nicht auch nur ein Modell gefunden bei irgendeinem Hersteller, der hier in Europa verkauft, die auch nur dieses Konzept dieser Tasche gehabt hätten. Also es gibt einfach keine guten A4-Vertikal-Taschen. Habe ich nicht gefunden. Vielleicht gibt es mittlerweile irgendwo was. So viel zum Thema Taschen und Rucksäcke. Das war ja der eigentliche Grund, warum wir heute hier zusammengekommen sind.
Da muss ja auch ein iPad Pro rein passen.
Ein Übergang, ein Übergang. Ja, lass mal über Apple reden.
Irgendjemand muss ja.
Lass mal über alles Mögliche außer Max reden. Ja, es war wieder so eine Schlüsselnote. Habt ihr das gesehen?
So gut es ging mit diesem Streaming, das geht ja.
Bei mir lief der Stream top.
Bei mir lief der Butterweich.
Ich hatte ausnahmsweise auch kein Problem, außer dass mitten drin der DSL-Router sich rebooten musste. Also in dem Moment mal nicht meiner. Kam dann aber grazil hoch und hat nur diese eine Demo von irgendeinem cheesy Gesundheits-App übersprungen.
Das war die App, wo ich mir an manchen Stellen gedacht habe, wie machen die das?
Ich habe es ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal nachgeschaut, was war denn da überhaupt das Thema.
War das das hier mit Meniskus live durchschneiden und den Patienten zeigen, wo es wehtut und so?
Nein, das war das mit der Uhr und dass der Arzt dann die Uhr hat. Und die Patientin hält dann irgendwie, ich glaube, ihr iPhone an den Bauch. Und dann kann der Arzt auf der Uhr dann den Herzschlag vom Kind. Das war alles ein bisschen strange. Also die Anwendung selber wirkte ein wenig angestrengt.
Die hat doch einen sehr komischen Namen, dass man gar nicht...
So ein Use-Case kann man sich jetzt ausdenken. Aber sie war zu dem, wie sie gemacht war, relativ genial, fand ich.
Also bei mir hat der Stream immer Audio, Sync war irgendwie, ging auseinander. Und dann hat es irgendwann geruckelt und dann stimmt das wieder. Aber das passierte schon ziemlich oft.
Das war nicht zweimal.
Nein, bei mir lief das Butterweich durch.
Also es kam schon immer irgendwas, aber out of Sync. Und die Qualität hat ab und zu mal hin und her geschaltet. Aber das würde ich noch okay finden. Aber nicht in Sync, das finde ich nicht okay.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall, die Keynote fand statt. Und es hat sich so ziemlich alles bewahrheitet, was mal wieder darüber gesagt wurde.
Ja, die Security ist eher ein Sieb bei denen inzwischen.
Ja, ich meine, bei den Mengen, die die auch raushauen, ist das wahrscheinlich einfach auch gar nicht mehr zu machen.
Ja, bei der Software kriegen sie immer noch Überraschungen hin.
Ja, weil die müssen sie ja nicht vorher schon an Tausende Firmen weltweit verteilen, wo irgendwie Abertausende Chinesen den ganzen Tag dran rumarbeiten. Also irgendeiner wird sich dann nochmal das Zubrot verdienen. Ich meine, die schmuggeln halt so ein Teil raus.
Ja, es schmuggelt wahrscheinlich nur das Foto raus.
Nö, es sind ja auch schon so Gehäuse vom iPhone 6 und so rausgekommen. Also da wird schon auch Hardware rausgetragen.
Ja klar, weil die ganzen Höhlenhersteller wahrscheinlich ordentlich Geld verzeihen, möglichst früh zu wissen, wie groß dieses Ding nun ist.
Das kommt dazu, ja.
Und da die Buden ja nun auch in China sitzen, haben die da auch irgendwie kein Sprachenproblem, sondern...
Kurzer Dienstweg.
Kurzer Dienstweg, genau.
Ja, aber ich denke auch, dass diese ganzen Unboxing-Sites da auch gerne mal ein paar Hundert-Dollar-Schein auf den Tisch legen für so einen Scoop. Das haben sie ja in der Hand Werbung und Aufmerksamkeit auf jeden Fall wieder drin. Na ja, wie auch immer. Also zur Uhr, damit ging es ja irgendwie los.
Es ist ja fast so, wie ich gesagt habe, sie machen noch mal eine neue Gehäusefarbe. Und dann die Anzahl der farbigen Plastibänder, den fand ich jetzt ein bisschen abstrus. Aber immerhin ist in WatchOS 2, kann man jetzt die Zifferbänder auch in den ganzen Farben der neuen Bänder einstellen. Die Ziffernblätter, ja. In den Farben der neuen Bänder kannst du also ein komisches Rehorsiegold-Sekundenzeiger machen.
Also ehrlich gesagt, was mich ja wundert ist, dass sie einen Feature nicht angekündigt haben. Weil das ist, ich weiß nicht, wie es dir so geht, aber ich verstehe nicht, warum es folgende Funktionen nicht gibt, die sie auch problemlos in der ersten Version hätten einbauen können. Ich entferne mich mit meiner Uhr am Arm von meinem iPhone. Und wir alle wissen, A, die Uhr wird dann ohnehin weitgehend unbenutzbar. Also verliert sie dann mal ihre Kernfunktionalität als Remote für das Telefon.
Ja. Okay, mit WatchOS 2 ist das nicht mehr ganz so schlimm, aber ja.
Ja, mag nicht mehr ganz so schlimm sein, aber der Nebenaspekt ist ja, wenn du dich von deinem Telefon entfernst, kann es ja auch sein, dass gerade dein Telefon sich von dir entfernt. Ich möchte ja gerne, dass meine Uhr mir wahlweise einfach mal ein Alarm in den Arm tappt, wenn sich mein Telefon entfernt. Also wenn mein Telefon zum Beispiel geklaut wird oder auch vielleicht nur von Kindern in einen anderen Raum getragen wird, dann würde ich das ganz gerne mitbekommen. Beziehungsweise um mal noch einen realistischen Fall machen, du verlässt morgens das Haus und hast dein Telefon nicht dabei.
Aber deine Uhr.
Warum macht die Uhr dann nicht...
Ich denke, das liegt vor allen Dingen daran, dass sie nicht ständig eine Connection offen haben, sondern die wirklich nur machen, wenn du sie tatsächlich brauchst.
Wenn sie in der Lage sind, mir da so ein rotes, durchgestrichenes iPhone-Symbol anzuzeigen.
Das kommt aber erst dann, wenn du irgendwas tust, was dann das Telefon auch tatsächlich braucht.
Nein, nein, das stimmt nicht.
Ja, weiß nicht. Vor allen Dingen habe ich ja die Erfahrung gemacht, wenn die Uhr und das Phone im gleichen WLAN sind, kann es durchaus passieren, dass du dieses Zeichen nicht bekommst, obwohl der eindeutig keinen Bluetooth mehr haben kann.
Weißt du, sie haben es deshalb nicht eingebaut, weil sie sich noch nicht so sicher sind, dass sie immer zuverlässige Kommunikation hinbekommen?
Ja, oder zuverlässigen Abbruch der Kommunikation. Keine Ahnung, kann man jetzt lange darüber spekulieren, warum sie es nicht machen.
Ich hätte das auf jeden Fall gerne.
Tim, hör zu, Tim will.
Es ist ja schön, dass ich auf der Uhr nach meinem Telefon suchen kann, indem ich es anpingen kann. Aber warum kann ich meine Uhr nicht anpingen mit dem Telefon? Ich habe auch manchmal das Problem, dass ich nicht weiß, wo ich die Uhr hingelegt habe.
Gute Frage.
Du gehst halt irgendwie duschen, wo ist denn die Scheiß-Uhr? Du hast aber dein Telefon.
Du hast kein Find-My-Apple-Watch.
Das ist da ja nicht mit vorgesehen.
Gucke gerade mal, haben sie das nachgerüstet? Aber so rum hatte ich das irgendwie auch noch nicht. Als vermisst markieren. Ja, okay, das war jetzt nicht das, was du wolltest.
Nein, das ist nicht das, was ich wollte. Ich will einfach nur in Kenntnis davon gesetzt werden, wenn das Telefon nicht in der Nähe der Uhr ist. Denn das ist ein Zustand, den möchte ich gerne wissen. Das ist für mich eine wichtigere Notification, als es 10 vor 3 Uhr stehen will. Wobei man noch nicht mal berücksichtigt, wenn man die ganze Stunde gestanden hat.
Am besten finde ich ja, dass du von der Uhr aus den Flugmodus einschalten kannst. Aber natürlich notwendigerweise logischerweise nicht mehr ausschalten kannst. Denn wenn das Telefon in den Flugmodus geht, dann verliert es ja Connection zur Uhr, weil das Telefon ja nichts mehr tut.
Da hätte ich eigentlich gerne noch, dass ich sagen kann, wie lange ich den ausschalte. Damit es auf jeden Fall nach einer Stunde wieder angeht, zum Beispiel, oder so was.
So ein Pausenmodus, ne?
Ja, wenn man es nicht vergisst. Bei WLAN genau das gleiche. Wie oft ich schon WLAN ausgeschaltet habe, habe ich vergessen. Dann geht das gleiche hier über LTE. Heutzutage ist das fast schneller. Und dann sagst du, oh, scheiße, mein Tarif. Das war es jetzt über den Keynote. Was haben wir noch?
Wir sind total aus dem Häuschen und die schönen Lederanbinder.
Bei der Uhr war nicht viel neu, außer dass sie ihren Brand auch untervermieten. Dieses Hermes?
Sprich man diese wirklich so aus?
Der ist französisch.
Deswegen würde ich Hermes sagen, aber naja.
Ach so, da hast du natürlich auch wieder recht. Das wird nicht interessant eigentlich. Es ist nur ganz interessant, dass sie mit ihrem Brand da so promisslich umgehen auf einmal.
Ja, wer weiß, wie viel die eingeworfen haben.
Ja gut, nur um Geld geht es da ja nicht. Also ich meine, wenn es um Apples-Brand geht...
Also ich erinnere mich da immer noch daran, dass sie irgendwann auf einer Keynote mal die Burton Ampjacket hatten. Irgend so eine komische Jacke, wo man den iPod reintun konnte und auf dem Arm irgendwie Play-Pause-Button hatte. Also insofern, ich weiß nicht. Ja, wie auch immer.
Aber das sah irgendwie ganz fancy-schmenzy aus.
Was? Ihr fragt doch gerade einer ganz berechtigt im Chat, warum nimmst du die Uhr nicht mit in die Dusche eigentlich?
Das Netz gibt einem zwar den Glauben, dass sie das überleben könnte, aber wenn ich mich schon wasche, dann wasche ich mich auch da, wo ich eine Uhr trage, normalerweise. Weil ich will ja nicht da Wochen und Monate lang so einen Peg ansammeln. Ich kann meine Uhr auch in der Dusche tragen.
Die kann man ja auch kurz abnehmen und dann kurz diese eine Stelle...
Also du meinst, sie soll erst mal einen Arm waschen, damit sie sie dann mit in die Dusche nehmen kann?
Hat sie denn festgenagelt an genau diese drei Zentimeter deines Arms oder hat die vielleicht auch ein bisschen Spiel?
Die hat nicht viel Spiel. Weil die muss ja auch den Puls messen.
Die würde ja nur messen, dass sie unter der Dusche, der Puls umgeht.
Und einmal am Tag fahren ja dann auch diese geheimen kleinen Stifte aus, die Apple sozusagen in direkte Verbindung mit deinen Nervenbaden bringen.
Da fahren Stifte raus?
Ich glaube, du blockierst auch. Nee, die laden dann direkt in deine...
Was hast du in der Mate?...
laden die sozusagen ihre Illusionen und Visionen nach. Dann gehst du halt wieder in den Laden und sagst, ich muss auch noch ein Band in Hautfarbe haben.
Dann ist auch egal, ob es schmutzig drunter ist.
Ja, also ich bin, wie gesagt, diese Uhr ist nach wie vor ein Produkt, was man noch nicht unbedingt braucht. Vielleicht ändert sich das mit WatchOS, aber Apple hat ja gesagt, sie wollen das heute noch nicht ausliefern. Dementsprechend können wir dieses Kapitel dann auch schon wieder beschließen. Dennis, hast du noch Fragen?
Zur Uhr? Nee, hab ja keine.
Das könnte ja auch ein besonderer Grund sein, dass du viel zu fragen hast.
Nee, ich warte. Ich geb das erst mal, bis das nächste Modell kommt.
Ich warte, bis man die Uhr ohne Telefon benutzen kann. Da kann ich vielleicht lange warten, aber vorher macht die Uhr nicht so richtig Sinn.
Man kann die Uhr ohne Telefon benutzen.
Ja, aber so vollwertig, dass du...
Mit GSM oder was?
Ich finde die vollwertig.
Naja, dass ich da GSM auch hab auf der Uhr halt.
GSM wird nicht passieren, aber du hast ja WLAN auf der Uhr.
Ja, aber ich hab halt unterwegs nicht immer WLAN.
Warum wird das nicht passieren, meinst du?
Glaub ich auch.
Und was ist, wenn sie...
Das Akkupack-Armband anbieten? Ja, das!
Nee, also was ich mir zum Beispiel vorstellen könnte, ist, dass sie sowas machen wie LTE, vierte oder fünfte Generation only.
LTE Low Energy, gibt's sowas?
Ja, der Strom, jetzt bin ich auf dünnem Eis. Ich meine, mich erinnern zu können, dass LTE auch niedrigeren Stromverbrauch nach sich ziehen kann. Was allein schon natürlich an den höheren Datenraten liegt. Das wird so schnell nicht passieren. Ich könnte mir das vorstellen, dass so etwas wie eine Uhr, also so ein Casual, wenig Akku, sollte lange laufen Device, dass das eben Mobilfunk aller LTE macht, um seine Daten zu bekommen, aber nicht diesen ganzen Fallback-Rattenschwanz mit 3G und GSM auch noch mitmacht. Sondern, dass das Ding sozusagen nur LTE hat. Und natürlich ist die Coverage heute noch nicht so, dass das jetzt was bringt, aber denken wir mal 2, 3, 4 Jahre voraus, da wird das mit dem LTE schon weitgehend, zumindest in unseren Breiten, überall sein.
Aber wäre es nicht andersherum eigentlich cooler, weil auf der Uhr brauchst du ja nicht gigabyteweise Daten, da brauchst du eigentlich nur so...
Es geht nicht um viel Daten, sondern es geht darum, dass du sie mit möglichst wenig Stromverbrauch ziehen kannst.
Genau, und dann kommt irgend so ein Android-Hersteller wieder um die Ecke und macht Telefonieren auf der Uhr.
Na ja, egal, wenn die Batterien dafür irgendwann mal besser werden, das ist ja eh einer der größten Fortschrittshämmer aktuell, diese Batterietechnologie. Vielleicht gibt es ja dann noch mal einen Durchbruch und dann ist alles plötzlich ganz möglich.
Also diese Physik ist auch ein Fortschrittshämmer.
Warte mal, aber mit Watcher S20 kann das Ding dann nicht schon telefonieren ohne Telefon? Das müsste eigentlich schon fast gehen.
Also was du machen kannst, du kannst natürlich Netzverbindungen aufmachen über WLAN. Ob du jetzt, weiß ich nicht, so einen FaceTime-Call ohne das Telefon machen kannst, das weiß ich gar nicht.
Also gehen würde das schon.
Aber das hängt wahrscheinlich von Codex und Rechenleistung und so ein Durchbruch ab.
Und GPS hat das Ding ja auch nicht, ne?
Nein, GPS hat das auch nicht.
Es hat nur Beschleunigungssensor und Kyro, glaube ich.
Also irgendwie so richtig geil fände ich, glaube ich, so eine Uhr. Also dann könnte die auch noch gerade so groß sein. Wenn die so ein bisschen Daten von alleine haben kann und GPS und so, das wäre schon...
Na gut, aber GPS zieht halt auch wirklich viel Strom.
Ja, das muss auch nicht unbedingt die ganze Zeit an sein. Aber gerade mal so hier, wo bin ich gerade, geil. Weil für mich ist das total behindert, wenn ich dann trotzdem halt diesen Riegel mitschleppen muss.
Ja, ich muss sagen, dass gerade das mit dem, wo bin ich gerade, das ist auf der Uhr irgendwie besonders nervig. Weil wenn du da die Karte aufmachst, dann dauert das richtig lange. Ja, weil er ja im Hintergrund dann auf dem Telefon irgendwie die Maps-Zeug aufmacht. Und dann muss er den GPS-Fix finden und das dauert ewig. Dann lädt das Telefon die Karten runter, rechnet sie auf Uhrengröße. Dann spielt er die Karten zurück auf die Uhr und so weiter. Also das macht echt keinen Spaß.
Es ist halt wie mit dem ersten iPhone. Es hat einfach totale Megakonstraints. Man sieht auch schon in etwa, wo es hingehen könnte. Und ich denke, GPS kann ich nicht so richtig beantworten, wie da so die Stromkonstraints sind. Aber Daten, LTE in dem Teil sehe ich schon. Dann ist halt auch die SIM-Karte Vergangenheit. Also sie werden hier bestimmt keinen SIM-Karten-Slot reinbauen.
Originales SIM-Karte würde gar nicht reinpassen.
Sind wir schon bei Micro-SIM oder waren wir noch bei Nano? Ah nee, Nano ist ja auch wiederum kleiner als Micro.
Genau, Nano ist kleiner.
Was gäbe es dann danach noch als nächstes?
Es gibt halt einfach den CPU, wo du die Scheiße einfach vor allem da reinladen kannst. Das reicht ja auch.
In irgendeinem TPM.
Ich finde einfach diesen Computing-Ort interessant. Und ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt, mit was für Apps die Freunde da rauskommen. Ich auch.
Unsere Freunde.
Vor allem, ob hier so Runtastic, also gerade diese ganzen Fitness-Sachen, ich denke mal, das ist so das, was als allererstes fliegen wird. Weil das habe ich jetzt gerade auch nochmal ausprobiert. Das macht einfach alles überhaupt keinen Spaß bisher. Also diese ganzen Lobes-Hymnen mit wie toll doch irgendwie Fitness-Tracking jetzt mit der Apple Watch ist, das ist wirklich albern, da bist du also mit dem iPhone und einem ordentlichen Hardrate-Monitor derzeit echt noch besser bedient. Aber das wird sich halt in dem Moment ändern, wo die Apps auf alles zugreifen können. Und ich hoffe, dass die Buden das in Griff kriegen. Es gibt ja mehrere Trecker, die da was zu sagen haben, gerade in dem Markt, und die werden sich bestimmt ordentlich anstrengen, sich gegenseitig mit Features zu überbieten.
Sehr gut, sportfrei.
Jetzt vor allem auch wieder so richtig, weil jetzt so Herbst, jetzt muss wieder Statue angenommen werden.
Für die Bikini-Figur im Herbst.
Wenn wir dann alle auf den Tischen tanzen. Okay, ich nerf euch nicht länger mit der Uhr. Weiter geht's.
Ja, Großes ist. Also ich meine, wir können jetzt wahrscheinlich lange darüber reden, wie dann das jetzt nochmal ist mit dem App-Markt und dem iPad. Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass der App-Store das iPad zu einem Rohr-Krepierer werden lässt.
Das was?
Ja. Also du brauchst auf so einem großen iPad willst du eine ordentliche App haben. Eine ordentliche App hat eine ordentliche Komplexität. Dafür musst du ordentlich Programmiererstunden drauf werfen und die kosten einfach Geld. Und der App-Store bietet momentan kein Monetarisierungsmodell, mit dem du dir das Geld wieder reinkriegst. Also es gibt keine Demos, es gibt keine bezahlten Updates und es gibt auch keine Möglichkeit als App-Hersteller mit deinem Kundenstamm irgendwie zu kommunizieren. Weil Apple einfach dazwischen steht. Und das bedeutet, dass du als App-Hersteller unglaublich schwierig hast, irgendwie einen ordentlichen Revenue-Stream über die App zu generieren. Und damit ist das Thema tot. Und damit ist meiner Meinung nach auch das iPad Pro tot. Weil ich meine, ein Twitter-Client oder eine größere Apple Maps, dafür brauche ich kein iPad Pro. Da brauche ich auch kein Stylus für. Ich meine, wenn du dir sowas anguckst wie diese Jungs von 53, wie auch immer sie heißen, die dieses Sketch-Programm da gemacht haben, die leben im Wesentlichen davon, dass sie diesen komischen Stift dazu verkaufen, den du dann mit ihrer App benutzen kannst, die halt umme ist. Aber der Stift kostet halt 80 Euro. So, jetzt kommt Apple, macht irgendwie einen neuen Stift, der weiß ich nicht, wie genau und schnell ist, und damit ist halt der Geschäftsmodell im Eimer. Gut, sowas kann passieren.
Das ist halt der Lauf der Innovation, das wirst du immer wieder haben.
Aber interessanterweise, wen haben sie denn gezeigt auf der Bühne? Sie haben halt Microsoft gezeigt mit ihrem Office, was über ein Subskriptionsmodell wahrscheinlich verkauft wird. Und dann haben sie Adobe gezeigt mit ihrem Kram, was wahrscheinlich auch über ein Subskriptionsmodell läuft. Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch die einzige Möglichkeit, wie du in dem Markt tatsächlich irgendwie was reißen kannst. Du hast die Apps halt im Quasi-Demo-Mode umsonst raus, und wenn du dann die benutzen willst, musst du eine Subskription abschließen. Das ist das Einzige, was ich mir vorstellen kann. Dass Firmen Pro-Software für dieses iPad machen. Alles andere wird nicht funktionieren. Und das ist ein massives Problem meiner Meinung nach.
Aber hey.
Sie werden sich da sicherlich schon ein paar Gedanken zu gemacht haben. Ich meine, wenn ich das iPad Pro sehe, dann denke ich mir halt zuerst einmal...
Geiles Gerät.
Ja, klar. Na gut, ich meine, das ist halt...
Spannend fand ich, dass sie es gewichtsmäßig gegen das allererste iPad verglichen haben. So nach der, na, was ist denn das schwerste iPad, was wir jetzt finden, gegen das wir das jetzt vergleichen können?
Und das ist so ein Hauch schwerer als das erste iPad, ne?
Ja, 830 Gramm oder was das waren.
Ja, aber das verteilt sich natürlich auf eine riesen Fläche, da wirkt das Ding immer noch sehr leicht. Jaja, klar. Also ich denke mir halt, dass... Und das sagt halt auch der Name aus, ne? Ich meine, warum?
Sie hätten es ja auch...
Plus nennen können oder... Super Size.
Ja, aber es nur Pro zu nennen, hat ja noch nicht den Effekt, dass es dann irgendwie zu einem Pro-Markt wird.
Ja, ich denke, dass das halt auch wirklich ein Lückenschließer ist in ihrer Gesamtstrategie, wie sie das iPad eigentlich am Markt sehen. Weil es gibt da eben zwei... Ist ein bisschen vermessen, das auf zwei runterzubrechen, aber ich sehe jetzt auf den ersten Blick vor allem zwei Anwendungen für so ein iPad. Das eine ist so dieser Casual Zuhause spielen Fernsehen Second Screen Markt. So wie Steve Jobs einst da bei der Präsentation des ersten iPads sich auf seinen Sofa geflätzt hat und schön gezeigt hat, wie man das zu benutzen hat. Man legt das irgendwie auf den Schoß und dann tippt man darauf rum, Couchpotato-mäßig und dann hat man eben die passenden Apps dafür, kann ein bisschen surfen, ein bisschen chatten, ein bisschen dies, ein bisschen das.
Dafür ist es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen fett, aber...
Dafür ist das jetzt ein bisschen fett, auch wenn es sicherlich Edge-Cases gibt, wo Leute sogar es gerne noch größer hätten.
Ja klar, screen estate ist viel screen estate. Das 17 Zoll MacBook hat sich damals auch gut verkauft aus genau dem Grund. Auch wenn dreieinhalb Kilo rumschleppen, halt nicht jedermanns Sache ist.
Ich werde jetzt drei Szenarien unterscheiden, fällt mir gerade ein. Szenario 2, und das habe ich für dich auch schon sehr oft gesehen, Leute benutzen so ein iPad quasi als Ersatz für ein Laptop. Das ist so nicht das, was... Also es würde unsere Laptops für uns natürlich nicht ersetzen und tut das auch nicht. Aber es gibt halt so Leute, die brauchen halt mal ein Gerät, wo sie was schreiben. Und tatsächlich, die haben das dann halt mit so einem Kensington Club-Keyboard oder Belkin oder wer auch immer die Dinger herstellt, habe ich ganz oft gesehen, dass so im Zug hochgestapelte iPads mit Tastatur verwendet werden oder auch mal ohne Tastatur einfach zum Schreiben.
Ja, das geht auch gut. Ich habe ja auch so ein komisches Keyboard. Und das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut. Abgesehen davon, dass ich immer irgendwie mir das erst abgewöhnen musste, die Finger auszustrecken, weil man dann immer aus Versehen aufs Display tappt und dann passieren Dinge, die man nicht wollte.
Und jetzt haben sie halt den Bildschirm so groß gemacht, dass eben ein Full-Size-Keyboard da drauf passt. Und das ist halt für manche Leute wirklich ein Argument. Du hast ein iPad Mini mit so einer Tastatur.
Warum schreiben die ihren Produktnamen nicht drauf? Anfänge. Folio. Ultra-Thin-Keyboard-Folio.
Kannst du mal raussuchen, bitte. Für die Notizen.
Für die Notizen.
Und sind deine Erfahrungen damit gut?
Na es tut. Also, ich hab da keine Probleme mit.
Also es gibt so Leute, die benutzen halt ihren Computer zum Schreiben. Das ist ja auch so das, was viele Leute auch mit Laptops gemacht haben. Da haben sie ja eigentlich ein Laptop gekauft und dann schreiben sie da eigentlich. Texte, Bücher, keine Ahnung, Korrespondenz, E-Mail. Aber sie sind eigentlich die ganze Zeit nur am Schreiben. Und auch das deckt halt das neue iPad ab, weil es halt, ich meine, mit 13 Zoll, wenn man das jetzt mal vergleicht, das ist halt so MacBook Air 13 Zoll in der Größenordnung, der Liga spielt das. Und das ist ja immer noch ein verhältnismäßig leichtes Gerät, was nicht dick aufträgt. Das kriegt man halt problemlos hier in seinen Restretto-Bag reingeschoben. Und alles ist gut. Und auch da, denke ich, macht das iPad Pro ein Angebot für manche Leute, die einfach einen größeren Screen haben wollen, weil sie mehr Text sehen wollen.
Also casual computing.
Ja, ich habe da gar keinen Namen dafür, aber es ist jetzt nicht dieses Couch-Potato-Usage, sondern es ist mehr schon so Serious Work. Aber jetzt nicht so im Sinne von mein Computer, meine Monster-Maschine, mit der ich unglaubliche Dinge machen, sondern einfach der Ersatz für eine Schreibmaschine, der der Computer jetzt einfach seit 20 Jahren ist. 30? 20? Und seit wann gibt es eigentlich keine Schreibmaschinen mehr?
Je nachdem, wen du fragst, gibt es immer noch Schreibmaschinen.
Frag mal Triumph Adler, die werden dir sagen, es gibt noch Schreibmaschinen.
Du weißt doch, die Zukunft ist schon hier, sie ist nur noch nicht gleich verteilt.
Glaub ich, kauft heute noch jemand mechanische Schreibmaschinen?
Bestimmt. Triumph Adler ist ja auch irgendwie schon vor... Also ich glaube, mein Opa hat... Der ist umgestiegen auf so eine Computerschreibmaschine mit so einem komischen, proprietären Floppy, das Kettenformat. Das war vielleicht kurz vor 2000, 2000. Also Computerschreibmaschinen gibt es zum Beispiel auch schon ziemlich lange. Wahrscheinlich macht Triumph Adler jetzt auch nichts anderes mehr, außer sowas.
Man kann tatsächlich bei Amazon noch Schreibmaschinen kaufen.
Ja, wundert mich nicht. Es wird bestimmt immer noch irgendwelche Leute geben, die sowas benutzen.
Elektrische und elektronische.
Leute kaufen ja auch noch Vinyl, also ich meine...
Wieder, vor allem.
Unglaublich. Triumph Adler elektronische Schreibmaschine. Twen T180 DS mit Display.
Rät mal nicht so laut, sonst fangen die wirklich an, wie die Vinyl-Wahnsinnigen jetzt da die Schreibmaschinen wahnsinnigen.
Also bei... Das ist ja geil.
Das ist aber cool.
Oh, das ist ja richtig schick.
Klickt mal in den Link hier, querkywriter.com.
Eine Schreibmaschine für das iPad?
Ja, es ist wohl eher ein Keyboard, was sehr an eine Schreibmaschine gemahnt. Der ist wirklich ein bisschen querky, aber...
Ja, vor allem mit dem Hebel ist ja geil, ne? Nie wieder Return drücken. Ja, da weiß man auch, was ein Line Feed ist.
Ja, vor allem, was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem Carriage-Return und einem Line Feed?
Ja, genau, der Hebel ist der Line Feed.
Nein, ist der Carriage-Return. Doch, weil du schiebst ja die Lade damit zurück. Die meisten Hebel machen aber gleichzeitig noch ein Line Feed.
Das stimmt.
Also der Hebel selber macht den Line Feed.
Genau, wenn du den drückst, dann macht er einen Line Feed und dann schiebst du den ganzen Wagen zurück. Dann hast du den Carriage-Return.
Ja, eigentlich ist es LFCA und nicht CALF. Diese Debatte, die kriegen wir heute eh nicht mehr.
Ja, das hat Microsoft damals nicht wirklich hingekriegt.
Aber auch nur 320 Dollar.
Gibt es hier mit deutscher Belegung?
Quirky Writer.
Nein, leider nicht.
Von irgendwas hat mich das jetzt gerade abgebracht.
Was war das noch?
Das waren deine Use-Cases.
Jetzt kommt der dritte Use-Case. Sag mal noch mal kurz, wie heißt dein Ding Logitech? Okay, dann habe ich das auch noch mal notiert.
Ich habe dir den Link da reingeschmissen.
Also wir haben jetzt zwei Anwendungen. CouchPotato, iPad Pro, keine große Rolle meiner Meinung nach. In diesem Casual Usage-Szenario, also so Schreibmaschine, würde ich sagen, da gibt es eine Zielgruppe, die ist aber nicht sonderlich groß.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, wenn du dir anguckst, was das kostet und wie viel, wenn du jetzt wirklich mal eine billige PC-Hardware anguckst in der gleichen Größe, was die kostet, dann wird es halt echt dünn. Also besonders so an diesen Casual User, dem das eh nicht beizubiegen ist, was der Unterschied zwischen iOS und Windows ist.
So, jetzt gibt es noch eine dritte Gruppe, die ich tatsächlich noch mal in eine Gruppe A und eine Gruppe B aufteilen will. Also Gruppe 3A, das ist...
Anlage 42B.
Ja, das ist Pro. Und zwar Pro im Sinne von Apple und seine Allianz mit IBM. Nicht nur die, aber vor allem auch die. Enterprise-Software, In-House-Software, Anwendungen innerhalb eines Betriebsablaufs, wo so eine Firma auch mal die iPads in 5-stelligen Stückzahlen kauft und damit ihre ganzen Außendienstmitarbeiter, Datenerfassungs-Menschen... Also es gibt einfach in der Industrie oder überhaupt in der Wirtschaft in größeren Unternehmen gibt es einfach so bestimmte Anwendungen. Da ist halt einfach mal ein iPad an sich schon mal eine deutliche Verbesserung gegenüber einem Laptop. Versicherungsvertreter, die dir einfach nur irgendwelche Dinge zeigen, Dokumente griffbereit haben müssen, etc. Aber die eben auch nicht unbedingt immer Bock haben, so viel mitzumachen und dann am Ende ein kleines Formular ausfüllen, etc. Vielleicht nicht das allerbeste Beispiel. Aber so in industriellen Abläufen brauchst du halt einfach immer mal was, was mobil dir irgendwas visualisiert.
Das elektronische Klemmbrett.
Ja, genau, so was. Das ist schön gesagt. So ein elektronisches Klemmbrett, bzw. halt aus einem mobiles Datenerfassungs-Terminal. Und auch da war das iPad schon immer auch gut unterwegs. Also das spielt definitiv eine Rolle in diesen Unternehmen. Da gibt es auch teure Software, bzw. eben auch sehr viel Inhouse-Customized-Software. Und ich denke, das, was IBM da für das iPad produziert, fällt auf jeden Fall in diese Kategorie. Und auch da macht halt das iPad Pro eine Menge aus. Das kann ich nicht quantifizieren, aber da bin ich mir relativ sicher, dass da eine ganze Menge Leute die eine oder andere Braue gelupft haben. Und jetzt gibt es noch die Kategorie 3b. Und das sind Leute, von denen ich jetzt schon zwei getroffen habe. Wo ich dann auch gleich als erstes gefragt habe, na, hast du ja schon ein iPad Pro bestellt? Die mich einfach nur mit strahlenden Augen angeschaut haben. Ja, und ich hole mir sofort eins.
Maler.
Grafiker, Zeichner, 3D-Leute, die alle irgendwie das Dreifache für so ein Vakuum-Clicky-die-Click-Stift-System mit, wie ich male, auf einem komischen Brett und sehe es auf dem Bildschirm.
Die habe ich auch schon ein paar gesehen.
Also die sind alle auf diesen Penseln so scharf wie nichts.
Wobei bei Vakuum gibt es ja auch die mit Display drin.
Die kosten aber 3000 Dollar und haben einen riesigen Abstand zwischen dem Stift und haben eine Turbo-Latenz beim Malen.
Das stimmt nicht wirklich. Dieses Cintiq, dieses 24 Zoll, das ist z.B. bei uns in der Firma, haben das alle Artists quasi da auf dem Tisch stehen. Das ist schon ziemlich geile Hardware.
Das kostet aber ein Vielfaches von so einem iPad Pro mit Pensel.
Ich weiß nicht, wie dieses Cintiq diese kleineren sind. Die sind nämlich auch um einiges billiger als dieses 24 Zoll Flagship-Product. Vielleicht sind die auch langsam oder da ist irgendwie Scheiße. Die stehen bei uns tatsächlich nicht rum. Die haben wirklich alle diese 24 Zoll-Dinger. Aber ich dachte mir auch so, bei der Vorstellung, die, die jetzt vielleicht am ersten schwitzen, sind vielleicht wirklich so die Leute von Wacom. Andererseits meinte dann hier auch der Falk im Twitter, naja, vielleicht reiben die sich auch die Hände, weil jetzt Apple einfach mal da schön die Schatulle für Patent-Lizenzgebühren halt aufmachen muss. Weil wenn man den Wacom-Jungs natürlich schon anrechnen kann, ist, dass die da seit auch gefühlten 20 Jahren am Markt sind und einfach so diese Industrie komplett quasi dominiert haben.
Also ich glaube, wenn da irgendjemand, irgendjemandes Schatulle geöffnet wird bei diesen Stiften, dann ist es Apples Schatulle. Weil die haben das als erstes gemacht.
Naja, aber Wacom hat sicherlich auch das eine oder andere Patent, meinst du nicht?
Ja, das kann schon sein.
Kann man nicht hier irgendwo in der Patent-Datenbank mal nachschauen?
Fangen wir hier nicht mit Dura-Kram an. Ich meine, diese ganze Stylos-Debatte, wo der dann auch gleich wieder kam, so ja, aber Microsoft hat doch...
Aber Steve hat doch gesagt.
Ja, Steve hat doch gesagt. Also ich meine, das ist halt...
Ja, Steve hat gesagt, und das war ja auch zum iPhone genau das Richtige, du willst natürlich nicht ein iPhone, ein Telefon mit einem Stift bedienen müssen. Das ist genau der Punkt. Aber einen Stift zu haben für gerade so ein großes iPad ist natürlich zum Fingerlecken und der wird ja auch für einen Hunni verkauft. Also ich denke, dass Apple da auch wieder den Preispunkt getroffen hat, wo die Leute zwar das Gesicht verziehen, aber trotzdem kaufen.
So ein Wacom Pen kostet auch 80 Dollar.
100 Dollar, da verzieht keiner das Gesicht.
Na ja, zumindest die Leute, die jetzt nicht jeden Tag irgendwas mit dem Stift machen, schon.
Die Leute, die nicht jeden Tag was mit dem Stift machen, die kaufen sich diesen Stift auch nicht.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Beziehungsweise da werden sich vielleicht sogar einige den noch kaufen, weil er nur 100 Euro kostet. Also ich wäre nicht überrascht gewesen, wenn das Ding 150 Euro gekostet hätte.
So gesehen.
Die Zielgruppe wäre da genauso drauf abgefahren. Also die 50 Euro macht es am Ende auch nicht aus. Was mich jetzt bloß ein bisschen wundert bei diesem iPad Pro. Dieser Stift funktioniert angeblich nur mit diesem iPad Pro. Warum?
Weil möglicherweise in dem iPad Pro noch zusätzliche Hardware drin ist, die den Stift ansteuert.
Ansteuert?
Beziehungsweise der Stift kann möglicherweise seine eigene Position messen und so weiter. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie die Vakum-Teile da funktionieren.
Naja, der Apple-Stift hat ja Batterie und so eine Lightning-Connector. Den musst du ja auch aufladen. Die Vakum-Schrifte sind ja, wie auch hier schon im Chat gesagt, die sind ja passiv.
Ja, aber trotzdem hat der Vakum-Stift ja sowas wie eine Druckerkennung und er hat auch eine Winkelerkennung und diesen ganzen Kram. Also das muss man ja auch alles irgendwie messen. Allein nur das Touch-Ting, so wie es eingebaut wird in allen anderen Geräten, wird nicht die Neigung vom Stift erkennen können und auch nicht den Druck.
Was? Natürlich kannst du die Neigung problemlos erkennen. Im Beschleunigungs-Sensor kannst du die Neigung problemlos erkennen.
Dann muss aber der Beschleunigungs-Sensor im Stift sein.
Die haben da einen Juro und einen Beschleunigungs-Sensor.
Du, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht ist der Grund auch einfach nur, das ist halt ein Stift fürs Pro und der wird nur fürs Pro verkauft, fertig.
Ja, aber warum sollten die sich da so einschränken? Warum?
Weil sie irgendwann einen iPad Air 5 rausbringen, wo sie dann sagen, geht auch mit dem Stift. Und es gibt zwar keinen Hardware-Grund, aber es gibt einen Marketing-Grund, weil du sollst nämlich das neue iPad Air 5 und das neue iPad Mini 5 kaufen.
Nein, es wird sich jetzt aber keiner ein iPad Pro kaufen, nur wegen des Stifts, obwohl er eigentlich mit einem Mini unterwegs ist. Also so doof ist auch Apple nicht. Nein, ich denke, es ist schon irgendeine technische Sache, aber meines Wissens haben sie keine erwähnt oder habe ich irgendwas überhört. Also das Einzige, was ich mir vorstellen kann, ist, guck mal, wie kann denn das iPad überhaupt merken, dass da ein Stift ist? Indem sich der Stift im Prinzip so verhält wie ein Finger. Was heißt in dem Moment, wo du mit dem...
Ja, aber nicht notwendigerweise.
Ich sage jetzt erstmal iPad, nicht Pro, sondern... Ja, ein Stift, also da müsste er sich verhalten wie ein Finger, also er müsste im Prinzip dieselbe Erdung, kapazitive Geschichte...
Nie müsste er natürlich nicht, weil Apple ja den Fingerabdruck ihres Stiftes kennt und sagen könnte, okay, alles was so aussieht und in unserem Netz von Sensoren diesen Abdruck hat, ist jetzt unser Stift.
Ja, aber die einzige Sensorik, die jetzt auf einem normalen iPad da ist, ist halt diese kapazitive Sensorik. Das ist das, was ich meine. Dass sie das unterscheiden können, klar, und dann auch auf kleine Pixel zurückführen können und nicht so einen dicken, fetten Finger da erkennen, okay. Die Styli, die es ja bisher gab, die so funktioniert haben, die hatten ja meistens alle unten so einen dicken Gummi-Gnubbel. Das heißt, die waren auch relativ unpräzise.
Ja, und viel davon war dann auch leitfähig, und die haben damit ja im Prinzip auch nur das verpackte Würstchen simuliert.
Genau, und die waren halt so ein bisschen fuzzy. Und dieser Stift ist angeblich ganz genau. Und trifft da jeden Pixel, den man schon gar nicht mehr sehen kann. Und deswegen frage ich mich, ist halt in dem iPad Pro, haben sie da halt irgendwas mit dieser Sensorik, oder haben sie noch eine zweite Sensorik drin, die eben jetzt speziell auf diesen Stift abgestellt ist?
Ich kann es mir vorstellen.
Ich kann es mir auch gar nicht anders vorstellen, auch wenn sie das halt so nicht benannt haben.
Naja, ich kann es mir vorstellen, dass es so ist. Ich kann es mir natürlich auch vorstellen, dass sie es einfach nur mal machen. Keine Ahnung.
Ich hätte das super gerne, ich würde diesen Stift gerne mit so einem iPad Mini benutzen.
Ja, nicht nur du, aber ist halt jetzt erstmal nicht. Sobald es den Stift und das Pro gibt, werden wir sicherlich dann die Antwort erfahren, weil iFixit oder andere übliche Verdächtige das sofort auseinandernehmen und herausfinden, wie es funktioniert.
Also hier, weil es gerade jemand im Chat mal gesagt hat, der Vakuum-Stift, der ist auch aktiv, der kriegt über Induktionen seinen Strom vom Tablett und 1984 hat Vakuum das erste Grafiktablett mit einem kabellosen Stift herausgebracht, 1987 ein Grafiktablett, dessen Stift mittels Induktionen funktioniert und daher auch ohne Batterie auskommt. Also schon auch nicht unfiffig.
Dieser Cintiq, ist der denn kabellos?
Glaube wohl, ja.
Vakuum macht seit Ewigkeiten nur noch kabellosen Kram.
Und es gibt jetzt einen 13 Zoll HD Cintiq tatsächlich, das liegt so bei 800 Euro. Das iPad Pro ist da schon genau, das fängt da schon so an. Wenn du dann irgendwann auf deinem iPad auch diesen Stift benutzen kannst, dann sind sie wahrscheinlich wirklich am schwitzen. Na ja.
Gucken wir mal, wie sie es entwickelt. Vielleicht schieben die auch ihren Stift noch für die anderen Produkte nach oder die Software dafür oder wie auch immer.
Ja, das muss man wirklich abwarten.
Aber ich meine, der Fakt alleine, dass du diesen Stift laden musst, das sagt ja schon irgendwie auch...
Nee, das sagt aber vor allen Dingen aus, dass sie halt nicht auf irgendeine Art und Weise da was aussenden, damit der Stift dann den Strom bekommt. Also das spricht eher dafür, dass eventuell du den Stift auch mit den anderen Geräten benutzen kannst.
Nur nicht so genau, weil diese...
Vielleicht haben sie auch festgestellt, das zieht viel zu viel Strom und es ist besser, das Teil richtig per Kabel in Anführungszeichen zu laden. Und wenn du das Teil, weiß ich nicht, kurz in der Zeichenpause ansteckst und hast dann irgendwie wieder für zwei Stunden Ladung in dem Stift...
Also was ich gelesen habe, ist, dass man ihn für 15 Sekunden reinsteckt und man ihn eine halbe Stunde benutzen kann. Wenn man ihn vollgetellt, hält er aber zwölf oder wie war das?
Das ist doch völlig ausreichend. Da muss ich doch kein Zinnova machen mit irgendwie induktiv Strom erzeugen und so. Na ja, ist doch so.
Dann können sich das ja auch erleisten, weil ihre Geräte wahrscheinlich relativ fett sind und nicht so zum Durch-die-Gegen-Tragen sind. Also so ein iPad, wenn das noch die Ladestation für den Stift wäre, wäre es wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen fetter.
Also die kleinen Vakums, die steckst du einfach nur bei USB ran. Also ich meine, die haben jetzt kein eigenes Netzteil oder so.
Die laden auch den Stift dann?
Der Stift braucht nicht geladen werden.
Der Stift erzeugt ja induktiv Strom, sprich die machen Strahlen irgendwie ein wie auch immer gehabtes Magnet.
Aber bei denen die Vakums auch ohne USB-Kabel und laden da ein Stift.
Die laden den Stift ja nicht.
Ja, die laden den nur anders.
Du, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, ob es einen Vakuum gibt, was jetzt ohne Kabel, aber der ist auch sinnlos. Also der ist genauso sinnlos wie das Magic Trackpad mit Batterien. Was soll der Scheiß? Du schleppst das Ding ja nicht rum. Das ist ja kein mobiles Gerät.
Ja, aber das iPad schleppst du halt schon rum. Deswegen machen die das da anders.
Also, da bin ich auf jeden Fall mal gespannt, wie weit jetzt wirklich diese User-Gruppe, die jetzt total scharf drauf ist, wenn die das dann wirklich mal in den Fingern haben, inwieweit das dann wirklich halt mit dem Vakuum vergleichbar ist. Weil, das ist schon so, dass das relativ ordentliche Geräte sind. Also, das hat Vakuum schon einfach auch die letzten, wie auch immer, 20 Jahre halt, oder was, seit 1987 halt schon ordentlich ausgefuchst. Und wenn du mal vor so einem großen, fetten Cintiq 24 Zoll sitzt und damit mal eben so Illustrator und so Sachen benutzt, das ist schon mal ordentlich. Aber ich kann mir halt auch genauso gut vorstellen, wenn jetzt die iMacs immer dünner werden und flacher und so, irgendwann hast du halt genau dieses Ding mit dem Computer und allem schon drin und musst nicht mehr noch irgendwo einen Rechner anschließen, dann, wenn dann ihr Stift auch noch genauso funktioniert und die gleichen Features hat, dann, ja, brauchst du das halt dann irgendwann vielleicht auch nicht mehr, das Cintiq.
Ich glaube auch, dass der Haupt-Benutzergruppe hier so Businesszeug und Enterprise-Kram sein wird aus Apple Sicht.
Ich denke auch, die werden jetzt nicht unsäglich viele von diesen Dingern verkaufen.
Aber die musst du halt anbieten, damit du deine Plattform halt insgesamt vorwärts bringst.
Interessant bleibt halt die Frage, ob das nicht ein Henni-Problem wird. Also einerseits halt User, die sagen, ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen, aber es gibt die Software nicht. Und Softwarehersteller, die sagen, ja, kann ich mir vorstellen, aber es gibt nicht genug User. Also es kann halt passieren.
Für den Stift meinst du jetzt?
Nee, für das Pro insgesamt. Weil halt, ja klar.
Na gut, ich meine, zunächst einmal musst du ja, wie wir ja wissen, eigentlich jetzt an der Software, ich meine, wenn du jetzt das große iPad, das R, unterstützt, dann ist jetzt, glaube ich, die Anpassung für das Pro eher nur noch mal so ein Testlauf. Also wenn du eh schon so mit Auto-Layout unterwegs bist, musst du wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr so viel machen. Haben die eigentlich irgendwas dazu gesagt, wie viele Pixel hat das? Das ist ja auch so ein normales Doppel-2X-Retina, ne?
Ja, naja, sie haben in Punkten 1024 hoch und 15 irgendwas rüber. Aber weil es Retina ist, sind es in beiden Richtungen doppelt so viele. Also ja, wahrscheinlich ist, wenn du eine iPad-Anwendung hast, ist die Anpassung nicht so groß. Wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung.
Und irgendwann gibt es den Mode, wo du zwischen OS X und iOS Oberflächen und her switchen kannst, und dann kannst du auch deine Mac-Apps auf dem iPad Pro fahren.
Also ich meine, das mit dem Auto-Layout ist immer wieder großer Spaß. Ich habe jetzt in einer App irgendwie ein View gemacht, der halt auf dem 4S, dem 5, dem 6 und dem 6 Plus gut aussehen muss. Das ist dann schon irgendwie so, äh, das ist Arbeit. Geschenkt bekommt man das nicht.
Aber zumindest unsere Unity-Entwickler, die fluchen ja da auch regelmäßig. Und die vermissen glaube ich auch so mit am meisten diese Layout-Features von iOS, weil in Unity wohl alles noch viel, viel, viel schlimmer ist. Also beschweren auf hohem Niveau wahrscheinlich dann am Ende.
Unity war doch dieses 3D-Zeug, oder nicht?
Das machen halt gerade.
Aber ist bei denen nur das Aspektratio eigentlich interessant und dann wird es halt skaliert, weil es ist eh 3D?
Die haben einfach so, wie sie das System haben mit ihren ankernen Punkten für, wo du deine GUI-Sachen halt aufheizen soll, und das Auto-Stretching, Table-Views und dieser ganze Kram.
Verstehe, verstehe. Der ist da nicht so schick wie bei iOS meint.
Genau. Also die meinten alle bisher immer, ne, also da merkt man auch so, die Apple-Jungs, die haben sich da schon sehr, sehr, sehr viel mehr Gedanken gemacht. Bei Unity ist es halt auch im Wesentlichen so, die haben halt eine Engine und alles andere ist so da hingehacktes Beiwerk. Also, die können nicht mal eine performante JSON-Library mitliefern oder HTTP-Library oder was auch immer. Das ist halt...
Ist ja auch nicht für End-Use, ist ja für Developer gemacht, ne?
Ja, aber wenn deine JSON-Library nicht JSON verstanden hat und auch noch dazu langsam ist, dann...
Also eine JSON-Library langsam hinzukriegen, muss man auch erstmal schaffen. Also, das ist ja nur wirklich kein schwieriges Format.
Apple Jungs und Mädels.
Was denn jetzt?
Ich wollte nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass das ja...
Kapitelmarke Keynote immer noch ist?
Nee, das ist einfach mehr als ein Geschlecht arbeitet bei Apple.
Ach so, Apple Jungs und Mädels.
Genau, das Keyboard gibt es ja noch und hat diesen skurrilen neuen Connector.
Na ja, gut, interessant fand ich, dass irgendjemand hat so ein Apple-Patent ausgegraben, was irgendwie deutlich älter ist als das Surface von Microsoft. Und in dem Apple-Patent, das was da drin steht, sieht verdammt aus wie das Surface. Das fand ich schon sehr witzig, samt dem Connector an der Seite. Also war das bei, wo war das? Keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich bei Patently, wie heißt diese Webseite?
Irgendwo flog das vorbei, vielleicht war es auch nur Twitter. Also fand ich nur ganz witzig, so dieses Jahr, drei Jahre nach dem Surface macht Apple jetzt auch so ein Keyboard. Aber dass sie ursprünglich mal das Patent dafür gemacht haben, das hatte irgendwie niemand auf dem Plan. Ansonsten finde ich das jetzt nicht spannend.
Ich frage mich, was alles über diesen Port geht.
Na, Strom plus Minus und Daten. Also ich meine, was soll schon rübergehen?
Das Keyboard, du meinst, ob es auch ohne...
Nein, ob man das iPad damit laden kann.
Interessante Frage.
Also kann man das iPad quer hinstellen und laden? Nachdem es kein Dock gibt, eher nicht.
Eher nicht.
Ja, aber das war ja schon immer so ein Problem bei dem Ding, dass wir halt dann immer so ein Kabel an der Seite raus...
Ja, aber meine Voraussage eher nicht.
Was eigentlich kein Problem wäre, weil wie man gesehen hat, das Pro ist ja eigentlich relativ leer an den Ecken. Da ist ja nichts mehr. Also ganz in der Mitte ist dieser CPU-Steg mit der Platine, dann links und rechts davon sind die Batterien und unten und oben ist jeweils noch so ein leerer Fächer, die sie mit so Verkreuzungen irgendwie so ein bisschen stabilisiert haben, aber da ist noch reichlich Platz und Boxen.
Ja, der Resonanzkörper für den Sound. Ja, also ich kann es mir vorstellen, wenn du dir anguckst, dass du den Stift ja über den Lightning-Port lädst, dann haben sie ja irgendeine Technologie, dass sie da nicht nur Strom so rein, sondern auch rausschieben. Zumindest aus dem Lightning-Port. Und wenn sie diese Technologie haben, dann könnten sie sie auch in diesen, wie heißt der Port eigentlich? Hat der einen Namen?
Ja, der heißt Smart Connector.
Smart Connector, oh Gott.
Da weiß ich auch nicht so ganz genau, was sie da geritten hat.
Oder ob sie da überhaupt irgendetwas geritten hat.
Hätte es doch sicherlich noch irgendeinen Namen für irgendeine andere Blitzerscheinung. Kugelblitz oder so.
Der Kugelblitz-Port. Ja, so sieht er aber auch aus, wie der Kugelblitz-Port. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ist jetzt, glaube ich, auch nicht so spannend, ob man das jetzt damit laden kann oder nicht.
Ja, aber habe ich mich so gefragt. Also, viel wissen wir nicht.
Ach, eine Sache natürlich noch. Die 4 GB RAM sind eigentlich ganz interessant. Vor allen Dingen dadurch, dass das Ding ja so hoch ist, wie das normale iPad. Das ist so, wenn man es quer hat, ist es so hoch wie das normale iPad im Hochformat. Und ich glaube doppelt so breit, wie das normale iPad breit wäre. Sprich, du hast eigentlich zwei iPads nebeneinander. Und du hast auch den Speicher dafür, zwei Anwendungen im Multitasking-Modus nebeneinander zu benutzen gleichzeitig. Das ist eigentlich ein ganz interessanter Gedanke, dass du damit also jetzt wirklich mal dieses Multitasking auch sinnvoll ist.
Ja, wobei ich glaube, diese 4 GB sind nicht so sehr... RAM. Also nicht nur... Bitte?
RAM.
Was habe ich gesagt?
Ja, die 4 GB sind nicht so sehr. Was sind die nicht so sehr?
Natürlich hilft das auch dem Multitasking, aber ich glaube, die sind vor allem deshalb auf 4 GB da drin, um einfach große 3D-Anwendungen fahren zu können. Also um wirklich auch Apps fahren zu können, die richtig Speicher auch brauchen.
Ja, auch, klar, natürlich.
Aber...
Die Office zum Beispiel.
Da braucht man bestimmt richtig RAM.
Oder diese komische Layout-App, die Adobe da gezeigt hat.
Ne, ich habe jetzt iOS 9 erfolgreich runtergeladen. Und geladen bin ich jetzt auch bei 100%. Alles super. Jetzt habe ich Public Transport Information irgendwie gleich auf der Web angeboten bekommen. Aber jetzt klicke ich hier auf Greifsweiler Straße, M10 und dann No Departure Times Available, No Upcoming Departures, the schedule may be provided bei Berliner Verkehrsbetriebe.
Ich denke, wir sind durch mit dem iPad Pro, oder? Haben wir noch irgendwie was dazu zu sagen? Mir fällt mir jetzt da irgendwie auch nicht mehr so richtig ein. Wir werden es sehen. Ach so, vielleicht noch dieser A9X-Chip. Ich meine, die haben da ein bisschen irgendwas. Was haben sie da erzählt? Das Ding sei ja schneller als 80% aller Laptops. Heißt so viel wie, ist langsamer als alle Macs. Also klingt schnell, aber heißt erst mal gar nichts.
Nee, das heißt vor allen Dingen, dass 80% aller Laptops, die verkauft werden, Crap sind, oder? Also ich meine, aber das hätte man eigentlich auch vorher gewusst.
Nee, das ist aber insofern nochmal ganz bemerkenswert, als dass es ihnen jetzt gelungen ist, oder dass, sagen wir mal, dem gesamten Markt gelingt, enorm aufzuschließen zu den etablierten Prozessorherstellern, die sich ja immer durch, ich habe beliebig viel Strom, definiert haben. Und während die halt versuchen, immer weniger Strom zu verbrauchen, was ihnen ja auch gelingt, wie man bei dem neuen MacBook zum Beispiel sieht, wie heißt diese Prozessorgeneration, die sie da verbaut haben, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Was ist dein Stichwort?
Skylake ist ja jetzt erst neu. Brassway? Ich weiß es jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau. Auf jeden Fall dieser Super-Mobile-CPU, der halt da in diesem MacBook drin ist. Genau, aber das nähert sich halt einander an. Und das nähert sich mit rasender Geschwindigkeit an.
Na ja gut, ich meine, Apple hat mit dem ARM, besonders mit dem ARM 64, halt den Vorteil, dass sie extrem viel Ballast nicht mitgeschleppt haben, die halt die Interplatform mitschleppen musste. Auch wenn, glaube ich, so dieses AMD 64 da auch relativ ballastfrei noch ist. Aber hey, na ja gut, die Diskussion hatten wir ja schon mal.
Das heißt nicht Brassway, sondern natürlich vorher. Jetzt heißt es Broadwell, so. Der Chat hat mich verbessert und Sie haben recht.
Ja, ich bin mal gespannt, wozu das noch führen wird. Ich glaube zwar jetzt nicht, dass in absehbarer Zeit wirklich Laptops auf Intel vererzielt werden.
Das geht schon von der Performance deswegen nicht in den iPads, weil in den Laptops sind schon noch fette Kühlkörper und Lüfter. Und in so einem iPad halt nicht. Da wird seine Wärme halt nicht los. Deswegen müssen die ja schon so ein bisschen langsamer machen.
Nein, im MacBook sind keine fetten Kühlkörper drin und Lüfter sind da auch keine mehr drin.
Sicher? Im kleinen R, ich weiß nicht, wie die so aussehen, aber hier sind noch Fettlüfter und Pipe und so weiter.
Dem R ist diese genannte CPU, das ist nur noch eine kleine.
Ja, aber der R ist jetzt auch nicht so wirklich schnell.
Nee, ich meine nicht R. Im MacBook, was keinen Namen hat. Nein, das MacBook, das neue, das zweite.
Ja, aber das war jetzt auch nicht unbedingt eine Performance-Kanone. Ja, okay.
Aber wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr so viel. Aber so ein MacBook Pro mit Lüftern und so einer Laptop-CPU ist schon nochmal eine andere Liga als fürs iPad.
So, was kam dann als nächstes aufs Programm?
Mach mal Reload bei deinem Flowey.
Das reloadet sich eigentlich immer.
Nee, gerade nicht.
Mach ich das mal.
Dennis hat da mal was vorbereitet.
Oh, na jetzt kommen wir zu Apple TV.
Wo ist mein Zeug?
Weiß ich nicht. Wo hast du es denn hingeschrieben?
Bei iPhone 9 habe ich ein bisschen was reingeklatscht.
Ach so, muss man ausklappen. Na wollen wir nicht erstmal, wir sind ja jetzt...
Von mir aus auch erstmal Apple TV.
Genau.
Haken wir den Scheiß ab, genau.
Ja, wir haken den Scheiß einfach ab.
Also mir wurde kein Developer bei Apple TV vergönnt.
Hast du beantragt? Und?
Na ja, wie gesagt, mir war keins vergönnt.
In der Firma jetzt oder bei Apple jetzt? Wie meinst du, wo war denn, von wem warst du denn nicht gegönnt?
Na ja, als Developer konnte man da klicken. Ich will einen Developer bei Apple TV haben. Und dann, manche Leute haben halt eins gekriegt. Ich hab halt keins gekriegt. Das ist ja auch okay. Also so richtig viele hätte ich jetzt damit nicht anfangen können.
Aber das wussten die.
Das wussten die schon, ja klar.
Na du, diese ganzen Daten, die du hier immer, wenn du ein neues Essen installierst und sie fragen, hier so Analytics irgendwie an Apple schicken und Usage-Data und so, damit profallen die dich und finden am Ende ganz genau raus.
Wahrscheinlich.
Was benutzt der junge Mann und womit kann man ihm eine Freude machen?
Ok, neues Apple TV höher, weil wahrscheinlich jetzt mit MIMO-Antennen für AC WLAN ausgestattet.
Aber immer noch Ethernet hinten drin, finde ich doch sehr schön.
Immer noch fast Ethernet hinten drin, ja.
Noch fast?
Wirklich? Wo kriegen die diese Bausteine her?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Vielleicht haben sie einfach mal ganz viele davon gekauft und die sind immer noch nicht alle.
Ich verstehe das auch nicht so richtig, weil es bedeutet, dass du mittlerweile über WLAN da schneller Daten rein und rauskriegst.
Über das Ethernet?
Jetzt kann man natürlich lange darüber argumentieren, wie schnell die Daten da rein müssen. Also was ist jetzt der Bedarf? Heutzutage ist die Anzahl von Internetzugängen, die deutlich über 100 Megabit liegen, überschaubar. Auch die musst du ja nicht vollständig zu 100 Prozent auslutschen, damit du damit einen Film angezeigt hast.
Ja, aber das ist ja wohl trotzdem nicht 3 Cent mehr für eine Asus.
Die Frage ist ja, was...
Wir reden von einem 100-150-Sofergerät.
Ja, ich verstehe das auch nicht, aber ihre Rechnung ist wahrscheinlich einfach... Das ist halt Internetzugang und nicht LAN. Das ist kein LAN-Device.
Aber kannst du nicht auch von deinem iTunes irgendwie so Sachen raufstreamen und so?
Fürs Streamen ist es halt schnell genug.
Aber du brauchst halt nicht mehr als 100 Megabits.
Wer sagt denn, dass ich das nicht brauche? Das ist doch Quatsch.
Apple sagt das. Aber du kannst mit dem Ding eh nichts machen, außer was kannst du machen? Spiele spielen und Filme gucken?
Na ja, das wird sich jetzt halt zeigen, was man damit machen kann, weil jetzt gibt es halt Apps.
Du brauchst nicht mehr Gigabit, weil damit kannst du eh nicht so viel machen.
Aber das mit den Apps ist jetzt genau der richtige Hinweis, weil du hast da irgendwie so eine absurde Grenze, wie groß deine App sein darf, und den Rest musst du dann bitteschön nachladen.
Ja gut, aber die liegt bei 200 MB in dem First Download.
Ja, trotzdem. Also ich meine...
Aber nicht auf Apple TV. Na ja, sie haben jetzt zum Beispiel in diesem TV OS, also in dem neu postulierten Geschmacksrichtung von iOS, WebKit zum Beispiel komplett rausgeschmissen.
Sie haben relativ viel komplett rausgeschmissen. Interessanterweise, es gibt ein Dokument, iOS 9 to TV OS 9 API DIVs. Da steht relativ genau drin, was anders ist. Und es gibt kein Address Book, es gibt keine Contacts, es gibt kein Chor Audio.
Es gibt keine iAds, ne?
Es gibt kein Chor Video.
Warte mal, es gibt kein Chor Audio?
Chor Audio Kit, weiß auch immer, das jetzt genau ist. Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht. Es gibt kein Chor Telefonie, ja okay.
Das heißt, wenn ich einen coolen Film habe, dann kann ich nicht in meinen Kontakt sagen, hier guck mal, ich hab eine coole Empfehlung.
Es gibt kein Health Kit, es gibt kein HomeKit.
Das gibt es auch nicht auf dem iPad.
Aber HomeKit haben sie nicht gesagt, dass HomeKit irgendwie das Ding ist.
MapKit gibt es nicht.
Was gibt es überhaupt? UI-Label.
Message-UI gibt es nicht. Multipeer-Connectivity gibt es nicht. Das ist interessant allerdings. Newsstand gibt es nicht. Notification gibt es nicht. Kein Pass-Kit, kein Fotos, kein Foto-UI, nichts.
Das kannst du ja nicht überhaupt machen.
Kein Watch-Kit.
Du kannst halt Sachen aus dem Netz holen und auf dem Screen bringen. Und du kannst Games machen.
Es gibt Scene-Kit, es gibt Brite-Kit, es gibt Store-Kit, es gibt UI-Kit, natürlich. Metal gibt es.
Animation, halt dieser ganze Grafiklimb. Game-Kit. Aber du musst halt auch alles generisch mit so, wie das gedacht ist, machen. Und du kannst halt nicht irgendeinen HTML auf den Screen werfen.
Nein, HTML gibt es tatsächlich überhaupt gar nicht.
Das finde ich auch sehr anständig.
Auch wenn ich dafür jetzt... Und iAds, ne?
Zumindest, wenn ich fünf Hater eingetreten habe.
Ich sag mal so, irgendjemand schrieb, da werden sehr viele Leute stöhnen, weil eigentlich jede iOS-App irgendwo diese dreckige Ecke hat, wo irgendjemand dann doch ein Webview verwendet, um irgendwas zu machen, was er zu faul war, richtig zu machen.
Genau.
Und genau diese Ecken müssen nämlich dann alle aufgeräumt werden. Das ist so cool.
Das ist so der Stahlbesen, den sie dann doch irgendwie nochmal aus dem Strand geurteilt haben.
Und zwar teilweise abstruse Sachen. Also ich kenne da eine App, sag ich mal so. Da war mal... In einer Tabelle gab es einen... Na ja, du konntest da so eine Homepage-Link anzeigen. Und nur um diesen verdammten Text zu unterstreichen, wurde da eine Webview verwendet. Er guckt schon. Jaja, so mit Tappen drauf und dann den Tab abfangen. Mir auch noch ein Bier, bitte.
Und mir auch noch, bitte. Mir auch noch.
Ich nehme Saft.
Ja, also...
Ich will zweimal O-Saft, bitte.
Ich einmal O-Saft. An Tisch zwei.
Was noch cool ist, ist, dass VLC schon angekündigt hat, dass sie ihr VLC fürs TV-OS portieren werden.
Ja, das ist natürlich total sinnvoll, dass sie das tun wollen.
Ja, weil wie soll ich sonst meine MKVs abspielen? Mit Wort?
Genau, der Hörer hat es auch nicht verstanden.
Das ist doch hier diese Software, mit der du dir quasi ein eigenes Medienarchiv auf dein Server ballern kannst. Das läuft dann auf deinem NAS oder auf deinem KleinstPC. Und dann kannst du das überall hin streamen. Und das macht auch gleich dein Recoding.
Dann glüht jedes Mal mein Router, weil ich mal einen Film gucke.
Dann muss es ja nicht unbedingt in Realtime machen. Der kann das ja sozusagen auch in the background machen.
Und muss dann den doppelten Speicher vorhalten.
Wenn du unbedingt MKV gucken willst, mit esoterischen Codex, dann ist das halt so.
Ich dachte, MKV ist das Container-Format.
Aber wir schweifen schon wieder ab. MKV ist das Container-Format, in dem sich sehr häufig H264 befindet. Und da ist es dann auch nicht so das Problem. Aber du weißt ja, es gibt ja dann auch noch so die Ecken im Internet, wo halt so ein VP9 und dieser ganze Kram.
Ja, okay. Ja, Max ist nicht da. Sonst könnten wir da noch mal länger drüber reden.
Aber bleiben wir nochmal bei dem Apple TV und wie sie es gemacht haben. Also was sie jetzt überhaupt erst mal gemacht haben, ist, sie haben diese Grundidee des schon vor Jahren überarbeiteten UIs nochmal überarbeitet. Und das Ganze ist jetzt sehr viel zappeliger und lebendiger. Und kommt halt jetzt mit dieser Remote, die halt so einen Sensorbereich, also einen Touchpad-Bereich hat, den man wohl auch irgendwie klicken kann oder tappen kann.
Du kannst zumindest swipen und so.
Ja, aber du kannst halt auch so ein Tap- oder Click-Ding auslösen, wie sich das anfühlt, weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau. Und du hast insgesamt sechs Buttons da drauf. Und korrigiert mich, ob ich das jetzt richtig mitbekommen habe?
Keiner mehr als vorher, ja.
Das Ding hat auch Infrarot oder hat es nicht?
Ne, Bluetooth haben wir gesagt.
Das hab ich nicht gesehen. Also Bluetooth wahrscheinlich.
Also Infrarot für lauter, leiser.
Also die haben auf der Präsentation gesagt Bluetooth.
Ja, Infrarot hat auch Stande.
Infrarot ist jetzt wirklich mal... Jeden auf deinem Device ist es wirklich vorbei.
Ja gut, wie willst du sonst lauter, leiser machen? Also entweder macht es...
Na, du hast den lauter, leiser Button.
Ja, und dann?
Drückst du da drauf und dann macht Bluetooth, hallo, mach mal leiser.
Also hier sagt ja einer im Chat, die Fernbedienung hat auch Infrarot.
Genau.
Um am TV lauter, leiser zu machen. Ach, lernt der das dann an der...
Ja, die alte war ja auch schon so drauf.
Das ist natürlich sinnvoll, dass man den Fernseher lauter, leiser macht und nicht die Apple TV, weil wenn du leiser machst, dann bleibt das Brummen vom Fernseher trotzdem lauter.
Genau, vor allem theoretisch wäre es ja auch möglich. Das Ding hat ja jetzt auch nur noch einen HDMI-Ausgang und keinen optischen Audio-Ausgang mehr. Den haben sie sich jetzt auch gespart. Und sie unterstützen diesen, wie heißt das, CIC, gibt es im Prinzip dann noch so eine Leitung auf diesem HDMI-Stecker mit deinen 1000 Leitungen, wo du im Prinzip Kommandos an andere angeschlossene Geräte durchleiten kannst. Also sozusagen alle anschalten, ausschalten oder halt auch lauter leiser und so weiter. Kannst du theoretisch auch von dem Apple TV über HDMI machen. Und im Prinzip müssten das heute eigentlich alle können, nur faktisch funktioniert das eben sehr oft auch nicht wirklich. Und ich vermute mal, sie haben diese kleine Infrarotgeschichte da einfach noch mit drin gelassen, um da einfach die Rückwärtskompatibilität damit einfach zu haben.
Es ist total sinnvoll, du lernst dann die Fernbedienung an mit dem Lauter-Leiser-Commandos und gut ist.
Exakt. So, und jetzt gibt es halt diesen Controller und du musst halt deine App, wenn du fürs TV, OS hackst, musst halt damit laufen. Du darfst nicht jetzt einfach irgendeinen Game-Controller supporten und fertig ist die Laube.
Ganz genau habe ich es mir nicht angeguckt. Das ist nur ein bisschen komisch, weil wenn du... Also ich habe hier mal in dem neuen Xcode Beta ein Projekt aufgemacht und so ein Standardprojekt angefangen. Und dann stehst du natürlich erstmal davor, wie bediene ich denn das jetzt? Weil mit der Maus nicht, sondern es sind tatsächlich hoch runter, vor und zurück, return und escape, genauso wie man sich das vorstellen würde, dass man die benutzt. Also keine Ahnung, wie das jetzt genau funktionieren soll.
Also ich meine, mich erinnern zu können, dass wir hier vor längerer Zeit schon mal so eine Debatte um Apple TV und in welche Richtung das geht, soll gehabt haben. Wenn irgendjemand der Hörer in der Lage ist, diese Sendung nochmal hervorzukramen, ich würde mir das gerne mal anhören, was wir da eigentlich zu gesagt haben. Aber ich meine, mich erinnern zu können, dass wir schon uns einig waren oder es zumindest zur Sprache kam, dass so dieses, was sich ja eigentlich bei dem alten Apple TV schon abgezeichnet hat, dass du dieses, du hast so einen App-Kontext, das gab es ja im Prinzip, also zumindest von der Bedienung her, du hattest ja schon immer diese Buttons. Das waren halt nicht Apps im Sinne von technisch programmiert wie eine App, sondern eben, ja auch immer Apple das entwickelt oder hat entwickeln lassen.
Wahrscheinlich war es schon immer dieses iOS für Apple TV.
Genau, aber wahrscheinlich waren das einfach nur so sehr einfache Templates, in die du da deine App reingießen konntest, damit da eben gar nicht so viel Flexibilität ist. Sonst hätten wir da wahrscheinlich auch schon sehr viel mehr Innovationen gesehen. Und Apple hat das vielleicht auch selber gemacht, weiß ich nicht, werden wir vielleicht nie erfahren. Jetzt ist das auf jeden Fall nicht mehr so. So oder so ist aber diese Idee, dass quasi die App, der Zugang zu dem Content ist, den man normalerweise als Fernsehen kriegt. Also schalt mal heute ein Fernsehen ein.
Lieber nicht.
Das ist schlimm. Ich habe das jetzt gerade mal wieder gemacht, weil ich festgestellt hatte, dass ich irgendwie seit einem Jahr Fernsehen bei mir in der Wohnung hatte, wovon ich gar nichts wusste, weil da ist irgendwie so hausintern die ganze Klingelanlage und alles ist irgendwie so vom Hausbesitzer her einmal neu gemacht worden. Und damit ist dann irgendwie auch Kabel Deutschland offiziell in das Haus reinmarschiert.
Keine DVB-T-Hausantenne?
Und du hast in der Mietvertrag auch so, du zahlst das schon?
Ja, wir zahlen noch irgendwas, aber ich habe dem nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit gewidmet. Und jetzt habe ich halt festgestellt, dass tatsächlich so eine Grundversorgung... Das ist ein Fernsehen. Ich musste nur mal ein Kabel reinstecken so. Woran wollte ich hinaus? Dass diese Darreichung, genau und alles kommt übers Fernsehen und du hast halt so Fernsehprogramme, die so voll mit Overlays sind. Ja, Untertitel laufen durch, Zeit wird angezeigt, sonstige Spielstände, Aktien, Werbung und so. Also irgendwie total bekloppt, alles wird sozusagen in Video gerendert und dann als ein Videostrom dargereicht und ist überhaupt in keiner Form konfigurierbar oder anpassbar und du wirst einfach die ganze Zeit mit diesem visuellen Lärm belästigt. Zusätzlich noch zu diesem inhaltlichen Lärm, der da ohnehin schon angerauscht kommt. Na ich gucke mir ehrlich gesagt, also das einzige Programm, was ich glaube ich häufiger sehe in der Woche, ist Kika.
Läuft eigentlich noch Berndtas Brot in der Nachtschleife?
Das habe ich auch schon mal gesehen. In der Nachtschleife?
Das war doch früher immer in der Nachtschleife.
Ah, naja, ich habe ja bisher immer mit DVB-T geguckt und dann hat sich das nicht mit irgendeinem anderen Kanal nachts irgendwie ausgetauscht. Ich weiß nicht, ich schaue wirklich...
Das ist auch lange her, dass ich Berndtas Brot in der Nachtschleife gesehen habe, aber das war eine heitere Zeit.
Man koketiert ja gerne damit, dass man es nicht macht, aber ich gucke wirklich sau wenig Fernsehen und habe da einfach den Anschluss an die Realität verloren. Und wenn ich mal wieder reinschaue, dann weiß ich auch warum.
An die Realität ist gut.
Genau.
Nicht Fernsehen und dann den Anschluss an die Realität verpassen zu nennen, finde ich jetzt mal sehr, sehr gewagt.
Die Realität der Anderen.
Ja, Tele-Realität oder wie auch immer.
Tele-Realität. Flüchtlingskrise und so. Man ist ja geradezu gezwungen, sich zumindest mal so eine Tagesschau anzugucken, einfach nur um zu checken, was bei den Anderen einfach so durchgespült wird.
Aber das kannst du ja auch im Internet machen.
Das ist aber nicht das Gleiche. Also du musst es schon auch manchmal auf den wenigen Kanälen runtergedampften Videostrom auch reduzieren, damit du mitfühlen kannst, wie die Gewichtung ist.
Kuratiert nennt man das heutzutage.
Ja, genau. Zurück zu den Apps. Weil eigentlich reden wir ja über Apple TV. Die Idee mit den Apps als Durchleiter und Filter und Konfigurator für deinen Informationsflow, die Idee ist halt super, weil jetzt kannst du eben diese ganzen Overlays quasi in Programmcode auf dem Gerät machen. Das wird so sein. Sie haben ja dieses Beispiel mit diesem Basketball-Sender da gezeigt. Basketball-Sender? Nein, nicht Basketball, Baseball.
Baseball, machen die nur Baseball?
Ja, das ist ja auch noch so schwierig, diesen Apple Keynote zu folgen, weil die halt die ganze Zeit immer so Sportarten zitieren, die kein Mensch kennt. Ich bin ja schon... Ja, meine Reaktion war so......Millimeter gesagt haben auf dieser Keynote.
Ja, aber dann das Gewicht wieder empfunden.
Ja, genau, das Gewicht muss dann wieder abhauen.
Aber ich sei froh, dass ich an Stones war.
Ehrlich gesagt, als sie da anfingen, dann irgendwie zwei Spiele gleichzeitig zu zeigen, dachte ich mir so, ja genau, so ist der Sport aber auch. Da guckt man zwei gleichzeitig, weil einer ist zu langweilig.
Ja, da passiert viel zu wenig.
Da passiert nichts, also guckst du zwei gleichzeitig.
Ja, aber hatten wir ja letztes Mal schon gesagt, dass die Amis das mit dem Sportfernsehen verstanden haben im Internet, das zeigte sich ja auch da halt. Das kommt mit NBA und so weiter wahrscheinlich auch noch alles. Aber du hast halt da überall diese ganzen Daten einfach zusätzlich zu deinem Videostream, den du wahlweise einschalten kannst. Ich dachte mir halt auch, ich meine hier jetzt im Fußball zum Beispiel, die haben ja auch dieses ganze Position-Tracking von den Plänen, die wissen, wie schnell die laufen, wie weit die gelaufen sind, wie viele Pässe die gemacht haben, wie genau die Pässe waren und so weiter. Warum kann ich nicht jetzt zum Beispiel auch von Sky oder so eine App haben? Ja, was auch immer, genau. So, Videostrom kommt an und dann kann ich mir diese ganzen Statistiken, die ja eh schon da sind, ja und dafür würde ich ja auch für diese Zusatzleistungen, da würde ich auch sehen, okay, das ist ein Mehrwert jetzt, würde ich auch sogar was für bezahlen. Und die Daten sind ja eh da. Warum kriegt jetzt nur der Moderator und die ja dann irgendwie alle paar Nasen lang nach Lust und Laune zitiert, warum kriege ich die nicht? Ich will die auch machen.
Ja, weil du dann sofort erkennen würdest, was der Moderator für einen Dünnpfiff redet. Gut, das erkennt man auch so.
Das ist ja noch eine andere Dimension. Aber da sind die Amis halt einfach viel weiter vorne dabei. Wie gesagt, bei der NBA ist das ja auch schon so mit diesen ganzen Statistiken und Aufbearbeitung und View-on-Demand, das haben die schon so lange. Und da kann man hier in Deutschland auf jeden Fall nur die Frau richtig hinterher gucken. Aber dann ist es halt eben so, ne? Amis-Sport interessiert halt keine Sau.
Aber was wird jetzt passieren? Ich meine, 150 Euro kostet das Ding wahrscheinlich hier dann, in Deutschland, das ist jetzt so ein vertretbarer Preis, würde ich sagen. Das wird durchaus eine Abnehmer finden. So, und jetzt gibt es halt so einen Tempting-Kanal. Es gibt so ein Gerät, wo halt diese ganze Abwolke aus der iOS-Landschaft schrittweise drauf landen wird.
Hinabregnet.
Also alles, was du heute schon an Live-Video-Übertragungs-End-Apps auf iOS hast, das wird da landen.
Ich glaube, der eigentliche große Trigger, den verschweigst du hier. Also ich glaube, dass Spiele das große Ding sind. Doch, doch, also es wird die Apple TV. Also ich habe mir jetzt zweimal die Diskussion geliefert mit jemandem, wo er sagt, ja, der Playstation, Xbox geht nie weg und so. Es ist überhaupt keine Konkurrenz. Stimmt auch, ist auch überhaupt keine Konkurrenz. Aber wenn jetzt jemand so wie dieses, wie hieß das mit dem Huhn, was da über die Straße rennt? Ja genau, Frogger mit Huhn. Da hast du ja gesehen, wie schnell die da ihren Scheiß portiert haben. Und bei anderen Spielen ist das ja nicht viel anders.
Ja, du musstest es nicht nur... Technisch ist das Portieren wahrscheinlich einfach, wenn du nicht viel Webkit-Kram drin hast. Es ist nur vom Controller her natürlich so eine Frage. Weil du hast halt keinen Touch.
Ja, doch, du hast den Touch.
Ja, du hast Touch, aber nur im Sinne von einfachen Slide-Gesten. Du hast keine Positionierung, du hast keinen Cursor, du hast keinen Ort, auf den du tippst.
Das ist richtig. Aber wenn du dir anguckst, wie die ganzen Casual Games mit dem eigentlichen Control-Mechanismen umgehen, dann hast du, klar, du hast einige, wo du Sachen auf dem Screen anfasst, um sie direkt zu manipulieren. Aber dann hast du halt viel auch so Sachen wie, wie war denn das, Flappy Birds, wo du nur drückst oder loslässt. Ich mein, sowas ist ja nur...
Klar, dass das, hier Tiny Wings und so weiter, das wird da alles wunderbar funktionieren und super ankommen. Du hast recht, also Casual Gaming auf dem Fernseher wird dann ein Thing sein. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ob es jetzt größer ist als die Sogwirkung, die eine DFL-App erzeugen kann, da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher.
Kommt drauf an, bei welchen Leuten, natürlich.
Aber es gibt, sagen wir mal, weitere Aspekte, als nur, welche Fernsehkanäle kann ich damit empfangen, die zum Kauf eines solchen Geräts führen können. Und das ist sicherlich etwas, was sich gegenseitig befruchtet. Und von daher ist die Strategie, erst mal auf diese beiden Pferde zu setzen und andere potenzielle Pferde rauszulassen, ist gut. Also sie haben jetzt kein Keynote für Apple TV angekündigt.
Also sie haben es nicht angekündigt. Das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass es nicht kommt.
Nein, nein, das heißt nicht, dass es nicht kommt. Aber sie haben es jetzt erst mal nicht für notwendig erachtet.
Na ja, solange das Ding irgendwie Airplay kann, brauchst du auch kein Keynote für Apple TV.
Noch mal eine andere Frage. Kann eigentlich dieses Amazon Fire Stick oder wie auch immer die anderen Produkte da alle heißen, können die nicht eigentlich auch sowas wie HBO, Netflix und Hulu und diesen ganzen anderen Kempel?
Google Chromecast oder wie das Ding heißt.
Ja und dieses Amazon Fire, was ist denn da so der... Also es gibt ja Leute, die machen gleich so, ja jetzt kommt jetzt das Apple TV raus, es ist schon langsamer als die anderen Geräte von vornherein und irgendwie so richtig doll was anderes kann das jetzt auch nicht. Hat sich da mal jemand mit der Konkurrenz beschäftigt?
Amazon macht mal Amazon.
Google macht alles wie immer.
Alle anderen Boxen machen auch alle Netflix. Und auch Apple setzt ja auch darauf.
Na gut, das konnte Apple TV vorher ja auch schon. Das, was alle machen wie Netflix, oder? War ja auch auf dem Apple TV.
Eben, also.
Dem habe ich ja auch nicht widersprochen. Das ist halt das, was da eben...
Gibt es denn für die anderen Kisten eine App-Store? Oder zumindest eine Third-Party-Anbieter-Lösung?
Da müssen wir mal den Chat reinrufen.
Nein, bei den anderen ist es halt so, wie es jetzt beim Apple TV bisher war. Und jetzt eben nicht mehr sein wird.
Also eigentlich eine Closed-Lösung, wo man halt besondere Beziehungen zu Amazon haben muss, um dann da draufzukommen.
Keiner kommt bei Amazon drauf, soweit ich weiß. Amazon macht nur Amazon, genauso wie mit dem Kindle halt.
Hier sagt jemand, Fire TV hat einen App-Store. Kann jeder rein.
Fire TV hat einen App-Store. Und was kann man dann da für Apps laden?
Und Google hat den Play Store. Das habe ich mir nämlich schon gedacht.
Ja gut, aber was kommt da rein?
Natürlich alles die Freiheit. Keine Restriktionen.
Freiheit bei Amazon, na, viel Spaß.
Na ja, immerhin bei Google.
Trojaner.
Wir sollten nicht über Sachen reden, von denen wir nichts verstehen. Also ich sollte das zumindest nicht tun.
Wie gesagt, ich hätte mich jetzt...
Wir machen das für dich.
Weil ich das jetzt eben auch noch nicht... Weil ich prinzipiell in diesen ganzen Boxen quasi null Bedarf habe, weil ich keinen Fernseher habe und jetzt auch nicht unbedingt einen will und eigentlich direkt immer auf den Rechner kick.
Was ich eigentlich will, ist kein Fernseher, sondern was ich will, ist ein größeres Display. Diesen ganzen Mumble, Chai-Star, Media, Shit, Steuer, hast du nicht gesehen, brauch ich alles nicht. Eigentlich nicht mal boxen, wenn ich es genau nehme. Weil die stehen da schon daneben, brauchen genug Platz.
In diesem Zusammenhang habe ich gelesen, aber noch nicht wirklich groß hinterher recherchiert, dass dir auch die ganze Airplay-Technologie sich jetzt wieder geändert hat. Dass sie jetzt mit dem neuen Apple TV auch ein neues Protokoll für Airplay oder zumindest eine Überarbeitung des bestehenden... Ihr guckt glasig, ihr habt davon noch nichts gesehen. Ich habe jetzt bisher auch nur Erwähnungen davon gelesen, an verschiedenen Stellen, aber noch nichts umfangreiches.
Okay, bleibt Hausaufgabe.
Ja, genau, also da tut sich sicherlich was. Ich vermute mal, dass das Performance-Gründer hat, weil da war ja auf jeden Fall noch eine ganze Menge.
Wahrscheinlich, weil das Alte von zu viel nachgemacht wird und das Neue ist bestimmt sicher mit Krypto und Dicht.
Ja, das Alte war aber auch wirklich simplest. Also war wirklich nicht schwierig.
Doch, weil ich habe noch nichts gesehen, was es ordentlich hinkriegt, sodass es funktioniert. Also funktioniert tut es immer, aber nicht verlässlich.
Oh, naja gut.
Zurück zur Apple TV und diesem ganzen Content-Kram. Also wir stellen jetzt fest, irgendwelche Fernseh-Film-Abspiele, Buden wie Netflix kommen eigentlich überall mit durch. Und Apple TV hat aber den anderen gegenüber den Vorteil, dass es halt potenziell jetzt auch eine Spieleplattform sein kann. Und sie werden aber sicherlich jetzt nicht in dem Bereich brillieren von Anfang an, wo jetzt eine Xbox zu Hause ist.
Eine Hardcore-Gamer sicherlich nicht.
Aber ich glaube, so einer Nintendo Wii können sie schon richtig Sorgen bereiten. Weil die Performance haben sie auch allemal. Sie haben auch vergleichbare Controller-Möglichkeiten.
Die neueste Generation Konsolen, da steckt sie eine Blu-ray-Disc rein. Da sind 25 GB Speicher drauf. Also das ist halt mal ein anderer Schnack, als wenn du jetzt so eine Kiste hast.
Ja stimmt, weil du musst eine Blu-ray haben.
Ja, du kaufst ja mal auch die Spiele viel teurer.
Nein, aber die Spiele haben halt dann auch Content für 25 GB.
Mit 100 MBit Interface geht das natürlich nicht, ne?
Na ja, insofern, das ist halt eine andere Liga. Das soll ja auch eine andere Liga sein. Und dass Apple da nicht mitspielt, hey...
Wie bei der Watch, das ist halt jetzt so gesehen, für das, was sie da vorhaben, das erste Apple-TV-Produkt, die vorherigen zählen ja nicht richtig, weil es hat ja auch dieses TV-OS nicht. Das heißt, die müssen auch erst mal rausfinden. Und wir müssen erst mal sehen, in welche Richtung das gehen wird, ob das hauptsächlich für Netflix oder hauptsächlich zum Zocken benutzt wird. Und dann kann man aber weitergucken. Und ich denke, wenn Apple das sieht, in welche Richtung sich das entwickelt, werden die da auch ihren Schwerpunkt dementsprechend in die Richtung legen.
Also, wir können ja mal kurz den Kaufentest machen. Also, ein iPad Pro, denke ich, kaufen wir uns alle nicht.
Richtig?
Korrekt.
Und ein Apple TV...
Ne.
Was soll ich denn...
Ich habe keinen Fernseher, der HDMI spricht, insofern.
Denkst du, wenn ich hätte. Also, was soll ich mit dem Ding?
Du hast keinen Fernseher, der HDMI spricht, insofern.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich hab keinen Fernseher.
Naja, so eine Röhrenmühle halt.
Echt?
Was?
Ja, die ist noch nicht komplett abgelebt und irgendwie...
Die Sau will nicht sterben.
Ich meine, ein Flachbild oder dann eine Runde.
Timme, willst du dir ein Apple TV holen? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Was machst du damit?
Na, das, was ich jetzt mit dem Apple TV auch schon mache.
Was machst du denn jetzt mit dem Apple TV?
Na, einerseits Airplay, andererseits halt Filme angucken.
Für deine Kids oder selber?
Vor allem die Kids so, weil...
Und die Filme, die du guckst, die könntest du nicht auf deinem Laptop haben und das Laptop an deinem Display oder was auch immer. Oder du hast ansteckend, das geht nicht, oder wie?
Aber dann kann er sein Laptop nicht benutzen.
Wenn du da so eine Horde schreiender Kinder, wie du vor einer halben Stunde versprochen hast, dass du jetzt The Incredibles anguckst, wenn du die da hast, dann ist das letzte, was du machen willst, ist dich mit Airplay-Problemen rumzuschlagen, deinen Router-Konfiguration aufzurufen oder irgendwas nur neu zu verbuten oder zu verkabeln. Du willst einfach auf Play drücken und deine Ruhe haben. Und das ist einfach mal, das funktioniert mit diesem Gerät. Kinder-Ruhesteller.
Also qualitätsmäßig, vom Anspruch her, sind die Kinder schon der Steve Jobs in der Familie.
Also ich meine, man kann jetzt, klar, DAM und alles Scheiße und Copyright und Pipapo und hast nicht gesehen, meinetwegen. Aber du kannst da hingehen und sagen, ich kauf mir das Ding jetzt hier in HD. Und bei Kinderfilmen hat das ja auch noch den, also Filme, die Kinder interessieren, die werden ja nicht nur einmal geguckt, sondern die werden immer wieder geguckt.
Ah, reale Berrjungfrau, wie oft?
Den hatten wir jetzt irgendwie noch nicht. Ich versuche andere Themen ins Spiel zu bringen, aber...
Kevin alleine zu Hause. Den hätte ich irgendwie wahrscheinlich nicht.
Nee, aber halt hier so Monster AG, der ganze Pixar-Kram.
Die hast du auch alle nicht gemietet, sondern gehören, weil die werden immer wieder geguckt.
Nicht alle, aber manches halt so.
So Filme, die halt mit den Kids irgendwie populär sind. Und dann drückst du einfach Play und dann spielt dir das ab und es sieht gut aus. Klar, gibt es Einschränkungen, weil, was ist mit Englisch, was ist mit Deutsch, hast du da mehrere Audiospuren, hast du da Untertitel, will man ja alles irgendwie auch machen.
Kann das überhaupt jetzt der iTunes-Store, dass du da Untertitel mit einblenden kannst?
Ja, das...
Kann man sich die Sprache aussuchen oder kaufst du sie in Deutsch und darfst sie dann für Englisch nochmal kaufen?
Es ist halt mal so, mal so und alles ist irgendwie komisch und wormig und ich hoffe, dass sich das verbessert, weil das ist eigentlich ein Unding, dass du so viel Geld ausgibst und sie sind noch nicht mal in der Lage, dir mal zumindest ein paar, also zumindest mal das Original dazu zu geben. Weil das hat ja auch einen didaktischen Grund. Also ist bei uns halt auch so, weil die Kids können halt Englisch und wir wollen das Englisch halt machen und dann ist halt so die Frage, ja wir wollen einen Film gucken. Also ja, aber nur auf Englisch.
Das sagen die Kinder.
Nee, ich. Also ihr dürft jetzt den Film gucken, aber ihr dürft ihn nur auf Englisch gucken. Und dann haben sie die Wahl zwischen Film gucken auf Englisch oder kein Film gucken. So, und so lernen sie halt Englisch oder trainieren das halt, das ist irgendwie ganz hilfreich. Also so eine Box macht schon Sinn, das ist das, was ich sagen will. Und wenn jetzt auch noch Spiele dazukommen und wenn jetzt auch noch coole Interfaces für interessante Sachen dazukommen, jeder kann jetzt so eine App da reinbringen. Du kannst halt da, was weiß ich, deine Webcams mitkoppeln, du kannst allen möglichen Climb in machen und du kannst Spiele, Daten visualisieren. Du kannst ja, was weiß ich, wir könnten eine Kongress-App machen für den Kongress. Dann hast du da eine 32C3-App und dann blendet die halt auch immer den Live-Schedule links an und du kannst dann halt mit ein, zwei Streams parallel hinterschalten.
Trotto hat die doch schon längst angefangen.
Niemals ehrlich, also ich meine gerade für sowas wie den Kongress ist das super, ja, dann hast du unten noch so eine Info-Laufleiste, wo Dinge passieren, also das ist einfach cool.
Also das heißt, du willst so ein Ding, wir drei nicht.
Also ich habe weder Fernseher noch Kinder, von daher.
Also auch ohne Kinder, ich habe ja auch hier an meinem Beamer, habe ich halt auch eine dran, weil das halt einfach die praktischste Möglichkeit der Zuspielung ist. Ganz einfach. Also allein schon für Airplay ist das Ding sinnvoll.
Ja okay, aber für Airplay bräuchte man jetzt nicht die neue.
Nee, stimmt.
Und 150 Euro ist auch eine andere Ansage als jetzt die 70 Euro, die wir zuletzt da aufgerufen bekommen haben. Also ich verstehe das auch nicht so richtig, warum das Ding eigentlich so teuer ist.
Na, weil es schon ein bisschen mehr kann, weil es ja Spiele abspielt.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, das Ding hat sich fünf Jahre lang seinen Prozessor nicht geändert und jetzt sind sie mit einem A8 dabei. Also das ist das Teil vom letzten Jahr.
Ja, aber du kriegst die Fernbedienung noch dazu, also die ist natürlich jetzt neu.
Die kostet ja alleine schon 99 Euro.
Aber du gehst dann natürlich auch wieder von der falschen Richtung ran. Also Apple fragt ja nicht, wie viel kostet mich das Ding herzustellen, sondern für wie viel kann ich es denn verkaufen? Und wenn sie der Meinung sind, sie können 150 nehmen, dann nehmen sie 150. Das ist ja logisch. Das nennt man dann Marktwirtschaft.
Ja gut, aber ich denke, dass sie ein größeres Interesse daran haben, da die Plattform möglichst breit aufzustellen und erst mal einen großen Markt zu schaffen für diesen App-Store, als dass es ihnen jetzt da um den letzten Markt geht. Also es ist schon knapp kalkuliert, aber ich dachte, sie könnten es noch knapper kalkulieren.
Worüber wir übrigens gar nicht gesprochen haben, war dieses ganze Siri-Gedöns über diese Fernbedienung. Hey Siri!
Das ist Apple TV, das auch mit Siri funktioniert.
Ja genau, du hast halt diese Siri-Taste und dann drückst du da drauf und laberst in die Fernbedienung rein und dann tut er angeblich Wunder-Dinge.
Ja, ich glaube auch in zunehmendem Maße, dass das eine gute Idee ist, im Sinne von, dass es funktioniert. Ich bin echt erstaunt, weil durch die Watch benutze ich ja überhaupt erst mal Siri. Ich hab das irgendwie seit es das gibt eigentlich immer ignoriert und abgelehnt und fand das immer doof. Und ein bisschen doof finde ich es auch immer noch, aber Talk to the Hand funktioniert halt relativ gut. Und hab halt jetzt so Sachen ausprobiert in letzter Zeit, wo ich dann doch immer wieder erstaunt war, dass das jetzt irgendwie auch geht. Vor allem gehe ich in zunehmendem Maße dazu über, weg von dieser Nerd geprägten Maschinensprache. Anlegen, Termin, morgen 19 Uhr.
So hast du mit Siri gesprochen.
Das bedeutet schwierig mit den Titeln. Ja, also was war das Letzte, was ich ausprobiert habe? Mal kurz gucken, wie privat das war, was hab ich gesagt?
Du benutzt jetzt auf jeden Fall Siri.
Na, sag mal so, was sagst du konkret, um jemanden auf dem Mobiltelefon anzurufen?
Es gibt einen intimsten Siri-Details-Preis.
Nehmen wir einen generischen Namen, sagen wir. Peter?
Ich würde sagen, ich würde Peter anrufen, wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung.
Wie würdest du darauf hinweisen, dass das Mobiltelefon und nicht das Festnetz genommen werden sollen?
Auf dem Handy?
Ja. Hast du das gemacht oder würdest du es vielleicht tun?
Würde ich vielleicht tun.
Also ich spreche nicht mit Siri.
Sie ist schon ganz beleidigt, aber ich tue das nicht.
Aber das funktioniert. Also genau das habe ich probiert.
Was ich immer gemacht habe war...
Ruf Peter auf dem Handy an.
Geht.
Und weißt du, wenn er mehrere Mobilnummern hat, wie es bei manchen dazu üblich ist?
Dann präsentiert er dir eine Liste und dann kannst du auswählen.
Wählen Sie eins für...
Und es geht auch mit den Nicknames. Dann kommt so ein, meinten Sie Peter A, Peter B, Peter C, was auch immer?
Du kannst sagen, ruf Roddy an, und dann ruft er Roddy an.
Meinten Sie den schwarzen Peter?
Ich kann ja hier mal auf meiner Uhr einfach sagen hier. Ruf Roddy auf dem Handy an.
Na jetzt werden wir mal gespannt. Dann gehe ich mal mit der Uhr ran.
Die Handy-Nummer von Rutger Dicke wird angerufen.
Hast du seinen Clan am Preis gegeben?
Das steht auch auf der Webseite.
Ja, insofern.
Und das klingelt richtig? Zumindest versucht er anzurufen. Jetzt muss er natürlich auch nochmal in diesem Studio. Also bei mir klingelt es schon.
Doch schon so schnell, ja.
So, hat funktioniert. Und da kann man dann glaube ich auch schon auf diesem Apple TV... Nee, ich hab das aufgelegt. Du musst jetzt nicht mit mir telefonieren.
Jetzt reden wir so durch die Uhr.
So, und wenn ich halt jetzt so vom Fernseher sitze und dann halt nach Sendung suche, weil das ist ja total elend, diese Eingabe mit Fernbedienung, mit hoch, runter, links, rechts und Tastatur und so, das ging ja überhaupt nicht. Also auch schon dieses Remote auf dem Telefon ging nicht.
Naja, habe ich, wie gesagt, nie gemacht.
Jetzt kannst du dich da hinsetzen und sagen, ich will die Incredibles gucken.
Nee, was ich manchmal tatsächlich mache, ist halt diese Diktierfunktion auf der Uhr, dass es halt, wenn eine Message reinkommt und man will da sofort antworten, und dann spricht man das halt schnell in die Uhr rein und dann kriegt er das in der Regel auch halbwegs fehlerfrei hin. Na ja, Controller von anderen Anbietern steht hier noch mit der neuen Apple TV. Also irgendwelche Game-Controller wird man anschließen können, benutzen können.
Richtig, weil da gibt es ja schon seit längerem so ein Standard, den Apple da definiert hat schon vor 2 Jahren oder so.
Das beantwortet aber deine Game-Controller-Frage letzten Endes auch.
Welche?
Na ja, wie steuert man dann die Spiele?
Ja, das Ding ist, die Apps dürfen nicht diese anderen Controller voraussetzen. Du kommst nicht durch den App-Store durch, wenn dein Ding nicht mit dem Standard-Controller funktioniert in allen Funktionen. Also du musst dir ein Bedienungskonzept aussuchen, was halt mit dieser Siri-Remote funktioniert. Und das ist natürlich schon...
Siri, Spielfigur hoch!
Spielfigur hoch! Spielfigur hoch! Schlage links! Gib alles!
Nein, nicht den Rocket-Launcher!
Scheiße!
Genau, Siri gewinnete den Level, tötete den Boss.
Das war ja einfach. So haben wir noch was mit Apple TV, sonst ist es langsam ausgelutscht, finde ich.
Ja, ist es.
Also nicht nur langsam.
Nee, richtig ausgelutscht.
Also richtig erbarmungslos mit den letzten Töpfen.
Aber jetzt wird es noch langweiliger. Neue iPhones. Dann machen wir doch erstmal gleich den Kauftest.
Ja.
Du wirst auf 6S upgraden. Weil du das musst, du bist Developer und die haben immer eine gute Ausrede.
Naja, ich bin jetzt auf 5S.
Du bist einfach dran.
Ich bin erstens sowieso dran. Und zweitens, warum nicht?
Also ich sag mal so wirklich, wenn ich jetzt diese alten Fünfer-Generationen in der Hand halte, das ist genau wie mit allem anderen, was man am Anfang so denkt. Ja, geht ja gar nicht. Wenn du es dir dann nach einem halben Jahr wieder anguckst, denkst du dir, das schneidet mir ja direkt das Fleisch von den Knochen, diese scharfen Kanten von diesem Gerät. Es ist irgendwie klobig, es ist klein und furzlig. Ja, okay, du hast Nöle, aber es ist irgendwie, also man hat den gleichen Effekt, dass man sich das alte Gerät dann wieder handelt und denkt so, was denn das für ein Spielzeug?
Na, aber ich komm zumindest überall ran auf dem Bildschirm.
Ich hab jetzt dann nochmal ernsthaft das Sex plus so ein bisschen versucht und plus ist einfach zu groß.
Du sagst jetzt, wenn du es dann hast, dann ist es etwas klein und dann sagst du, das ging ja gar nicht, ich kann ja nichts erkennen.
Bei dem Großen kommst du wirklich nicht. Das ist dann wirklich wie ein iPad Mini eher oder Mikro.
Ne, so ein Behinder-Phone, das würde ich auch nicht haben.
Ein Behinder-Phone. Behinder-Phone. Ne, also ich fände auch, die Größe ist eigentlich noch genau richtig. Und du hast ja dieses tolle Feature hier mit diesem Runterfahren.
Auch beim Nicht-Plus. Ah, okay, wusste ich nicht.
Oder Antennenlinien.
Ja, okay, die sind nicht übermäßig hübsch, das stimmt schon.
Da kommt eh eine Hülle drüber.
Ich akzeptiere ja, dass man mit der Größe klarkommt. Und ich akzeptiere auch, dass man neue Features und Geschwindigkeit dann geil findet. Aber im Hinblick auf Industrial Design ist es kein Schöpf nach vorne.
Ein großer Wurf.
Ich finde, dem fehlt einfach so eine spezielle Note.
Okay, wir sprechen uns nachdem du es hast, ein halbes Jahr nochmal wieder.
Nachdem ich was habe.
Ach so, du kaufst gar nicht, ne? Du bleibst noch.
Wir waren ja da stecken geblieben. Ihr habt es ja nicht zu Ende gemacht.
Ja, also du willst auf 6S oder nicht? Ich bin ja einer mit den geraden Geräten. Also nicht die S-Varianten. Ich bin jetzt nicht dran. Wobei ich ja dieses Subscription-Modell hier jährlich ein neues iPhone oder was das war, was sie da vorgestellt haben, da habe ich ja kurz drüber nachgedacht. Aber eigentlich ist das ganz schön.
Das gibt es aber auch noch nicht in Germany.
Ja, da bin ich mir auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so sicher, ob das so eine gute Idee ist. Also ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das verstanden habt, aber man muss monatlich einen Betrag abdrücken.
Ja, und kriegt dann aber jährlich das neue Phone.
Ja, aber wenn du ein neues Phone, also du musst es anfordern. Du musst es dann auch wollen. Du kriegst es nicht einfach so geschickt, sondern du musst sagen, ich nehme das jetzt auch. Und wenn du das nimmst, verlängert sich aber die Laufzeit deines Vertrages um 24 Monate.
Welcher Vertrag?
Dieser Vertrag, den du da mit Apple hast, hast du da monatlich Geld überweist. Deinen Subscription-Vertrag.
Und wenn ich dann kein neues will, dann zahle ich noch zwei Jahre so nach oder was?
Naja, er läuft wahrscheinlich, also ich habe mir jetzt die Details nicht genau durchgelesen, aber ich schätze mal, wenn du anfängst, dann zahlst du auf jeden Fall erst mal 24 Monate diesen Betrag.
Ja, dann kriegst du nach einem Jahr ein neues und nach den zwei Jahren, wenn du aufhören wolltest?
Naja, wenn du ein neues nimmst, läuft der halt zwei, du musst immer noch zwei Jahre, nachdem du das letzte Telefon bekommen hast, zahlen. Das heißt, du kommst da nur raus, indem du dir kein neues geben lässt.
Nach einem Jahr.
Und musst aber noch zwei Jahre zahlen. So habe ich das verstanden.
Nee, da kann irgendwas nicht stimmen.
Wieso, was soll denn sonst sein?
Na doch, wenn du ein Telefon dir ja subventionieren lässt von der Telekom, zahlst du das ja auch zwei Jahre mit deinem Kontakt ab.
Das ist doch der, ich mein...
Nee, aber bei Apples...
Die wollen ihre Kohle auch wieder haben. Du musst zwei Jahre so einen Betrag zahlen, damit sich das für die lohnt.
Wie viel war das im Monat?
Also das hängt ja von dem Modell ab, und das ging bei 29 Dollar los, oder so.
Ja, für das ganz, ganz kleine.
Ja genau, und dann würdest du halt so bei 380 Euro oder Dollar landen, und das Doppelte muss es halt schon sein, um dieses Telefon zu bezahlen. Das ist halt Ratenzahlung. Du zahlst aber am Ende immer noch denselben Preis. Du hast halt nur dieses Apple Care Plus noch mit drin. Das ist für Apple sozusagen ja eine andere Kostenstelle, weil das müssen sie nicht für produzieren, das ist eine reine Versicherungssache. Und das können sie halt regeln.
Also du meinst immer, nachdem man das letzte Phone bekommen hat, muss man es noch zwei Jahre lang abbezahlen. Dann kriegst du aber nach einem Jahr erst mal kein neues mehr, weil sonst, ja, verstehe, ja, ja. Das macht ja doch Sinn eigentlich.
16 Gig, 6S, 32 im Monat.
Und man kann sein?
Geht hoch bis zum 6S Plus mit 128 Gig für 45 Dollar im Monat.
Man kann sein Telefon behalten, wenn es abgelaufen ist nach dem Jahr, oder muss man es zurückgeben?
Nein, du musst natürlich das, du tauschst dann sozusagen das, was du hast, gegen das Neue ein. Also du hast dann halt auch...
Nichts zum Weiterverkaufen. Genau. Das ist doch voll der schlechte Deal. Das haben wir voll vergessen. Der einzige Vorteil ist, dass dieses, also für Leute, die das nutzen, dass dieses jetzt ziemlich teuer gewordene Apple-Keyer-Zeugs da mit dabei ist.
Der Apple-Keyer ist dabei, du hast keine Vertragsbindung mit dem Provider. Die sind alle unlockt und du kannst halt jederzeit vorbei wechseln.
Ja, das ist doch ein normaler Phone ja auch, wenn ich das so kaufe.
Ja gut, in den USA ist das schon noch eine kleine Revolution.
Immer noch.
Ja, weil du da halt in der, also bis vor kurzem hat man da einfach sein Telefon generell immer von den Telekom-Firmen gekauft. Verstehe. Und dass man das, dass es überhaupt so was wie ein unlockt Phone im Store gibt und so, das war da schon so, huuuuh.
Ja, deswegen machen die da in den Apple News Seiten irgendwie so einen Alarm, weil das bei denen noch ein bisschen anders läuft.
Ich habe das noch nicht so verstanden. Ja, weil die Leute sind gewohnt, ein Telefon sind sie einfach…
Abgezockt zu werden.
Ne, vor allem über eine monatliche Ratenzahlung zu machen. An wen sie aber jetzt diese Ratenzahlung entrichten, also an den Telekom-Anbieter oder an Apple selber, ist ihnen in gewisser Hinsicht egal. Nur Apple grätscht halt hier rein und sagt, ja, wir haben ja auch Subscription und du hast auch eine Versicherung dabei und du kriegst immer shiny, shiny neues Telefon und die Leute dann immer so, oh, das neue Telefon, ich will es haben.
Aber so gesehen ist es natürlich wirklich ein Frontalangriff an die Provider, ne?
Ja, wobei sich das, glaube ich, in den USA auch jetzt schon gewandelt hat. Die wollen halt auch alle weg aus diesem Markt. Also das funktioniert für sie auch nicht mehr so. Das ist mit hohen Kosten verbunden. T-Mobile hat das, glaube ich, schon komplett eingestellt. Die machen das gar nicht mehr. Und ja, die anderen teilweise wohl schon noch.
Ich erinnere mich nur daran, wie ich vor zwei Jahren im AT&T-Store stand und die allein nur für die SIM-Karte 50 Dollar haben wollen.
Ja, das ist in den USA total gaga.
Wir standen da zu zweit und haben erst mal ausgelacht. Das fand er nicht so richtig komisch.
Das verstehe ich ja auch nicht. Das ist doch eine SIM-Karte. Das ist für die so wie Blattgold. Zwei Gigabyte RAM.
Finally.
Muss ja weitergehen.
Und 3D-Touch.
Der Name ist total bekloppt.
Das Feature ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Wie hat Susse genannt?
Force-Touch.
Force-Touch oder weiß ich nicht.
Das ist eine 3D-Dimension.
Eine sehr kleine, sehr schmale 3D-Dimension.
War ich deswegen auch sensitive-Touch oder weiß ich nicht wie?
You're so sensitive.
Of course I am.
Na ja, ich kann das schon verstehen, weil so wie sie es ins US eingebaut haben, haben sie ja auch quasi eine 3D-Dimension. Du drückst ja quasi den Content nach vorn. Nee, der kommt ja auch nach vorne.
Genau, du drückst und deswegen kommt er zu dir.
Und dann kommt das Zeug ja nach vorne. Du drückst ja ein bisschen und hast ein Preview.
Der Content kommt zu dir.
Genau, sie benutzen schon so diese Planes und diese ursprüngliche Design-Language, die sie mit iOS 7 angefangen haben, dass alles so gelayert ist und mit Milchglaseffekt. Das kommt ja hier nochmal enorm zum Tragen.
Das recht hatte ich den Titel 3D auf jeden Fall.
Ja, aber ich fand die Beispiele ganz gut. Also zum Beispiel dieses in eine Mail, mal kurz in eine Mail reinschauen, um festzustellen, dass man die dann eh nochmal auf Wiedervorlage haben will und dann nochmal mark as unread und dann wieder zurückgehen. Und das machst du mit 30 Mails. Während du so halt wirklich so kurz reingucken kannst, kann man viel besser prokrastinieren mit, glaube ich.
Mit 3D-Touch.
Du meinst Mails prokrastinieren?
3D-Prokrastination.
Ich finde einfach dieses, was sie da immer gemacht haben, ist ja eigentlich dieses Quick Look Feature. Ich schaue mal kurz rein, will wissen, was ist dahinter, aber ich will jetzt auch nicht so viele User-Interface-Interaktionen haben.
Ja, ja, Quick Look ist ja...
Eine tolle Sache.
Das ist immer wieder gern genommen.
Genau, und das haben sie damit jetzt eben auch auf Touch-Ebene gemacht, und ich finde das sehr cool umgesetzt.
Dagegen sage ich auch gar nichts. Also, ich fand den Namen nur bekloppt, aber da drüber müssen wir jetzt nicht streiten. Wie gesagt, cooles Feature. Also, insgesamt fand ich das interessant, wie viele zusätzliche Funktionen sie an welchen Stellen da ins OS eingeklingt haben. Also, es wurde irgendwie nicht weniger so.
Was gibt es da jetzt noch ein?
Na ja, diese Menüs vom Homescreen.
Stimmt, dass du den Apps schon, bevor du sie launchst, sagen kannst, in welchen Modus sie gehen sollen.
Naja, so Sachen und dann, ja.
Und dann kommt es auch noch dazu, dass dieser Vibrator jetzt immer so eine kurze Hinweise gibt, oder?
Das ist kein Vibrator mehr.
Die Taptic Engine.
Ja, aber es ist am Ende dasselbe.
Nee, es ist nicht dasselbe, weil das ist jetzt halt so, wie es in der Watch ist. Das ist ja auch kein Vibrator.
Ja, aber was ist es denn dann?
Das ist ein Linearbeschleuniger. Das ist sozusagen ein Linearbeschleuniger, deswegen nimmt es auch mehr Raum ein. Aber damit kannst du halt viel kürzere Effekte erzeugen, als mit einem Vibrator. Der muss sich halt eine Mindestzeit drehen, um überhaupt auf den Effekte zu kommen.
Das Ding nervt mich übrigens auch. Bei diesem HTC One die ganze Zeit, bei jedem Tastendruck, alles vibriert da. Und ich weiß auch nicht, wie man das ausschalten kann. Aber abgesehen davon.
Aber Tastendruck, zum Beispiel mit dieser Taptic-Engine, also mit diesem Linian-Aktuator, könnte ich mir das ganz gut vorstellen auf dem Sensor. Aber davon haben sie nichts gesagt, ne?
Na ja, mal sehen, vielleicht war das einfach auch zu unwichtig für die Keynote. Aber ja klar, so ein Vibrator-Ding, der muss halt...
Und den Vibrator haben sie auch noch oder ist der jetzt weg?
Nein, die können damit auch einen Vibrations-Pattern machen. Das machen sie ja auch auf der Watch. Aber du kannst halt auch Tapp-Tapp machen. Also du hast halt so ganz kleine Ticks, die du einfach spürst und die zehn Millisekunden lang sein können. Also sehr, sehr kurze Sachen. Und während so ein Vibrator macht halt immer... Und ist halt relativ lang. Und kannst halt nicht so Granular-Dinge mit abbilden. Also bei der Watch ist das ja so, dass du damit einfach diese Muster sehr viel besser erkennen kannst. Also es gab ja auch früher... Oder was heißt früher? Es gibt auf iOS die Möglichkeit, dass du so einen Vibrations-Pattern kannst du ja definieren.
Ja, kannst du ja malen da eben.
Das habe ich mal gemacht. Da wirst du total bekloppt dabei, weil das einfach viel zu lang ist. Aber hier ist halt richtig so...
So ein richtiger Drum-Sequencer. Reverse-Drum-Sequencer.
Ja, das ist schon...
Der zurücktrommelt.
Ab heute wird es zurückgetrommelt.
Was ich ein bisschen schade finde, ist, dass dieses Optical Image Stabilization, dass das immer nur noch bei dem Plus geht und nicht mal runtergewandert ist in das normale 6er. Geht wahrscheinlich von der Größe nicht genau.
Definitiv bessere Kamera wohl. Also zumindest haben sie mehr Pixel.
Und die ist schon beim iPhone 6. Also das muss ich auch sagen, das ist eins der geilsten Features von diesem iPhone 6. Die Kamera ist unfassbar gut. Also...
Das ist in der Tat ein Upgrade-Grund, wenn einem viel an Fotos liegt.
Das ist Videos und Fotos. Ich gehe ja immer zu diesem Segelurlaub. Das Jahr davor hatte ich noch meinen Fünfer dabei. Da waren die Fotos alle so, ja, okay, Telefonfotos. Also schon bessere Telefonfotos, aber sieht man auch an Telefonfotos. Und jetzt die Videos und so, die kannst du dir Fullscreen angucken. Und das sieht einfach extrem perfekt aus. Also selbst hier der eine Freund von mir, der auch letztes Mal schon da war, der so Fotojournalist war, der hatte vorher auch noch so immer seine richtige Kamera am Start und hat auch wirklich atemberaubende gute Fotos damit gemacht. Und dann ist ihm die Kamera tatsächlich gleich in der ersten Woche verstorben und hat da erstmal mit dem iPhone weitermachen müssen, mit dem iPhone 6. Und die Fotos sind auch alle top-notch. Auch mit dem 6er oder was? Ja genau, und wenn das jetzt sozusagen noch mal eine Ecke drauf ist, dann ist irgendwann auch wirklich der Punkt, wo man sich überlegen muss, ob man überhaupt noch so eine Kompaktkamera braucht. Weil es gibt ja jetzt auch immer dieser Aufstecklinsen-Markt, der wird ja auch immer verrückter, ne? Also da gibt es ja jetzt auch wirklich krasse Objektive einfach teilweise.
Sie haben wohl jetzt von 8 auf 12 Megapixel hochgerüstet. Ob das jetzt unbedingt das bessere Bild gibt? Na, wir werden sehen.
Na, nur in Begleitung mit den sonstigen Maßnahmen, damit du eben diese Überstrahlung zwischen den Pixel nicht hast, weil kleinere Pixel heißt ja erstmal mehr Rauschen und da haben sie wieder halt irgendeinen Voodoo unternommen, keine Ahnung.
Aber 4K-Video kann das Ding jetzt aufnehmen und das ist schon mal auch nochmal...
In 30 oder in 60 oder in wieviel?
Na, ich hoffe, also vermutlich mindestens 30, aber das habe ich jetzt, weiß ich nicht, aus dem Kopf, aber das ist natürlich auch schon mal eine Ansage für so ein kleines Furzgerät.
Ja.
Da kannst du dann den vierten Teil von Herr der Ringe dann mit dem iPhone 6S drehen.
Du brauchst nur noch so eine kleine Aufstecklinse, genau.
Ja, wenn man bedenkt, das 4K-Video bis vor kurzem noch im Kino-Bereich ein Novum war und jetzt hast du so eine Rosentasche, ist schon echt bemerkenswert.
Absolut. Also, ich gucke mal gerade hier, Tech-Specs, Tech-Specs, Chip, Kamera, auch die Panoramas sollen ja jetzt noch gerade sein, Hybrid-IR-Filter, Video-Recording, also 30 FPS kannst du 4K-Video machen. Full HD, 30 oder 60, 720p kann man nur 30 FPS machen. Aber, wie gesagt, ist schon auf dem iPhone 6 wirklich supergut.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, also das Einzige, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, was mich zu so einem 6S bringt, ist, dass ich dieses 3D-Touch für eine geile Sache halte, die ich unbedingt haben will.
Und dein anderes wird zu langsam?
Ich habe überhaupt keine Probleme mit meinem 5S. Ich finde meinen 5S super.
Es ist vor allem klein.
Also es ist einfach schön kompakt und sieht super aus. Ich love it. Also ich finde, das 5S ist einfach designmäßig das iPhone bisher. Aber das 6er, nee, diesen Gartenzaunmuster da hinten drauf. Ich meine, da gibt es ja Modelle, da ist das sogar in weiß. Wie albern sieht denn das aus? Rosé-Gold mit so weißen Antennenlinien und so. Ja, aber das sieht doch scheiße aus.
Ich finde es auch nicht schick, aber da kommt eine Hülle drüber.
Über Rosé-Gold müssen wir glaube ich nicht reden, oder?
Es gibt Leute, die mögen das.
Ja, die sind hier in diesem Podcast falsch. Da ziehe ich auch nicht in Zweifel, dass es Leute gibt, die das mögen. Ich glaube, wir sind uns alle einig, dass wir nicht dazugehören.
Das stimmt schon.
Aber vielleicht unsere Hörer und diese Hörerinnen vor allem. Nein, jetzt sagen wir mal so. Wer auch immer das mag. Wir sind alle freundlich.
Ich würde sie auch niemandem nehmen.
Genau, das will ich auch.
Ich habe auch mal eins bestellt. War Samstag früh. Deswegen habe ich auch getweetet. Ich weiß, warum ihr alle wach seid. Das war deswegen, weil da konnte man das iPhone nämlich bestellen. Genau, manche haben es auch mitgekriegt.
Ich war nicht deswegen wach.
Ja, ich schon. Habt ihr noch eine Stunde gewartet? Weil um 9 ging es noch nicht. Es ging erst um 10 Uhr.
Also du hast jetzt ein 6S bestellt, oder was?
Weil? Weil ich auch nur ein 5S habe. Ich bin da schon zwei Jahre alt. Es hat eine Kratzer auf der Rückseite. Ich glaube deswegen, nee, ich muss mal abdecken. Aber ich habe nicht mit Kreditkarte instant zahlen können, sondern erst mit Überweisung. Die kam erst heute Mittwoch, gestern an. Jetzt muss ich mindestens bis 7. Oktober warten, nur weil man keine Kreditkarte hat. Ich prange das an, ich finde das doof. Wenn man bezahlt hat, dann wieder in die Que an die Stelle, wo man hingehört.
Du hast gar nicht erst eine.
eine von der ING-DiBa hättest, oder von der DKB, dann könntest du kostenlos Geld abheben.
Ich muss auch nicht voll den Kartenalarm in meinem Portemonnaie haben.
Du brauchst ja auch nur eine dann.
Ich habe aber meine EC-Karte auch noch.
Wenn du z.B. bei einer Bank wärst, die dir kostenlos europaweit Geld abheben ermöglichen würde, dann hast du nur eine.
EC-Karte plus Kreditkarte in einer Karte.
Nee, das ist dann halt eine Visa-Karte, aber mit der kannst du ja auch an jedem Automaten Geld abheben.
Ich bin nicht überzeugt.
Also ich habe zwei Karten. Ich gebe es dir zu, aber du kriegst auch z.B. von diesen Banken auch noch eine Maestro-Karte. Irgendwie war mir das irgendwann zu blöd in Deutschland, immer mit diesen Gebühren fürs Geld abheben. ZB wenn man nicht bei der Sparkasse ist, dann ist es nicht so, dass man 4,50 Euro oder 5 Euro nimmt. Das geht mir gar nicht.
Während alles schon iOS 9 lädt, habe ich schon fertig. Ich bin hier noch nicht überall so weit.
Und alle GM-User denken, sie hätten es schon. Da gibt es noch einen 40 MB-Update, weil ihr seid noch drei Bildnummern hinterher. Da könnt ihr noch mal klicken.
Von dem iOS 9. Ich hoffe, bei El Capitan wird sich das ähnlich einstellen. Ich habe das GM installiert und seitdem Crasht Mail.
Hatte ich in der Beta-Phase, im GM war es dann weg.
Bei mir nicht, bei mir hat es richtig schön eingeschlagen. Was insofern ganz interessant war, als es in dieser besonderen Situation war, keine Mail zu haben.
Ach, deswegen hast du dich mal nach Mail-Programmen geschaut.
Da dachte ich mir so, das ist doch jetzt mal genau die richtige, weil das war ja dann auch mein Laptop. Wenn man so im Kaffee sitzt, hier im Prenzlauer Berg, Milchkaffee schluffend, alle Klischees erfüllt. So, mit VDSL am Kaffeehahn. Ich brauche morgens schon Mail. Das ist schon so das, was zum Milchkaffee gereicht wird. Das ist einfach das Beste, was man machen kann. Im Kaffee rum sitzen und Mail wegarbeiten. Und dann hatte ich halt keine Mail. Scheiße, Gala lesen. Da gab es auch mal was in der Freak Show.
Freak Show-Berichtete.
Du hast ja mal Postbox und benutzt sie immer noch. Dann hab ich das mal installiert. Das hat bei mir allerdings nicht lange gehalten, weil es sehr schnell an so ein paar Grundfesten gerüttelt hat bei mir. Also es legt halt Passwörter nicht in die Keychain ab.
Der Chat hat mich übrigens erinnert, was das Problem mit der Mail war bei El Capitan. Du musst den GPG-Mail-Plugin entfernen, das sorgt dafür den Absturz. War bei mir nämlich auch so jetzt, wo ich es lese. Hast du nämlich auch richtig?
Ja.
Siehst du, und das funktioniert dann in Postbox wiederum. Da kannst du dann nämlich das Enig-Mail, das wohlgepflegte einfach, was quasi aus der Thunderbird-Community kommt, benutzen, dann funktioniert GPG nämlich auch ohne Gefricke.
GPG-Mail funktioniert dann irgendwie wieder sechs Wochen, bevor die nächste Version rauskommt, oder?
Nee, sie wollen jetzt schon, da stand schon da, dass sie für El Capitan schon am Testen sind und so. Und ich weiß nicht, vielleicht kommt sie heute. Ich glaube, die sind da, seitdem sie gesagt haben, sie wollen jetzt bald mal Geld nehmen, haben da ein bisschen mehr Motivation.
Wo liegt denn das?
Das ist wirklich so ein Trauerspiel. Dass dieses Mail immer noch so mit der Brechstange aufgedübelt werden muss, um da so ein GPG-Plugin reinzubringen in 2015. Das ist doch auch echt ein Armuts. Brechstange ist es gar nicht. Na ja, es gibt ja keine offizielle Extension-API.
Eine offizielle Extension-API gibt es nicht, aber es gibt Mechanismus, der Extensions lädt, und das tut er halt nach wie vor.
Ja, aber offensichtlich ist das ja höhere Magie. Sonst würde es ja nicht so lange dauern. Vor allen Dingen seit Jahren. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass dieser Use-Case total speziell und eigenartig ist.
Wir können uns gleich nochmal über GPG unterhalten und darüber, ob das nicht einfach sowieso vorbei ist. Wo ich jetzt langsam so...
Ich benutze GPG höchst selten, weil meistens auch nur andere Leute mit mir in GPG kommunizieren wollen.
Während ich hier das Plug-In entferne und gucke, ob das nur daran lag. Ich habe dann Postbox installiert, und das basiert ja auf diesem ganzen Thunderbird-Framebook. Das war mir zu cross-platformmäßig, das schmerzte mich einfach zu schnell. Das war mir zu weit weg von meinem Macintosh, und da bin ich irgendwie sehr eigen. Aus verschiedenen Gründen wollte ich das ja nicht weiterverfolgen. Und dann habe ich aber mal Mail-Made ausprobiert. Das fandest du wohl nicht so toll.
Das habe ich früher halt auch.
Oh, jetzt kann ich dir sogar sagen, was für mich der Moment war, wo ich aufgehört habe mit Postbox. Vielleicht lässt sich das ja beheben, aber das war für mich leider das Ende. Und zwar, sorry, ich bin wirklich vorhin ein Kacker.
Ich habe ja darauf gewartet, als du damit anfingst, und mir ist schon klar, was jetzt kommt.
Die Mails, also die Liste der Mails, wo die Mails sozusagen in einer Tabelle untereinander sind, sind durch eine schwarze Linie getrennt. Das ist so wie bei Eudora in den 90er-Jahren. Und nicht durch unterschiedliche Hintergründe. Also du hast nicht so einen abwechselnden hell-dunkelen Hintergrund, sondern sie malen da eine Linie. Und das war für mich eine visuelle Distortion, die war nicht zu Ertrag.
Davon spricht Tim.
Ich habe 10 Minuten darauf gestartet und mich gefragt, ob ich damit klarkomme und am Ende ging es einfach nicht.
Genau, in dem ColumnView ist das doch genau das gleiche. Oder benutzt du nicht den ColumnView, du benutzt den ListView oder was?
ColumnView ist ja der Feind.
Ja, hier guck mal, Tim benutzt das noch so in dem Modus. Der einzige View, der geht, verstehe.
Nee, wenn sie nur diesen ColumnView gemacht hätten, dann wäre ich da schon längst weg gewesen.
Ja, okay, ich benutze nur den ColumnView.
Ich habe schon ganz vergessen, dass es den gibt. Wie stellt man den überhaupt ein? Wie stellt man den aus? Irgendwo gibt es so einen Befehl mit mach alles wieder heile.
Und seitdem verlässt man diesen Zustand nicht mehr.
Den Grumpy Old Tim Mode oder was?
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das heißt. Das habe ich halt irgendwann vor Jahren eingestellt und dann war gut.
Also bei Postbox kann man bei View, Layout, Classical View und Vertical View...
Ja, man macht halt immer Linien dazwischen. Und das geht wirklich überhaupt nicht. Sorry, da war dann bei mir einfach Ende. Und Kennwörter nicht in die Keychain ablegen, sondern in so einem komischen Mozilla, irgendwo in irgendeinem Punkt direkt drüben liegen meine Passwörter. Ja, das würde ich allerdings auch nicht gelten lassen. Da bin ich einfach nicht dabei. Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wo man das einstellt.
Hast du mal nachgeguckt, wo die abgelegt werden? Oder hast du das jetzt nur dahin gefaselt?
Na, es ist halt nicht in der Keychain.
Ich habe halt geguckt...
Aber du weißt da auch nicht, wo sie liegen, wirklich.
Das ist mir egal.
Wenn sie nicht in der Keychain liegen, dann sind sie raus. Also da haben sie zu liegen und nirgends woanders. Use Classic Layout heißt das hier in den Präferenzes. Viewing, Use Classic Layout. Und dann ist alles gut.
Na, mach mal aus.
Wo ist denn das?
Na, in den Präferenzen.
Ja, wo da?
Unter Viewing.
Ah, jetzt hast du gar nicht den...
Darstellung.
Da, hier.
Entschuldigung, ich benutze das.
Ein klassisches Layout. Oh, ja, da kommen Erinnerungen hoch.
Nicht nur die.
Ja, sorry, I'm.
Also ich muss halt einfach oben durch eine Liste durchgehen und einmal draufklicken und ich will meine Mail sehen.
Ich finde diese kleine Liste da so, also dieses ColumnView gar nicht schlecht, weil da hast du die Liste auch.
Da sehe ich ja gerade mal 5, 6, da sehe ich ja nicht im Ansatz.
Ja, aber dafür kannst du schon so ein bisschen reingucken und weißt ja genau, um was es da gerade ging.
Ja, aber für mich sind die Spalten total wichtig. Für mich ist es super wichtig, das muss alles untereinander sein, ich muss danach sortieren können, alles.
Ja, jeder so wie er es braucht. Aber ich finde das Mail-Ede ist eines der wenigen Programme, die ich im Fullscreen nutze.
Ja, kann man auch machen. Wie auch immer, das ist auf jeden Fall...
Und im Fullscreen habe ich halt eine breite Viel Platz.
Ich habe dann Mail-Mails ausprobiert und ich finde, ich bin noch nicht so richtig gefangen, aber es ist nicht schlecht.
Das ist schon mal ein hohes Lob bei Tim.
Wo ist der Berliner halt?
Schlecht.
Kann man nicht meckern.
Ein paar Sachen finde ich auch noch, weiß ich noch nicht, muss ich mich noch daran gewöhnen, aber dass man so ein bisschen konfigurieren kann, welche Counter er anzeigt, dass du so bestimmte Gruppen von Unread oder was auch immer du halt angezeigt haben möchtest, dass man sowas konfigurieren kann, das ist ganz gut. Da ist auch seit Jahr und Tag, weil das schon längst durchge-crowdfunded ist, eine Version 2.0 angekündigt, weiß nicht, wann die kommt. Also wer auf jeden Fall mit Mail-App nicht glücklich ist oder aus anderen Gründen, weil er zu doof ist zu schnallen, dass es das GPG-Mail-Plugin ist, was alles zum Crashing bringt, mit Mail-App nicht klarkommt, kann auch Mail-Made mal eine Chance geben.
Dann können wir jetzt wieder zum iPhone zurückkommen, weil du bist zwei Themen abgeschrieben.
Ne, wir müssen dann gleich nochmal auf GPG kommen.
Das ist ja ein anderes Thema, wir waren doch noch überhaupt nicht fertig.
Wieso, iPhone waren wir doch schon längst vorbei.
Ja, aber da gibt es noch mehr Punkte.
Beim iPhone?
Ne, bei der Keynote oder nicht?
Wir haben jetzt halt mal ein paar Klammern aufgemacht, wir sind in diesem Scope ein bisschen reingerutscht.
Was war denn?
Ich dachte, da kommt noch was.
Nach dem iPhone war Schluss, da kam Musik.
Echt? Hab ich nicht gehört.
Ne, man schaltet dann ja auch aus.
Ihr müsst euch das aber mal bis ganz zum Schluss angucken, die Musik, die ist nämlich lustig, weil ganz zum Schluss der Sänger von der Bühne springt und noch während er singt, ein Selfie mit sich selbst und Tim macht.
Oh Gott, ich weiß schon, warum ich dann gleich auf Stopp brüche.
Da muss ich sagen, da war ich aber sehr erstaunt, wie lässig der das hinkriegt, da zu singen, seinen Song, den relativ glaubwürdig rüberbringt, aber gleichzeitig am Phon rumfummelt und irgendwie versucht.
Weil du den Song 23.000 Mal gesungen hast.
Ihr seid jetzt immer noch bei der Keynote, bei dem, wie hießen die?
Gut. Das war nämlich, weil ich jetzt auch noch mal kurz was sagen will, also mir ist das zwar auch nicht recht, dass das nicht in der Keychain liegt, das Passwort, aber wie gesagt, ich habe ja so ein etwas komplexeres Mail-Setup und Postbox ist das Einzige, was das einigermaßen, also nicht nur einigermaßen, sondern komplett abbildet, performt, viel Mail handeln kann. Und dann irgendwie genau dieses GPG-Thema habe ich letztens auch mal wieder anfassen müssen, weil irgendwie wollte jemand mir jetzt unbedingt nur in GPG kommunizieren. Und theoretisch denkt man sich ja auch als nur so, ja, ja, ich hatte da auch mal so ein Key...
Muss das jetzt sein, weil wir uns fürs Kino verabreden?
Nee, ich dachte mir so, ja, nee, hast ja schon recht, okay. Ich guck mal, oh, meine Keys, oh, jo, jo, nee, ich fang da noch mal von vorne und hab mir mal einen neuen Key gemacht. Und dann dachte ich mir, oh, willst du jetzt... Ich war schon kurz davor, einfach GPG nur an der Shell zu benutzen und den Text in die Mail zu pasten.
So mach ich das immer.
Und dann hab ich mich aber daran erinnert, hey, Moment, ich benutze ja Postbox, das hat ja eine Extension-AP, im Gegensatz zu manch anderem Mailclient. Und da gibt es halt dieses Enigmail-Programm, oder wie auch immer man das korrekt in Englisch ausspricht, Plug-in. Und das klickt man sich dann in seinen Postbox rein, und da geht GPG einfach sofort ohne irgendwie großes Tamtam und Zeremonien und irgendwie Dateien verschieben, sondern einen Klick, erkennt sofort dein GPG-Setup, lässt dich auswählen, welche Identitäten du jetzt auswählen willst, und vor allen Dingen, wie die so verwaltet werden, alles genau, wie man das haben will. Und da war ich dann auch wieder eigentlich vergleichsweise glücklich, Postbox zu benutzen. Weil da war so dieser ganze Hesel, den ich noch von Apple-Mail und GPG-Mail kannte, nicht hart.
Ja, das Problem ist halt GPG. Also ich musste schon so ein bisschen grinsen, als neulich so ein Tweet rumging, dass irgendjemand versucht hat, Phil Zimmermann, der Erfinder von PGP, jemand wollte Phil Zimmermann eine PGP-verschlüsselte Mail schicken. Also dem Erfinder von PGP. Und wer es noch nicht weiß, GPG ist im Prinzip dasselbe. GPG ist halt Open Source-Reimplementierung. Und PGP ist die ursprüngliche Implementierung, die es halt auch als kommerzielles Produkt gibt. Und seine Antwort war, er benutzt kein PGP.
Das ist natürlich ein Brüller.
Also Phil Zimmermann, der Erfinder von PGP, benutzt kein PGP, weil er der Meinung ist, dass es halt nicht genug Sicherheit bietet.
Nicht genug Sicherheit?
Ja, nicht genug Sicherheit bietet. Genau. Der Inhalt ist verschlüsselt.
Der Inhalt ist verschlüsselt, der Header ist schon mal nicht verschlüsselt. Du hast halt keine Forward-Secrecy. Das heißt, wenn der Schlüssel halt einmal kompromottiert ist, wie wir das jetzt zum Beispiel heute melden, das ist der PGP-Schlüssel von kryptoam.org, einer der Dauer-Whistleblower und Leaker der Welt. Der hat bekannt gegeben, dass sein PGP-Key, der jetzt seit Jahren im Einsatz ist, kompromottiert ist, ohne weitere große Details zu nennen. Das Problem ist, dass jede Kommunikation, die auf dem Transportwege mal stattgefunden hat, die diesen Schlüssel benutzt hat, entschlüsselbar ist. Auch 10, 20 Jahre danach. Ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht niederreden. Ich weiß, dass es immer am Ende eine mit GPG verschlüsselte Kommunikation sicherer ist, als wenn sie es nicht ist. Das ist ja überhaupt gar keine Frage. Nur, dass mittlerweile auch viele Leute der Meinung sind, dass das eben nicht unbedingt der Weg sein kann. Das andere ist, dass trotz solcher absolut bewundernswärter Bemühungen, wie zum Beispiel dieses gpgtools.org, also dieser Plug-In-Lösung für GPG, um das hier in die Standard-Mail-Up von Apple reinzubringen, sich eigentlich in der Benutzerfreundlichkeit dieses GPG-Systems oder PGP-Systems eigentlich nichts getan hat. Das fängt schon bei so Sachen an, wie den Schlüssel finden. Also du willst halt einfach mit jemandem mal eine verschlüsselte Kommunikation starten. Und was willst du machen? Also ich hatte das jetzt auch neulich wieder, klassischer Fall, Mädel, ich kenne sie, aber ich kannte halt den Key nicht. Wo kriege ich den Key halt jetzt her? Jetzt kann man natürlich erstmal anfangen, unverschlüsselte Mails hin und her zu schicken, mit hast du mal einen Key. Klar, kann man machen. Aber ich dachte mir so, muss ja auch irgendwie, muss ja auch flüssiger gehen. Das ist ja Internet, ist ja alles da. Du suchst halt erstmal einen Key, findest da halt auch einen mit einer Mail-Adresse, die so ich hatte und dann habe ich den halt genommen, Mail hingeschickt. Kriegt dann nach zwei Tagen eine Mail. Ja, sorry, dieser Key ist outdated und bitte nicht mehr benutzen. Was man diesem Key natürlich auch nachträglich dann auch nicht so ohne weiteres sagen kann.
Vor allem, weil man die Revocation-Sets nicht aufbewahrt.
Ja, und der liegt halt auf irgendwelchen Key-Servern rum und so weiter. Und das Ding ist halt auch, und das ist auch ein Grundproblem bei GPG, wenn es jetzt wirklich jemand darauf anlegt, die Kommunikation mit dir in irgendeiner Form zu torpedieren. Niemand hält mich davon ab, von euren E-Mail-Adressen in irgendwelche Keys reinzuschreiben und diese Keys einfach auf tausenden Key-Servern zu verbreiten. Und die Chance, dass irgendjemand mal so einen Key nimmt, selbst wenn ich nicht in der Lage bin, das abzufangen, ist das für dich ein riesen Hesse, weil du eigentlich dann nur noch damit beschäftigt bist, alle Leute zu erklären, welche Keys alle jetzt nicht von dir sind. Das eine Millionen Keys, die da rumliegen, nicht sind, aber nur dieser eine goldene. Wie kommunizierst du das? Wo schreibst du das hin? Schreibst du auf deine Homepage? Wo, wo, wie? Es gibt so Ansätze wie dieses keybase.io, über das wir uns ja auch schon mal unterhalten haben, wo man zumindest so halbwegs sagen kann, naja, hier, ich habe diesen Twitter-Account und diese Webseite und das ist hier irgendwie alles so halbwegs getrusted und zertifiziert. Dadurch kannst du rauskriegen, was wohl der Key ist, den ich derzeit verwende. Aber nur wenn du den dann wieder wechselst, dann musst du das auch wieder alles from scratch neu aufbauen. Das habe ich jetzt neulich mal gemacht, weil ich dachte, das wäre einfacher. Es ist halt einfach alles schwierig. Also du hast halt auf der einen Seite eine Verschlüsselung, die ohnehin nicht vollständig ist. Viel von deiner Mail ist unverschlüsselt. Also das Subject zum Beispiel und die Header. Viel der Kommunikation lässt sich gar nicht verschlüsseln damit, sondern eigentlich nur der Buddy. Dann hast du häufig auch noch so Buggy-Software, wo du sagst, ja verschlüsseln und dann macht sie es halt einfach nicht, weil wieder irgendein Setting irgendwo gesetzt ist, was du nicht kennst. Dann hast du das Problem, dass es kein ordentliches Key-Management gibt. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, irgendwie da ein Trust zu machen. Dann gab es ja hier jahrelang auch auf dem Kongress immer diese Key-Signing-Partys. Also wirklich so das Arschgeweih der Hacker-Szene. Also Sign-by-S, wo sie alle völlig und web of trust und wenn wir uns alle nur gegenseitig unterschreiben mit unseren ganzen Schlüsseln, nur in so einem System, wo jeder jeden Key signen kann und du dir aber auch beliebige Keys von irgendwelchen Leuten ausdenken kannst.
Wenn sich alle gegenseitig signen, ist es so, wenn sich alle gegenseitig nicht signen, oder?
Es sagt überhaupt nichts aus am Ende. Dann hast du halt da solche Key-Wulster. Im Prinzip ist das so ein bisschen wie so eine Autogrammsammlung.
Mehr ist das nicht. Vor allen Dingen haben die Leute nicht verstanden, dass du ja nicht... Also da stehst du ja bei diesen Key-Signing-Partys und zeigst dir da irgendwie gegenseitig noch einen Ausweis oder sowas. Aber es geht ja darum, dass du da deine E-Mail-Adresse quasi und deine Kommunikationsfahrt eigentlich so trusten sollst. Und nicht, dass ja, ok, du hast das Gesicht auf dieser Karte und ok, das ist vielleicht dein Fingerprint. Aber also das Barumgehen war total, ja ok, schön, ihr wart jetzt auf 23 Key-Signing-Partys, aber das sagt noch lange nicht, dass ihr eure GPG im Griff habt irgendwie.
Hochnotparanoiden Aluhüte, die irgendwie jedes Social Network meiden, wie das Weihwasser, weil ja dein Netzwerk da abgebildet wird, aber dann Key-Signing-Partys machen. Das passt einfach alles nicht zusammen. Und vor allem, es hat einfach auch diesen System, GPG oder PGP, es hat sich einfach gefühlt nichts getan. Wie lange gibt es das jetzt schon? 25 Jahre? Ewig immer und es ist immer noch unbenutzbar und es hat immer noch komplett ungelöste, grundsätzliche Probleme und du kriegst es einfach niemandem beigebracht. Und das ist einfach mal gescheitert. Viel besser sind da diese Messenger. Schon Messages und so. Also jetzt iMessage und wie sie alle heißen, weil die halt tatsächlich diesen Key-Austausch automatisiert haben, wo du forward secrecy hast im Idealfall und auch halbwegs moderne Verschlüsselungsverfahren verwendest, die dann halt schon so, was weiß ich hier, diese elliptic curve Kryptography machen und halt nicht auf diesem RSA-Algorithmus. Bevor ich mich jetzt auf technische Diskussionen einlasse, wo dann sowieso wieder alles besser wissen, mir geht es auch mehr so um dieses Handling. Es gibt aber S-Mail. Das ist ein Standard. Jedes Mail-Programm unterstützt das. Jedes iPhone kann das, wo es kein GPG-Mail gibt. Wenn ich jemanden mit GPG-Mail schreibe, dann muss ich erst warten, bis ich wieder an meinem Computer bin. Weil ich auf meinem Telefon keine Chance habe, dieses Ding irgendwie auszupacken. Geschweige denn, dass man auch so eine Mail mühelos ansieht, dass sie verschlüsselt ist, weil die sieht ja dann auch aus wie ein Stück Scheiße. Ja, hier irgendwie bla.ask-attachment. Sieht eigentlich aus wie Spam. Also jetzt so, schick mal irgendjemand eine verschlüsselte Mail.
Aber sind mit S-Mime, We-Header und alles verschlüsselt?
Ich kann dir ehrlich gesagt jetzt nicht genau sagen. Du hast halt immer noch Mail und das Problem, dass du halt Transport haben musst, aber du kannst die Subject-Zeile zum Beispiel verschlüsseln. Wobei, das gibt, glaube ich, auch bei GPG die Möglichkeit, da noch irgendwas reinzuschreiben. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau. Tatsache ist, das Ganze basiert halt auf Domains und Zertifikaten, was halt lange ein Problem war auch, weil man wollte dafür immer nicht bezahlen. Gleich werden wir uns über Let's Encrypt unterhalten. Da versuche ich das gerade so hinzubringen. Aber man muss halt einsehen, S-Mime ist halt da, ist halt überall implementiert und funktioniert. Und ich denke, dass verschlüsselte E-Mail-Kommunikation im Prinzip darauf basieren müsste.
Kriegst du aber glaube ich auch einfach. Also das S-Mime gibt es ja auch schon seit...
Ja, aber das scheitert an diesen Zertifikatsproblemen.
Ja, aber ob du das wirklich dann trotz... Also ich meine, sagen wir mal, Let's Encrypt und so, alles super, bald, der Zertifikatsmafia ist dann erst mal so ein bisschen abgestellt. Meinst du denn wirklich, dass du dann den Leuten und die mir hin zu den Kunden erklären kannst, wo sie jetzt ihr Zertifikat herkriegen und wie sie das installieren und so weiter und so fort?
Aber du hast eine App, die es generiert. Das iPhone macht das für dich. Was ich auch nicht verstehe, warum das noch nicht da ist. Das ist noch mal eine andere Debatte. Diese Penner von de-mail, die jetzt erst mal sich einen komplett neuen Standard für alles haben einfallen lassen und mit 380 kmh auf die nackte Betonmauer zugefahren sind und ich glaube, wir sind jetzt auch schon mindestens zweimal davon wieder abgeprallt. Wahrscheinlich noch dreimal dagegenfahren, bis sie endlich merken, dass sie eigentlich platt sind. Hätten sie von vornherein auf S-Mail gesetzt, hätten sie erst mal überhaupt nichts programmieren müssen. Keine Plugins, keine Software, keinen Transfer, gar nichts. Sie hätten einfach gar nichts machen müssen. Sie hätten einfach nur Zertifikate ausgeben müssen und fertig. So, eine Zertifikatsinfrastruktur, wo man sich quasi so ein de-mail, ich meine, das wäre ja mal was. Dass man einfach mal so ein Bürger-Mail-Zertifikat bekommt. Und dann funktioniert das halt auch gleich mit jedem Gerät.
Naja, aber es ist doch auch nichts, was sie nicht auch verkacken könnten.
Nee, es ist nichts, was man nicht verkacken kann. Da ist zumindest schon mal 20 Jahre drüber nachgedacht worden. Und es gibt irgendwie tausende Implementierungen. Und es gibt auch Motivation für all diese Anbieter weltweit, die dann im Zweifel auch zu verbessern, wenn sie halt noch Probleme haben. Irgendwie müsste es da hingehen. Aber jetzt können wir mal kurz über Let's Encrypt reden, weil da hat sich ja was getan. Wir hatten das ja vor einiger Zeit...
Ja, ich habe nur diese News... Also ich gucke ja immer noch gelegentlich so mal auf Hacker-News, so alle zwei Tage mal rein. Da gibt es ja schon immer noch so einen anderen Nachrichten-Flow. Und da kam halt, dass Let's Encrypt jetzt ihr erstes Zert irgendwie fertig hat, was jetzt...
Zeter-Zert.
Genau, was jetzt irgendwie, aber auch bei Apple und Mozilla und bei Google und so... Also die sind jetzt kurz davor mal... Oder sie haben jetzt schon angeklappt?
Die wollten es in die großen Browser rein kriegen, aber haben sie nicht. Aber sie legen jetzt gerade los. Und eigentlich wollten sie heute, oder nee, am 14. Also vorgestern fertig sein, aber sie haben es jetzt ein bisschen verschoben.
Ach doch? Okay, aber es geht jetzt los. Vielleicht haben wir es zum Kongress ja schon ein bisschen mehr.
Das sollte dann eigentlich der Fall sein, denke ich.
Also auf jeden Fall, für die, die es jetzt nicht mitbekommen haben, Let's Encrypt ist sozusagen das Projekt der IFF, eine CA zu machen, eine Certificate Authority, wo man seine Zertifikate quasi auch kostenlos im weitesten Sinne bekommen soll.
Ja, nicht nur kostenlos, sondern vor allem voll automatisiert übertragen und eingespielt und auch zur Not noch direkt in die Webserver-Konfiguration eingespielt bekommen. Vor allem wendet sich das an Webseitenbetreiber. Also wenn man selber jetzt einen Blog hat, einen eigenen Domain und man will halt HTTPS haben, dann war das halt immer ein richtiger Ratten-Tanz, bis man irgendwie so ein Zertifikat bekommt und dann hängen da Kosten dran und diese ganzen…
Ratten-Tanz?
Ja, ein Ratten-Tanz. Ja, wo die Ratten halt einen richtigen Tanz aufführen müssen, bis sie halt mehr Scheiß-Zertifikate bekommen. Ich weiß, du wolltest, dass ich Schwanz sage im Podcast, aber das mache ich jetzt nicht.
Das ist auch eigentlich Holgis Aufgabe.
Ja, eben.
Nein, ich fand das nett, Ratten-Tanz. Ich habe mir das nur so vorgestellt, wie da so die kleinen Nadel rum.
Das waren von sich aus schon die Meldungen, dass die halt da weitermachen.
Ich habe das nicht so richtig verstanden, warum sie das so gemacht haben, aber was sie ja rausgebracht haben, ist, sie haben eine Webseite, ein Zertifikat, und das ist mit ihrer RUT-CA unterschrieben. Und diese RUT-CA muss man sich als solche nochmal klicken, so wie das früher schon bei CA-Zert und anderen Sachen waren, damit die keinen Fehler wirft. Und ich wunderte mich so ein bisschen, weil irgendwie hatte ich das ja anders in Erinnerung. Wenn sie aber online gehen, dann werden diese Zertifikate, die von Netz Encrypt ausgegeben sind, auch mit diesem RUT-Zertifikat gesigned sein. Aber sie werden nochmal ein Co-Signing haben von dieser Sub-CA, von dieser Bank, was den Vorteil hat, dass eben auch alte Browser, die jetzt noch nicht mit diesem neuen Top-Level-Zertifikat ausgestattet sind, damit kein Problem haben. Für mich war die eigentliche Information überhaupt schon neu, dass sie überhaupt ein eigenes RUT-Zertifikat haben werden und das auch in den Browsern ausgeliefert wird. Das ist ja jetzt schon ein richtiger Erfolg. Haben denn da alle schon zugesagt?
Nein, sie haben ja geschrieben, dass sie die Initial-Applications von Mozilla, Google, Microsoft und Apple heute aufgerufen haben. Das war am 14. Und jetzt steht da nicht viel mehr, ob sie davon ausgehen, dass das dann auch erfolgreich wird. Ich denke mal, Mozilla wird das wahrscheinlich schon machen. Wie jetzt Apple, Google und Microsoft so die Sache sehen, mal schauen. Bei Mozilla wäre ich vorsichtig, optimistisch, dass das schon klappen wird. Und ja, man weiß ja immer nicht, das ist so diese Zertifikatsgeschichte. Irgendwie ist einem das ja immer so ein bisschen suspekt, weil man nicht genau weiß, wie kommen denn jetzt eigentlich diese Root-Zertifikate unter welchen Umständen?
Die 400, 500 Root-Zertifikate.
Wie kommen die da in diese ganzen Browser von Google, Microsoft, Apple und Mozilla rein? Ob fließt da jetzt Geld, fließt da kein Geld? Also wer muss man sein, um das zu machen? Und sprechen die sich auch untereinander ab, was so die Regeln sind dafür? Gibt es da ein Konsortium? Keine Ahnung, ne? Vielleicht steht das doch irgendwo im Internet, wenn es ein Hörer weiß und das vielleicht irgendwie so Sendung mit der Maus mäßig erklärt im Internet gefunden hat. Der Link würde mich ja schon auch mal interessieren. Deswegen ist so dieses Let's Encrypt so, wow, da traut sich jetzt mal jemand und macht so richtig Anstalten, da mal durch diesen ganzen Zirkus quasi von der anderen Seite durchzubrechen. Deswegen ist das Projekt ja an sich auch spannend, weil die bloggen ja auch da drüber und so weiter und so fort. Da kann man halt schon auch sehen, dass das einfach ein riesiges Projekt sein scheint. Und wenn das dann am Ende wirklich erfolgreich ist und die dann auch noch in diese ganzen Browser mit reinkommen, super.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie von den anderen CAs relativ viel Gegenwind bekommen, weil die denen natürlich das Business-Modell kaputt machen. Und wenn einer erst mal anfängt, die Preise so ordentlich runterzuschrauben?
Es gibt ja schon dieses Start-SSL. Da gibt es ja im Prinzip jetzt auch schon mehr oder weniger kostenlos bis Spottepreis-Zertifikate, die auch überall supported sind. Das Einzige, was wahrscheinlich dann so CAs halt noch irgendwie, wofür die Geld verlangen können, ist zum Beispiel, was ich ja auch schon mal erwähnte hier, was DigiZert macht oder DigiZert, dass die halt auch noch so ein bisschen Management drumrum bieten. Dass du halt so deine 150 Zertifikate auch entsprechend managest, dass die dich dran erinnern, wenn die ablaufen und etc. noch so ganz viel enterprise-y Features drumrum. Aber für den einfachen, hier ich will mal einen Blog mit HTTPS-User, gibt es da wirklich kaum noch Gründe. Und die Preise sind ja auch schon in den letzten Jahren total runtergegangen. Du kriegst ja jetzt auch generell Zertifikate schon für 29,19 Euro. Das war ja auch vor, weiß nicht, 5, 6, 7 Jahren. Da kam es ja nicht unter 100 Dollar für ein Zert raus.
Und diese Routzerz nicht auch voll ein Security-Problem, weil jeder, der so ein Routzerz in deinem Browser hat, kann dir alle möglichen Zerts irgendwie erstellen und unterschieben. Richtig?
Ja, richtig.
Also eigentlich will man das doch überhaupt gar nicht benutzen.
Na, das war ja auch schon öfters mal ein Problem, dass einigen CAs da ihre Routzerifikate, die Private Keys abhanden gekommen sind. Beziehungsweise bei einem war es ja sogar so, dass sie MD5 noch benutzt hatten für die Fingerprints.
Ja, oder selbst wenn es nicht die Großen sind, wo das passiert. Also man hat ja auch voll viele Rout-CAs irgendwie bei sich drin. Du weißt doch nicht mehr, wem die gehören und wer da unterschreiben darf.
Man weiß, die Chinesen haben ja das schon gerne gemacht. Die haben ja so für Google und so weiter.
Ja, eigentlich will man das komplett ohne betreiben. Man will die alle rausschmeißen und jeden Einzelnen von Hand.
Naja, es ist ja jetzt so, dass man jetzt, das bräuchte man mal Kliemanns, aber ich glaube, da haben wir auch schon darüber gesprochen, dass du in Zukunft dann auch eben schon sagen kannst, für diese Webseite gilt auch nur genau dieses Zertifikat und nur diese CA darf für diese Domain auch etwas ausgeben.
Das ist das, was mir noch fehlt. Du kannst jetzt Zerts von Webseiten irgendwie akzeptieren, aber du kannst nicht irgendwie sagen, wie war das? Na, wenn die sich ändern halt. Das heißt, wenn die mal ein neues reinmachen.
Du machst halt dieses Fingerprint-Pinning. Das wird jetzt zum Beispiel bei Apps oder bei Spielen gemacht, um so Cheaten zu verhindern. Dann wird schon HTTPS benutzt. Dann haben die Leute angefangen, na ja, ist ja egal. Ich meine, in the middle und trust jetzt hier diesem anderen Zertifikat einfach. Und jetzt, genau, certificate pinning heißt das. Dann sagst du halt im Prinzip, nur genau das Zert darf jetzt hier akzeptiert werden mit dem Fingerprint. Und das kannst du dann im Prinzip da theoretisch auch machen.
Ist eigentlich dieses Zertifikat pinning ein Teil von dieser Security-Initiative von Apple? Die hatten doch da was, dass man...
Ja, das war ja auch, glaube ich, ein Problem bei dem App Store, dass die gejailbreakten Telefone und so, die haben ja dann auch alles Mögliche gefaket und so weiter. Und da war es halt auch so, weiß nicht, ob es beim App Store, bei dem Payment, bei den In-App Purchases und so, da gab es halt diverse Stellen, wo die halt auch nie auf den Fingerprint geguckt haben und du einfach dem irgendwas unterschubsen konntest. Und dafür haben die das ja auch mal eingeführt, damit die Leute dann nicht mehr mit dem Store so viel Schindluder treiben.
Nee, aber die hatten ja zur WWDC, hatten ja diese komische Security-Initiative da, wo dann Apps, weiß ich nicht, welche Bedingungen erfüllen mussten. Und ist da Certificate-Pinning eigentlich mit dabei? Weiß ich nicht.
Sollte ich es ja mal vermuten, aber wissen tue ich es nicht.
Naja, bei diesen Standards, die du erfüllen musst um Clemens. Ja, Clemens muss es wissen.
Der alte Apple-Kennner.
Ich hätte das jedenfalls so wie bei SSH, wenn sich da auch nur irgendwas ändert, dann will ich da eine Warnung haben eigentlich.
Also du willst quasi auf die Webseite gehen, dann siehst du den Fingerprint und sagst, okay, Accept. Und dann, wenn der sich irgendwann ändert, dann...
Ja, ich will nicht eigentlich das andere mir vorschreiben oder andere mir irgendwie sagen, das ist jetzt safe. Weil die können ja alles unterschreiben. Das heißt, ich gehe auf irgendeine Seite, die haben da sonst was signiert von diesen, gab's noch mal diese türkischen CRZ, das war, glaube ich, nur für eine Arsche irgendwie. Aber ja, dass jedes RUZ da mir sonst was unterschieben kann, das finde ich nicht cool. Deswegen müssen die eigentlich, das ganze Konzept ist auch für einen Arsch.
Ja, prinzipiell ist es auf jeden Fall nicht so gut. Aber Besser, was Besseres haben wir jetzt auch nicht.
Nee, was Besseres haben wir jetzt auch nicht und das muss auf jeden Fall alles noch besser werden. Oder?
Ansonsten, wenn wir schon bei Security sind, eine kleine Erwähnung, weil beim iOS 9 kann man jetzt das, was bei iOS 8 nur mit diesen komischen Configuration Profiles ging, das geht jetzt auch im GUI, nämlich IPSEC mit IK Version 2. Das ist jetzt auch Default bei Apple für alle VPNs erstmal. Also die wollen da in diese Richtung.
Moment, es waren zu viele Abkürzungen auf einmal.
Na, beim iOS 8 gab es schon IPSEC mit IK Version 2. Das ist das Protokoll, mit dem du die Schlüssel austauschst, um dann eigentlich IPSEC zu fahren. Du könntest ja alle von Hand einstellen, aber dieser IK Demon ist dafür da, um das zu managen. Da gibt es eine neue Version, schon ziemlich lange. Bei iOS 8 war das nur mit dem Configuration-Profil zu machen, mit dem Configurator-Tool. Beim iOS kannst du das direkt klicken und brauchst nicht mehr dieses Configurator-Tool. Und El Capitan, wenn wir schon mal dabei sind, sind jetzt beide auch auf gleicher Höhe. Du kannst im El Capitan auch sagen, hier bitte IPSEC mit IK Version 2, wo du klickst, dass da alles rumfertig geht.
Also wenn man so einen VPN aufsetzt in der Netzwerk-Konfiguration.
Hab ich auch hier oben, klicke ich jetzt mal, connect, zack, und da ist er. Jetzt ist natürlich mein Irrtod.
Und womit? IKE V2, ja? Ah ja, richtig, das ist neu. Und vorher gab es nur L2TP, PPTP und Cisco IPSEC.
Und Cisco IPSEC war sozusagen IK Version 1.
Und was spricht auf der Gegenseite zum Beispiel dieses IKE V2? Also womit verbindest du dich, wenn du das machst?
Na komm, drauf an, was du sagst. Ich selber mach das gerade, wie ich auch schon halt bei AWS hab ich alles schon erzählt hier mit diesem Strong Thorn unter FreeBSD.
Aber es gibt keine Public-Dienste?
Doch, die wird's auch demnächst in Massen geben. Oder die gabs wahrscheinlich schon, weil es ja mit dem Configuration Profiler-Dingens da, diesen Konfigurator unter iOS 8, auch schon ging. Deswegen denke ich, wir bieten das auch schon ganz viele an.
Und wie sind so deine Erfahrungen mit dem Durchdringen von komisch konfigurierten Netzen, so Uni-paranoia-Netze und sowas?
Also ich benutze das jetzt, keine Ahnung, seit wann, halbes, dreiviertel Jahre. Und ich bin noch nie nirgends nicht rausgekommen mit meinem Tunnel.
Aber das ist ja auch nicht an Unis so oft, oder?
Nee. Du bist selten im Feines Land, du wirst nicht hinter den Freunden gehen.
Da ist man nicht im Feines Land, weil da gibt es kein ordentliches Netz, also geht man da weg. Naja, ich meine, gehst du in den Kaffee zweimal rein, wo dein Netz nicht geht? Ja, heutzutage nur hier.
Das sei denn, der Kaffee ist wirklich richtig gut.
Ja, ich meine, aber nur gut Kaffee machen oder Getränke mixen reicht heute nicht mehr. Du musst schon noch ein bisschen mehr bieten.
Stimmt.
Und das mit dem Netz genauso. Also bisher bin ich überall durchgekommen, also auch, ja.
Es gibt schon wirklich haarsträubend.
Bestimmt.
Furchtbare Blocker, also volles Programm. Da kommt man sich echt vor wie in China.
Ja, da sind so Läden, da gehe ich dann nicht mehr hin. Das war irgendwie so, Kaffees wurde dann, dich hinsetzt, ist dein Kuchen, ist auch voll lecker. Im Rubens ist das, im Mehringdamm, da ist ein Laden Rubens. Kennst du den? Nein. Da gibt es lecker Kuchen, die haben richtig guten Kuchen. Aber wenn du da WLAN haben willst, dann sagen sie, klar haben wir. Und dann klickst du so und dann kommt da auch hier so ein Portal-Capture-Tralala-Webseite, dann bleibt da schon der Kuchen im Hals stecken. Aber der Kuchen ist wirklich lecker.
Kannst du dir den Kuchen holen und dann nicht mit LTE einfach in Parknähm ansetzen?
Ja, könnte klappen wahrscheinlich. Genau, da hat jemand gerade auch noch was gepostet hier. Das ist höchstwahrscheinlich, nehme ich mal an. Ich habe es letztens gelesen, das ist nämlich die Ankündigung aus dem Juli, dass die schon gesagt haben, der Apple-Developer hier testet mal unser iQ-Version 2. Stimmt es? Das ist doch bestimmt diese Mail. Ich sehe die jetzt nicht mehr, aber ich bin jetzt erst gerade wieder rein.
Sag IK-E. IK-E. Sag IK-E.
IK-E V2. Funktioniert auf jeden Fall super. Funktioniert so super, dass der VPN-Tunnel so lange oben bleibt, dass mein Telefon über die Nacht leergesaugt ist, weil der scheint das die ganze Zeit anzubehalten. Da habe ich erst mal gedacht, von wegen hält länger jetzt das iOS 9, das hält eher kürzer. Aber jetzt habe ich es mal ausgelassen und jetzt merke ich irgendwie, ich habe jetzt 60 Prozent und das Ding ist seit ca. 24 Stunden an.
Kannst du mir eine Count machen auf deiner Büchse?
Aber ich glaube, bei dir hätte ich ein Problem, weil du saugst dann irgendwie die so leer, dass ich dann eine Provider-Rechnung kriege. Was?
Na einmal seine 300 Podcasts auf einmal runter, da liegt der Gigabit am Anschlag.
Ich will das hier nicht in der Metaebene anschalten, sondern ich will halt, wenn ich halt in Not bin.
Also für dein Telefon kann ich dir das machen, ja.
Ja, wenn ich so ein Netzflüchtling bin, dann...
So ein Refugee meinst du, ist ja ein Hype-Gring gerade zu helfen.
Und dann lädt er aber auf seinem Telefon erstmal 64 GB.
Ja, das sehe ich in meinen Statistiken.
Ja, wie so was hast du nicht Flatrate, oder was?
Doch, ich habe Flatrate 0 Euro. Und wenn das aber nicht flat bleibt, sondern mountainmäßig aussieht, dann kommt die Rechnung.
Das ist nur für den Notfall, wenn ich irgendwo...
Und?
Was kommt jetzt?
Bei iOS 8 war so ein Fehler. Die konnten einen IP-Stack, die haben da irgendwas falsch gemacht. Die hätten irgendwie eine IPv6-Adresse, hätten sie sozusagen 16 FFs liefern müssen. Und sie haben aber FF00, FF00 geliefert, weil irgendwie was auch immer die da falsch gekodet haben. Jedenfalls ging das nicht. Jetzt haben sie es in 8.4.1, glaube ich, hatten sie es gefixt. Das heißt, du kriegst auch gleich IPv6 über diesen Tunnel.
Und kannst du mir die Konfiguration als einzelne Datei schicken? Genau. Und ich klicke da nur drauf, und dann ist das konfiguriert und alles läuft?
Na, wahrscheinlich sogar noch viel besser. Ich schicke das nicht mal als Datei, sondern du trägst das jetzt bei dir ein.
Na, ich will ja nicht was eintragen.
Ich kann dir das auch als Datei schicken. Willst du mit On-Demand oder ohne?
On-Demand?
Na, On-Demand heißt, du kannst hier auf On-Demand stellen und der kommt immer wieder hoch, solange er kann. Also das ist einfach immer.
Ach so, nicht immer, sondern ich will es halt aktivieren.
Du kannst es auch ausschalten. Dann sagst du einfach nur Connect. Aber du kannst es hier auch reingehen und einschalten. Und das heißt, wenn demnächst Netz binden, dann wird automatisch dieser hochgefahren. Zack.
Nehme ich also. So, so full Monty.
Alles klar, kriegste.
Gerne wieder. Top VPNer, gerne wieder.
Top E-Bayer. Fertig mit VPN? Ich habe ja noch ein lustiges Thema.
V6 ist dabei, geht alles jetzt genau? Ne, das war's mit dem Krypto eigentlich.
Ich habe vielleicht nur aus der Abteilung kleine Tools. Erstens gibt es jetzt wieder Netnewswire. Das ist jetzt nach ewiger Beta-Phase in Version 4.0.
Von dem gleichen Typen immer noch?
Ne, das ist ein neues Team. Das hat irgendwie auch ewig gedauert. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, warum. Ich hatte das auch schon gar nicht mehr verfolgt. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich hatte die Hoffnung auch schon aufgegeben. Das Problem ist, dass diese Abwesenheit von Netnewswire, das Programm war ja irgendwie dysfunktional, weil diese Syncing-Infrastruktur von dieser Einbude, die das mal gekauft hat, die war dann halt irgendwie weg. Und irgendwie konnte man das halt nicht mehr so richtig benutzen. Und Google Reader gab es ja dann auch nicht mehr. Dann gab es halt sozusagen kein Syncing-Ding.
Dann gingen viele nicht mehr.
Und dann gab es halt so komische Syncing-Dienste, so eine ganze Latte. Und da habe ich auch mal so ein paar. Und das war mir ehrlich gesagt immer viel zu bekloppt. Und damit habe ich dann aufgehört, RSS zu benutzen. Und jetzt fange ich wieder an, meine Feats zusammenzusuchen. Weil es gibt jetzt Netnews, das kostet irgendwie ein Zehner, und das synkt halt einfach mal innerhalb der App. Da habe ich jetzt nicht so ein großes webbasiertes Dienstleister, in dem ich regelmäßig viel Geld zahlen muss, Backends, sondern ich kaufe halt die App und die synkt einfach. Und das funktioniert. Und das funktioniert auch auf iOS und das funktioniert auf Mac. Und das funktioniert so, wie ich das gewohnt bin von Netnews, weil es hat, glaube ich, nicht alle Features, die früher drin waren. Die haben das Ding ziemlich zusammengestrichen, damit sie da clean und fresh für sozusagen die aktuelle Ausrüstung, die die Betriebssysteme so mit sich bringen, da gut aufgestellt sind. Und ja, soweit ich das benutze, kann ich sagen, hat das irgendwie funktioniert. Und jetzt benutze ich RSS wieder, weil ehrlich gesagt, kein RSS...
Ist auch keine Lösung.
Also das kann man, das geht wirklich nicht. Also das fand ich sehr interessant. Also dieses Ganze, ich beziehe meinen Scheiß nur noch aus Twitter oder irgendwie sowas, das ist einfach unseriös.
Ich habe ja kürzlich auch mich mal interessiert, wie viele Leute eigentlich noch RSS benutzen. Hab ja immer auf Twitter gefragt, wer von euch benutzt eigentlich noch so RSS? Und da kam ja tatsächlich, also ich hatte so das Gefühl, alle, die sich von dieser Frage angesprochen fühlen, also es war, ich würde sagen, 99% der Antworten war ja, ich benutze RSS. Und die haben dann auch alle verschiedenste Lösungen mir getwittert, irgendwie verschiedenste Self-Hosting-Lösungen quasi, wo du dein eigenes Google-Reader-Derivat quasi dir selber aufsetzen kannst. Oder eben sowas wie Reader. Net News Wire hat jetzt keiner tatsächlich auf dem Plan, weil es wahrscheinlich keiner wusste, dass es das wieder gibt. Aber ja, da war ich auch tatsächlich sehr überrascht, weil letztendlich genau das halt, wenn man halt irgendwie einen Kanal hat, der eben nicht Twitter oder so ist und ein bisschen mehr Infos hat, wie ein Blog zum Beispiel, dann ist das schon wichtig, dass man weiß, dass die Leute das auch noch subscribieren und auch noch benutzen und das auch noch einen Kanal ist. Man nicht irgendwie gleich als erstes in seinem WordPress, als Facebook, als Twitter und was es nicht noch alles für Social-Media-Plugins gibt, die das dann irgendwie überall rauströten und alle Leute damit nerven, sondern bei RSS ist ja auch so das entspannte, du machst so dein Tool auf und jetzt willst du es halt auch sehen.
Und du kriegst vor allem auch alles, jeden Scheiß und Gedöns, irgendwie in RSS rausgedrückt. Und was auch immer es ist, dem du folgen willst, ob das irgendwelche Kommentare in irgendeinem absurden Artikel sind oder Podcast-Feeds oder was auch immer, man kann damit alles wunderbar debanken. Das ist für mich zum Beispiel auch so ein Tool. Ich tue da meine Podcast-Feeds noch mal rein. Einfach um schnell zu sehen, dass die sich auch aktualisieren, wenn was rausgekommen ist. Oder dass ich den Kommentaren noch mal anders folgen kann als die ganze Zeit nur über Mail oder so. Und das ist einfach unsäglich praktisch. Und NetNews ist ja das Programm, was eigentlich die Popularität von RSS auf dem Mac und damit eigentlich auch überhaupt im Netz überhaupt erst so richtig losgetreten hat. Und ja, jetzt ist es wieder da. Und sie haben es nicht komplett verkackt.
Ja, ich muss mal gucken, weil ich habe auch gesehen, also ich habe ja dann...
Also ich habe es mir auch geklickt und bin bis jetzt ganz zufrieden damit. Aber ich habe noch nicht richtig angefangen zu lesen.
Nee, man muss auch nicht unbedingt immer alles lesen. Aber manches liest sich damit einfach besser.
Aber zum Thema RSS, es gibt ja auch...
Darf ich noch ganz kurz eine Sache sagen, weil du mir gerade schon... Du bist ja gerade quasi von der Seite reingegreetscht. Roddy, du alter Grätscher. Die andere App, die ich ja auch lange Zeit benutzt habe, bei Reader, die war ja auch irgendwie so komisch zwischendurch versynkt und dann nur noch online und so weiter.
Die konnte man nicht selber synken. Die konnte nur auf Reader benutzen. Und dann hat sie halt auf die ganzen anderen Backends. Aber ich weiß nicht, wo Reader hat. Dieses Reader hat bei mir noch nie eingeschlagen.
Ich fand es eine Zeit lang echt ganz gut. Da gibt es bestimmt auch ein paar Meterebene Folgen dazu, wo ich davon schwärme. Ich werde es jetzt mal mit Net News Wire Battle testen. Weil von denen scheint es auch immer noch eine aktuelle Version zu geben. Und das kam zumindest ein paar Mal auch an den Responses. Also nächste Ausgabe, Net News Wire vs. Reader.
Ich habe Reader auf dem iPad relativ viel verwendet, bis es dann endlich brach. Und die Version 2 mir dann aber irgendwie, das hat es dann nicht so richtig gebracht. Ne, so ein bisschen anderes Thema, aber es passt ganz gut rein, weil RSS Feed, es gibt ja nicht nur News oder Blogs und Podcasts. Man kann ja auch noch ganz andere Sachen über RSS abonnieren.
Nein.
Und zwar gibt es ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange schon, gibt es irgendwie von Berlin so eine Open-Data-Site, wo relativ viele Daten als RSS Feed gepublished werden. Unter anderem gibt es seit einiger Zeit die VBB-Fahrplandaten als RSS Feed in diesem GTFS-Format.
Hatte man die Fahrplandaten, kommt da immer ein Update, wenn irgendeine Straßenbahn irgendwo hält oder was?
Es gibt eher unregelmäßig, aber es gibt Updates. Also immer, wenn es ein Update für den Fahrplan gibt, dann machen die nochmal ein komplettes Datenbank-Dump. Und das ist relativ heftig, weil es sind nur CSV-Dateien. Ich habe mich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, dass lustig ist, es gibt ja tatsächlich irgendwie einen Standard zum Thema CSV-Dateien. Da wird einem anders, wenn man das liest, weil halt Dinge in Dingen drin sein können, die nochmal in Dingen drin sind. Also, naja, im Prinzip hast du Felder, die mit Kommas getrennt sind, aber das Feld an sich kann...
Kommata oder Semikoli.
Kommata.
Wirklich.
Ja, naja.
Und dann mit Anführungsstrichen und...
Genau, mit Anführungsstrichen, dann kann eben String in der Anführungsstrichen wieder ein Komma drin sein und so weiter. Da einen robusten Parser für zu schreiben, ist nicht ganz trivial. Aber sei es drum. Also, dieses GTFS-Format ist relativ witzig. Also Google hat da wirklich ganze Arbeit geleistet. Aber wenn man sich einfach mal anguckt, also die Tabelle über alle Haltestellen, Stops in Berlin, die ist halt mal 190 Megabyte groß. 190 Megabyte CSV-Datei, da gehen die meisten Tools dann noch so langsam ans Ende irgendwie. Also, das ist wirklich spannend. Und wenn man sich dann so anguckt, wie dieses Format funktioniert, was da so alles drinsteht in dieser Datei, dann weißt du auch, warum irgendwie in dem Apple Maps von iOS 9 der öffentliche Nahverkehr so aussieht, wie er aussieht. Das sind nämlich genau die Daten.
Ah, und deswegen ist die M10 da auch nicht drin.
Die M10?
Ja, die M10, die ja hier direkt an der Metaebene vorbei fährt, die fährt ja jetzt bis zum Hauptbahnhof und das scheint bei Apple noch nicht durchgedrungen zu sein.
Die ist ja auch ganz neu. Ja, das ist ja auch ein paar Monate schon wieder her, aber...
Das ist jetzt zwei, drei Wochen her, aber das... Ich meine, die releasen jetzt. Wenn die jetzt releasen...
Ja, aber die Daten sind ja nicht von jetzt, dann haben die die schon eine Weile.
Also die letzten Daten sind von August, die die hier veröffentlicht haben. Geil.
Das heißt, ich kann es nicht benutzen.
Ja, die haben sowieso ein paar Probleme. Wirklich? Und zwar gibt es halt so eine Tabelle, die heißt Kalender. Und da steht so drin, wann welche Routen bzw. also welche Linien wann fahren. Und in der großen Tabelle, das ist halt von Montags bis Sonntags, gibt es halt jeweils ein Feld. Da steht eine 1 drin, wenn an dem Wochentag gefahren wird, und eine 0, wenn an dem Wochentag nicht gefahren wird. Und diese gesamte Tabelle hat an allen Wochentagen eine 0. Also laut dieser Tabelle fährt in Berlin gar nichts, wenn man diesen Daten traut. Also es ist total absurd, was die da machen. Der Rest scheint einigermaßen okay zu sein, aber... Wir werden es sehen.
Ich habe dir mal so ein Konfig-Ding gesendet.
Hauptsache, du hast noch ein paar Links für mich, damit ich das auch irgendwie gut verschonen unten kann.
Ich habe übrigens mir während der Sendung hier ganz frech mal einen Content-Blocker installiert. Weil da gibt es nämlich jetzt welche, seit heute gibt es die im Store. Das Prinzip ist, dass man sich eine App installieren muss, weil sie wahrscheinlich kein Konzept für Content-Blocker hatten. Deswegen ist das immer eine App.
Sie haben da ein Konzept für, das heißt, Extention und das muss halt an einer App dran sein.
Ja, aber da hast du halt rote Apps überall rumliegen.
Na, weiß nicht, die können ja auch in ihrem App-Frontend eine Konfiguration für sich selber zum Beispiel bieten. Weiß nicht, ob sie das tun, aber...
Na ja, man macht sich da wahrscheinlich in eine Gruppe oder irgendwie so, wo man die Dinge alle reinschmeißt. Jedenfalls habe ich mir Crystal runterladen, weil Crystal kostet nämlich kein Geld. Crystal macht es umsonst.
Das muss geil sein dann, ne?
Umsonst?
Crystal macht es umsonst.
Jedenfalls darf Crystal dann einfach die Settings öffnen, bei Safari reingehen, Content-Blockers anklicken und Crystal enablen und Crystal tut jetzt. Und ich weiß nicht, ich habe jetzt mal Heise genommen. Bei Heise kommt bei mir keine Werbung. Ich weiß aber nicht, wie es vorher war. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern. Kommt da bei euch Werbung? Ich habe hier eine schöne lange Liste, die ich runterscrolle, wo keine Werbung drin ist.
Wonach muss man denn hier suchen, damit man das überhaupt findet?
Wo bist du denn überhaupt?
Ich kriege hier nur Games. Im App-Store?
Man muss nach Content-Blockers suchen.
Das ist bestimmt die populärste Programm-Kategorie der nächsten Wochen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich, ja.
Und danach interessiert es niemanden mehr.
Es wird sich auch noch ärgern, dass er kein Geld genommen hat. Obwohl, da steht ja schon da, dass er es zukünftig tun will. Aber installiert ihn schnell jetzt, weil irgendwann nimmt er Geld.
Oh Gott, ein Euro vielleicht oder zwei Euro.
Nee, ich habe schon welche mit vier gesehen.
Vier Euro!
Als wäre den Leuten das wert, wenn sie keine Werbung mehr kriegen.
Mir ist das auch zehn Euro wert. Die Frage ist, ob es ordentlich funktioniert. Mal gucken. Es gibt auch schon erste Listen. Da gibt es irgendwie OneBlocker und Pipapo, alles Mögliche. Keine Ahnung, was davon jetzt am meisten taugt. Das werden wir dann feststellen. Aber schon mal gut, überhaupt irgendwas zu haben.
Was ich auf jeden Fall nicht empfehlen kann, und ihr könnt ja die Geschichte dazu selber nochmal durch googeln, lesen, machen, tun, ist AdBlock Plus benutzen. Ich habe die jetzt auch noch hier nicht gefunden, aber deren Geschäftspraktiken sind sehr fragwürdig. Und deswegen, die machen wohl auch ein, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Also von dem kann ich nur abraten.
Was sind denn deren Geschäftspraktiken?
Na, sie zeigen keine Werbung an, außer, wie nennen sie das? Akzeptierte Werbung, wie war das? Nicht nervende Werbung oder so?
Außer der Werbung, für die sie bezahlt werden, dass sie sie anzeigen und die angeblich nicht mehr. Das heißt, die haben da sozusagen noch mal eine eigene White List. Und dann kommen halt so Google Text Ads und so ein Kram halt durch. Und das ist im Prinzip, bauen sie sich sozusagen noch mal ihren eigenen, ja, eigenen Wegezoll sozusagen.
Das heißt, die Firma, die Werbung schaltet, muss nicht nur die Werbung bezahlen, sondern müssen sie dann auch noch mal bei AdBlock Plus bezahlen, damit die Werbung auch durchkommt. Also, nee, außerdem will man ja alle Werbung weghaben und nicht nur ein bisschen. Ist zwar schade für viele Seiten, wenn die nichts mehr verdienen, aber ja, sorry. Naja, ich lese schon auch viel Heise und das ist schon deren einziges Werbe, also die verdienen ihr Geld ja nur mit mit Werbung dann, aber naja, dann liest du danach halt keine Heise mehr, weil es gibt ja dann keine Heise mehr, ne? Kommt wer anders, der seine Brötchen anders verdient vielleicht.
Ja, aber das ist natürlich die Chance für die App-Entwickler, weil du kannst halt in Apps keine Werbung blockieren.
Ja gut, aber doch, kann aber die App deinstallieren, wenn da zu viel Werbung kommt und die mich nervt.
Ja gut, aber du kannst auch auf eine Webseite nicht gehen, wenn zu viel Werbung kommt und sie dich nervt. Das ist dann das Gleiche. Nein, ich denke, dass die Web-Leute da diese Gefahr noch gar nicht so richtig auf dem Schirm haben, dass ihr offenes Web durch genau solche Sachen halt in Gefahr ist.
Also zum Beispiel Spiegel macht es ja ganz schlau, auch wenn wir jetzt gerade beim Werbe-Adblock-Dings-Thema. Bei diesen Spiegel-Movies, da guckst du 10 Minuten oder so, je nachdem, wie lang das Filmchen ist. Und die wollen ja unbedingt, die machen ja ganz viele Movies und so. Und dann kommt mittendrin, nach 10 Minuten, kommt so diese Werbepause. Die am Anfang, die er trage ich ja noch einmal. Aber dann kommt eine mittendrin. Und ich glaube, es dauert immer keine 3 Sekunden. Ich schließe einfach immer schon reflexartig das ganze Fenster. Weil da kommt ja dann eventuell auch irgendwie wieder was gequatscht und so. Das will ich gar nicht hören. Ich habe noch nie an diesem Werbeblock vorbei gesehen. Ich gucke immer nur die ersten 10 Minuten, dann fällt es mir an der Scheiße. Das war es ja. Bumm, weg ist es. Also keine Chance.
Tja, also bezahlen willst du nicht?
Nee.
Werbung gucken willst du nicht?
Ich bezahle wahrscheinlich für gute Werbefilter. Das ist Markt, Jungs.
Aber die schreiben halt da nicht die Artikel, das ist das Problem.
Vielleicht sollten die bei Heise ihren eigenen Werbefilter schreiben. Wahrscheinlich verdienen sie mehr damit.
Ja, nee, ich meine, das ist generell natürlich das Problem von dieser ganzen Branche, dass da, also ich weiß nicht, wenn du zum Guardian gehst oder wem auch immer und deinen Adblocker an hast, dann blenden sie dir ein. Ja, hallo, guten Tag. Ist ja schön, dass du jetzt keine Werbung willst und kann man auch verstehen. Aber du kommst ja vorbei, offensichtlich, um hier Content abzusaugen. Also überleg doch mal, ob du nicht vielleicht hier so Mitglied wirst oder so, oder irgendwie auch so jahresmäßig irgendwas überweist, wie halt früher ein Zeitungsabo, ne? Aber ich denke mal, dass die Conversion-Rate da vergleichsweise gering sein wird. Aber ich hab bis jetzt auch noch keine richtig gute Lösung für dieses Problem gefunden. Eigentlich war nicht dieses Apple-News-Stand irgendwie, ne, das war nicht eine Lösung dafür, ne? Dass das da alles irgendwie so, also eigentlich, wenn man ja da, was ja schon oftmals hier so als Kultur-Flatrate oder so, oder Flatter-Modelle, was auch immer.
Das haben wir doch schon, der SG.
Du bezahlst halt für irgendwie an einer Stelle und dann, egal, wo du klickst, wird das dann halt irgendwie schön verwertet. Aber das ist auch alles schon seit Jahren Fantasiemusik.
Wieso, die heißt GEZ, die zahlen wir schon seit Jahren.
Ja, nicht mehr für Zeitungsartikel.
Zu viel Geld, wie da da gerade übrig ist, wenn man sich ZDF und ARD anguckt, was die jetzt da nachverlangen, weil plötzlich viel Geld da ist, könnten sie das gleich mitfinanzieren.
Also ich glaub, zu jedem heiße Online-Journalisten, der jetzt dir zugehört hat, die letzten fünf Minuten, die rollen sich nicht nur die Fußnägel hoch, sondern die Bohnen drauf. Die fragen sich auch, ist das der neue FIFA?
Jetzt mal über der Gürtellinie bleiben, ja?
Jetzt haben wir gleich mehrere Fässer auf einmal aufgemacht. Nämlich das eine, was bedeutet sozusagen, das Aufkommen von, uns ist ja allen klar, iOS, Content-Blocker, das wird was ändern. Ich glaube, nicht nur die Ladezeiten, die auf jeden Fall auch, aber auf jeden Fall auch so diese ganzen Page Impressions und Ad-Views und was auch immer, die jetzt gerade für Metriken da haben, da wird einfach mal...
Vor allem haben die jetzt ja gerade gedacht, alles klar im mobilen Bereich, da müssen wir jetzt Werbung platzieren, weil die Leute sind jetzt alle mobil unterwegs. Und bumm, was passiert, bang, wird die Lücke dicht gemacht.
Genau.
Und ich meine, es ging schon los. Du konntest ja den Content auf dem iPhone kaum noch erkennen. Von oben war irgendwie der dicke Balken, der dir irgendwie das Menü anzeigt. Von unten wurde schon die Werbung hochgeschoben und dann noch ein Pop-Up drüber, den du erstmal irgendwie wegklicken musstest, wenn du es geschafft hast, damit du deinen eigentlichen Content siehst. Also es war ja in den letzten Monaten kaum noch zu vertragen, was die da an den Start bringen.
Ja, das ist auch wirklich ein Gebaren. Das geht halt einfach gar nicht. Das ist wirklich so, als ob da irgendwie jemand an deiner Tür klingelt und bevor du überhaupt irgendwie den Mund aufmachen kannst, ziehen sie dir die Hose runter und drücken dir die Eier. Also das ist einfach invasiv. Und so geht es halt nicht. Aber es geht halt sicherlich auch nicht komplett nur mit solchen Subscription-Modellen, weil du an der Stelle noch sehr viel verstärkter diesen Plattform-Effekt hast. Jetzt haben wir vor ein paar Tagen, hat ja hier so ein neuer Dienst angefangen hier, mit diesem unsäglichen Namen Blendle. Ja, die heißen Blendle.
Blendle?
Sie meinen wahrscheinlich, dass sie Blendl heißen, aber ich lese halt Blendle. Ist aber nicht aus dem Blendle, sondern ist da, wo es keine Berge hat. Da kommt die her. Aus Holland, aus den Niederlands. Und die haben da wohl einen gewissen Erfolg. Und das ist halt auch wieder so ein Ding, so ja, hier, wir haben jetzt alle Zeitungsartikel. Die haben halt irgendwie einen Großteil der deutschen Verleger jetzt auch wohl ins Boot bekommen, von Spiegel bis alles aus der Bild. Und das läuft dann irgendwie so, du kriegst halt dann so einen Link auf den Artikel, der dann halt in der Blendle-Wolke ist. Und um den lesen zu können, musst du ihn kaufen, aber du kaufst ihn halt mit so Mikro-Beträgen. Aber du kaufst jeden Artikel. Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, was so die durchschnittlichen Preise sind, das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber irgendwie niedrig halt. Und du hast halt da einen Account mit Kohle drauf, und das wird halt von deinem Account runter gedingst. Wenn du jetzt auf so einen Link klickst und du hast noch keinen Blendle-Account oder du bist nicht eingeloggt, dann wirst du halt auf diese Webseite geworfen und ohne dass du diesen Artikel siehst, musst du dich halt erstmal einloggen oder registrieren und lalala. Wenn du aber schon eingeloggt bist und du hast Kohle auf deinem Account und du klickst auf diesen Link, der zu diesem Artikel führt, dann kriegst du sofort den Artikel und hast ihn damit auch sofort gekauft. Cent-Bereiche, ich habe nicht genug Aufmerksamkeit auf das Modell. Ich habe es auch nicht wirklich ausprobiert, aber so habe ich es wahrgenommen. Soweit so gut, das heißt, die versuchen da halt quasi wieder eine Plattform zu sein für den Content, was ja Facebook jetzt auch probiert, was Apple in gewisser Hinsicht auch probiert, mit anderen Zielen. Weil Apple halt da keine Werbung gibt es dann bei den anderen auch nicht. Aber Apple stellt ja dann auch die ganze Lese-Software zur Verfügung. Und die Frage ist, was ist jetzt eigentlich das Modell? Ist es Micropayment, das du wirklich für jeden Artikel irgendwie zahlst und zwar vorher? Ohne so einen Flatrate-Aspekt wie bei Flatter, den es da halt nicht gibt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass du da so ein gewisses Kontingent bezahlst. Und dann hast du okay, ich gebe 10 Euro im Monat aus und dafür alles, was bei 3 nicht auf den Bäumen ist. Wäre ja auch mal ein interessanter Ansatz, wie ich finde. Ja, genau. Also diese ganzen Flatrate Modelle, ich meine im Prinzip wurden die ja auch immer gefordert. Jetzt sind sie ja irgendwie da und so richtig froh bin ich damit auch nicht. Podcastbereich werden das sicherlich jetzt demnächst auch einige probieren, so All-You-Can-Eat-Angebote zu machen. Mal sehen, wie das so kommt. Auf jeden Fall kriegt man ja die Tür nicht zu. Also es kloppt ja am laufenden Meter irgendjemand an gerade.
Bei mir nicht.
Habe ich ja schon geschrieben, Kabelnetz-Verticker, die Drücker des 21. Jahrhunderts.
Ja, ich meine jetzt so konkret Anfragen an Podcaster, ob man denn nicht an ihren tollen Netzwerken und Plattformen mit uns berühmt und mächtig werden und so. Nein, die haben da schon Ideen, aber ich bin einfach generell gerade sehr vorsichtig, was diese Plattformen betrifft. Ich traue denen allen nicht über den Weg. Können mir erzählen, was sie wollen, aber so bisher überzeugt hat mich da noch gar nichts.
Dem Podcast Papst, dem macht man nicht so einfach vor.
Wie sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich da gerade hingekommen?
Ich habe mit Content-Blockern angefangen.
Ja, du warst bei Content-Blockern und genau, dann hast du sozusagen die Frage aufgeworfen, du willst halt irgendwie nichts bezahlen oder willst alles kostenlos haben?
Ja, wer nicht?
Da gibt es noch mehr Leute. Naja, ich bin durchaus bereit zu bezahlen. Die Frage ist, was ist das akzeptable Modell?
Genau, das Modell ist meistens der Problem und nicht der Preis.
Ja gut, naja, das ist natürlich auch Teil des Dings, weil die Kosten müssen natürlich den Aufwand auch in irgendeiner Form reflektieren und müssen am Ende dann eben auch für die Autoren oder Verlage oder beide auch, sagen wir mal, substanziell so viel abwerfen, dass es sich auch lohnt, so einen Vertriebsweg zu machen. Und in gewisser Hinsicht kann natürlich dieses Ausblenden dieses Webs, wo ja in gewisser Hinsicht noch Chancengleichheit besteht. Jeder kann mühelos eine Website aufsetzen und Werbung draufpacken. Aber die Teilnahme an diesen Plattformen ist meistens schon sehr viel verzerrter. Da bist du dann schon besser dran, wenn du groß bist und schlechter dran, wenn du klein bist. So, und dann, auf wie viele Plattformen soll ich denn dann eine Subscription halten, wenn ich jetzt also hier bei Blendle bin und jetzt der Meinung bin, ich muss den deutschen Nachrichtenwald über diese Plattformen abliefern und nur da zahle ich halt rein, dann ist sozusagen jetzt Blendle der Gatekeeper an der Stelle für diese Art Inhalte und nicht mehr die Webseiten selber. Was natürlich auch ein Aufwand ist, weil jede Webseite programmiert sich da wieder ein Hund und Zeit Online hat jetzt einen fetten Relaunch damit das auch alles mal mobil und responsiv und modern und schick und schnell ladend ist. Das nimmt ja auch alles enorme Kosten. Kein Wunder, dass die alle jetzt zu Facebook rennen oder eben zu solchen Plattformen und sagen, ja hier, Content, das ist eigentlich das, was wir machen wollen, publiziert ihr mal, nehmt ihr mal das Geld für mich ein, alles fertig. So wie iTunes Musik verkauft und dafür die Kohle einnimmt und weiter verteilt. Ist ja auch alles irgendwie nachvollziehbar. So, aber es könnte sozusagen sein, dass jetzt eben dieses Werbemodell im Web damit auch gescheitert ist, dass alle Leute so angekotzt sind und jetzt eben sagen, mit Content blockern Schluss.
Ja, interessant fand ich, den Link finde ich jetzt ähnlich auf die Schnelle, aber da hatte jemand einen Artikel geschrieben und hat das Modell der Verlage, der klassischen Printverlage, damit verglichen, dass du im Supermarkt nur Präsentkörbe bekommst. Und wenn du einen Liter Milch haben willst, dann musst du halt noch die Wurst und die Butter und die Eier mit dazu nehmen, weil es gibt halt nur den Präsentkorb. Und wie halt der Print eigentlich immer darüber gelebt hat, dass er halt ganz viel Kram gebandelt hat, von dem dich irgendwie 80% eigentlich nicht interessiert hat.
Fernsehen ja auch quasi, ne?
Fernsehen ja auch quasi, ja. Und dass das halt jetzt ein Ende hat und nur die best laufenden Artikel dann tatsächlich Geld abwerfen, fand ich auch einen interessanten Aspekt, besonders diesen Vergleich zum Präsentkorb.
Aber was ja das Blöde ist, wenn nur der Geld regiert, dann werden halt vielleicht die unpopulären Themen auch gar nicht mehr betrachtet. Die aber halt auch manchmal sein müssen. Also so eine gewisse Unabhängigkeit jetzt vom Euro direkt auf, also ist ja dann auch vielleicht gar nicht schlecht.
Jaja, das ist ja richtig. Hier ist es halt nur nicht vom Kunden aus gedacht. Also ich meine, in heutigen Webseiten sehen es halt kaum noch jemand ein, warum er jetzt irgendwie ein Gesamtmachwerk teuer erstehen muss, wenn er nur einen Artikel lesen will.
Ich würde ja mal interessieren, wieviel die an meiner Werbung verdienen, die ich, sagen wir mal, bei Heise, um da zu bleiben, am Monat durchklicke. Wie viel ein Klick wert ist oder die ganzen Werbung-Dinger, die da ist und was das theoretisch, ja eben. Und wenn aber da so ein Abo-Modell oder was auch immer abschließt, dann zahlst du nicht diese Bruchteile, dann zahlst du ein deutliches Vielfaches davon.
Was ich ja, wie gesagt, mal ganz cool fand, ist ja, was die OkCupid-Leute gemacht haben. Die haben ja immer so ein geiles Blog, wo sie so auch mal so über ihre Daten und so weiter. Und die haben ja Folgendes gemacht, die haben...
Also OkCupid ist diese Online-Ding.
Genau, die aber offensichtlich von Nerds betrieben wird, weil die sind einfach so die Blog-Posts und alles, was die machen, ist einfach sehr cool. Und die haben halt Werbe... Also wenn du mit einem Werbeblocker da rauf gehst, dann blenden sie dir einen Banner ein und sagen quasi, ja, hier, Werbebanner, gut und schön. Verstehen wir auch, dass er das nicht wollt. Jetzt haben wir mal ausgerechnet, was unser Lifetime-Value von unserer Userbase ist und im Durchschnitt kriegen wir von einem User 5 Dollar in der gesamten Lebensdauer. Also das ist so das Maximum, Lifetime-Value. Das heißt, dann haben sie so in das Banner reingeschrieben, wenn du uns jetzt einmal 5 Dollar überweist, hast du quasi deinen Dienst an deinem Lifetime-Value für unsere Plattformen getan. Wir zeigen dir nie wieder ein Banner und lassen dich auch noch ansonsten in Ruhe. Und das ist halt irgendwie so eine Ansage, wo ich so dachte, okay, wenn du mit so einer Transparenz da dran gehst und sagst, pass auf, hier, das ist der Lifetime-Value, wenn du jetzt einfach einmal uns sozusagen den Servicebetrieb ermöglichen willst und du willst ihn ja auch weiter nutzen, auch gerne kostenlos sozusagen, gibst du einmal dein Lifetime-Value hier ab und dann lassen wir dich in Ruhe und du hast auch keine blinke Banner mehr. Und das fand ich eigentlich irgendwie auch...
Hier, da klick mal, da hat jemand den Banner.
Klick mal da drauf. Das fand ich halt irgendwie echt auch sehr korrekt. Und ich hab den, genau, das ist halt auch, das ist so ein Banner, da denkst du halt auch die ersten paar Male, ist jetzt der Edblocker kaputt oder so, da findet er das nicht raus und irgendwann fängst du es doch mal anzulesen und denkst du, ah, okay, korrekte Ansage.
Ja, irgendwie so was muss es sein.
Na und wenn jetzt halt irgendwie zeit.de dahingehme und sagt, so jetzt, also unser Lifetime-Value ist 123 Dollar.
Ich weiß nicht, was der Lifetime-Value ist. Das stimmt ein bisschen mehr, ne? Die haben wahrscheinlich sehr viele User bei OkCupid. Wenn die wirklich alle 5 Euro überweisen, dann sind die wahrscheinlich durch. Na ja, siehst du mal, wie viel Kohl das irgendwie kostet.
Ja, wir sagten, einer im Chat, er will nach Hause. Ich wollte auch gerade schon sagen, es ist nach Mitternacht. Ich bin schon müde angereist und morgen ist auch wieder hartet. Ich laufe hier, ich zerschmelze hier schon auf diesem Stuhl.
Ja, na ja, okay, dann würde ich sagen, dann hebe ich mir das lustige Besprechungsthema, wo ich der Meinung bin, auf so bestimmt eine halbe Stunde schon lustig darüber quatschen kann fürs nächste Mal auf.
Ja, bitte sehr gerne, wenn dann wieder frisch alles am Start ist, wobei natürlich so total ausgefahren, da entstehen ja auch noch die besten Sendungsteile. Wenn da Röhrensättigungen schon sind, dann...
Du hast schon recht, das ist grinswertig. Ja, dann können wir ja mal... Haben wir noch irgendwas anzukündigen? Vielleicht noch zwei Kleinigkeiten? Also erst mal... Du hast drei Minuten. Danke an Arno, der hier ein bisschen geholfen hat, den Wiedereinschluss der Meda-Ebene an das Internet zu befördern. Und danke auch natürlich an alle, die hier immer fleißig zuhören, spenden und interessante Dinge... Ach ja, warte mal. Post? War da nicht was?
Na, wo ist sie?
Na ja, wir haben Bier zugeschickt bekommen. Was sagst du jetzt? Sorry, ich weiß nicht, ich bin heute später zugekommen. Ich lese das jetzt einfach noch mal vor. Also ich weiß, das ist jetzt der vollkommen falsche Zeitpunkt. Aber das nächste Mal ist vielleicht... Ne, Roddy, du machst das mal hier gucken.
Ich mach das mal.
Ja genau, und das Bier, das müsstest du aber eigentlich auch schon entdeckt haben. Ich wundere, dass du das nicht gleich extrahiert hast, weil das liegt da sozusagen im Kühlschrank.
Also uns schreibt die Wiesbadener Braumanfaktur. Hallo, alle fünf Namen. Ich sag dir jetzt nicht alle einzeln. Als langjähriger Hörer der Freak Show aka Mobile Max und diverse andere Publikationen aus dem Hause Metaebene dachte ich mir, dass ich auch mal etwas für eure frische Versorgung in diesem Sommer tun kann. Als alter IT-Hase und leidenschaftlicher Braunerd habe ich Anfang des Jahres eine Brauerei gegründet und braue mit einem Kollegen abseits der Hightech-Pfade etwas ehrliches ganz ohne Beachballs oder Bluescreens, nämlich Bier. Ihr bekommt heute unsere erste Kreation, das Wiesbadener Pale Ale. Na komm dann hol doch mal eins her. Dann will ich das. Jetzt aber.
Ich hoffe, sie finden euch.
Weitere Sorten folgen in Kürze. Selbstverständlich werden diese auch den Weg zu euch finden. Ehrensache. Um mehr zu uns erfahren, gut, hier gibt's noch so ein paar Web, Twitter, Facebook und Instagram-Angaben. Danke für unzählige unterhaltsame Stunden und vielen Infos aus sämtlichen Themen.
Das Bier hat den Tisch voll gesaut.
Ja, ich halte das jetzt mal so, wie es da ist, weil es nämlich gerade noch nicht ins iPad reinläuft. Weiter so, schreibt er hier noch. Also ich glaube, es bezieht sich jetzt nicht da drauf, dass wir hierhin ein Biersee auf dem Tisch bilden.
Na, das ist doch jetzt das Willkommene Ende ein Umfall.
Ja, danke Holger.
Danke, ja.
Genau, es gab auch noch irgendwelche andere Posts, aber ich glaube, die habe ich noch nicht abgeholt. Das ist immer alles ein bisschen schwierig. Warum das auch alles mal am Mittwoch immer alles so zusammenkommt, ich weiß auch nicht. Na, das kann man trinken.
Und recht hopfig und recht säuerlich. Erinnert so ein bisschen an das Bog, die Bogweiße.
Na ja, am Ende lässt es sich auch darauf zurückführen, in irgendeiner Form. Äh, da war noch noch was, Moment. Genau. Da war noch was. Also Leute, das war's hier. 161, nicht die letzte. In zwei Wochen sind wir wieder da. Pünktlich und...
So pünktlich wie immer.
Genau.
Also sagen wir Tschüss, oder?
Danke, Michael.
Tschau, bis bald.
Verbreite deine Daten, CSV.